ALL RIGHT
I'M GOING TO CALL THIS A JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE TO ORDER THANK YOU
SO MUCH AMAZING GERMAN ONCE
AGAIN. FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE JOINED
US ON THIS IN NOVEMBER MORNING
A BIT LATE BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GET STARTED HERE NOW WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE IN IN
PARTICULAR. THE FORTY EIGHTH
ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER FISHERIES
FORM THIS IS A TIME HONORED
TRADITION HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BEFORE WE GET INTO
SOME OPENING REMARKS AND I'M
JOINED TODAY BY SENATOR WAY SO
FROM- THE GREAT COUNTY IS SEEN
DIEGO. WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE
SOME HOUSEKEEPING AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE ON HOW PUBLIC COMMENT AND-
HOW THE HEARING IT WILL BE
ROLLING FORWARD HERE REMOTELY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE TORS
EMPLOYEES WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TOO SOCIAL DISTANCING
SOME FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE- WITH THOSE
ORDERS THE SCENE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE GONNA BE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL AND ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS TODAY WILL BE JOINING
US. REMOTELY THEY'LL BE ZOOMING
IN HERE TODAY AND OF COURSE WE
HAVE A FEW FOLKS WHO WILL BE
WITH US HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE OF THE PUBLIC BUT THE
VAST MAJORITY FOLKS WILL BE
JOINING THIS COMMITTEE. ON LINE
NOW WE DO WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
AT THE END OF TODAY'S HEARING
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE AND PROVIDE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE'S THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER TO CALL TODAY. IT'S
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR- THAT PHONE
NUMBER ALONG WITH THE ACCESS
CODE IS NOW ON YOUR SCREEN IF
YOU LIKE TO PARTICIPATE. IN
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL WHICH WILL
BE AT THE END. OF TWO DAYS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING YOU CAN
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. TODAY WE
ARE NOT GONNA HAVE ANY MEMBERS
WILL BE JOINING US REMOTELY THE
ONLY MEMBER WHO IS HERE WITH US
ALONG WITH MYSELF. IS THAT
SENATOR WAY SO AND HE IS IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. IN THE
UNLIKELY EVENT THAT WE HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO INTERRUPTS
TODAY'S HEARING. WE ARE GOING
TO ASK THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. TO REMOVE
THEMSELVES IF THEY DO NOT
REMOVE HIMSELF BUT THEY MAY BE
REMOVED BY SENATE SERGEANT. AND
OR OUR REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
INDOOR HAVE YOUR CONNECTION.
MUTED IN WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE HEARING
PROCESS CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN
AS CLOSE AS MENTORS CUSTOMARY.
FOR ME MAYBE IF YOU LAG TIMES
TODAY NOT FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THEIR ONLINE
TOOL. SO AGAIN LAYS IN GERMAN
WE WELCOME YOU TO THIS TIME
HONORED TRADITION FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NASA FORTY EIGHT
THEN YOU'LL SEE GREATER
FISHERIES FORUM. HI MY NAME'S
MIKE MCGUIRE AND I'M HONORED
CHAIR THIS JOINT COMMITTEE
HERE- AND I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING TIME IN YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE TO BE ABLE TO JOIN
WITH US AND- WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE THAT SENATOR
HUESO. HAS JOINED US AS WELL
GOOD MORNING SENATOR AND WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM EAH OF THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. WITH
EVERYTHING IN LIFE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC LIFE IS DIFFERENT. AND
THE SAME CAN BE SAID FOR THE
FORTY EIGHTH ANNUAL FISHERIES
FORUM USUALLY AT THIS POINT IN
THE PROGRAM TO BE MY HONOR TO
BE TO THANK THE INCREDIBLE CREW
OF VOLUNTEERS IN. SEAFOOD
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK AT THE ANNUAL SEAFOOD
RECEPTION THAT WE HEAR. THAT WE
HOST TRADITIONALLY THE NIGHT
BEFORE THIS FORM- THAT SAID
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC WE
COULDN'T HOST THAT AMAZING
SHOWCASE OF GOLDEN STATE
SEAFOOD BROWNING SO HERE'S TO
HOPING IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO.
GATHER IN PERSON AGAIN AND
ENJOY ALL ASPECTS OF THAT
TRADITION. NONE THE LESS THE
SUM THIS MORNING WE ARE PLEASED
TO WELCOME ALL MEMBERS OF THE
FLEET IN FISHERY
REPRESENTATIVES AND COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS TUNING IN FROM EVERY
CALL OF THIS GREAT. TO
CALIFORNIA TODAY. FOR FORTY
EIGHT YEARS EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERY SPECIFIC
COMMITTEES ORGANIZATIONS.
ASSOCIATIONS COUNCILS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR FISHERMEN AND
WOMEN. ARE HERE TO BE TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THEIR NEEDS THEIR
GOALS. A YEARLY ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS YEAH THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT SINCE LAST YEAR'S
FISHERIES FORUM. OUR STATE'S
FISHERIES HAVE BEEN THROUGH A
LOT AND THAT IS TO SAY. IT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT NOT LONG AFTER
WE GATHERED IN MARCH THE FLEET
SCRAMBLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
FISHERIES WERE CLASSIFIED AS AN
ESSENTIAL INDUSTRY DURING
COLBERT. CONTINUED TO PROVIDE
FOR OUR CRITICAL FOOD SUPPLY.
AND THAT'S TO BE HONEST LAST
YEAR'S DUNGEONS CRAB SEASON. IT
WAS BLEAK OR IN THE MIDDLE OF A
DESTRUCTIVE AND COSTLY OIL
SPILL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND OF COURSE CATASTROPHIC
DROUGHT AND SIGNIFICANT WATER
OVER USE LED TO DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR OUR SALMON
FISHERIES. INTERSTATES IN NOW
OUR SEATS THE SEAFOOD INDUSTRY
MAY HAVE BENT. BUT IT DID NOT
BREAK. OUT TODAY IN SPITE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE WE'RE
GONNA LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE.
AND HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THE LONG TERM SUCCESS OF
THE FLEET. HOW WE CAN ENSURE
THE LONG TERM SURVIVAL OF
ENDANGERED SALMON SPECIES AND
HOW WE CAN INVEST IN THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES WHO. DEPEND
ON THRIVING FISHERIES FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOODS. IN THAT VEIN OVER
THE LAST YEAR WE'VE BEEN ACTIVE
ENGAGE OVER THE PAST YEAR WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FROM
THE DUNGEONS CRAB FLEET ALONG
WITH PROCESSORS WORKING WITH.
FISH AND WILDLIFE
REPRESENTATIVES ON SPECIFIC
REGULATORY CHALLENGES RELATED
TO THE DUNGEONS CAPTURING. I
WILL BE GETTING A FULL BRIEFING
TODAY ON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DUNGENESS CRAB SEASON. AS YOU
KNOW DUE TO THE PRESENCE OF
WHALES. THIS SEASON SOUTH OF
MENDOCINO COUNTY ALONG WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. IS
CURRENTLY DELAYED THAT AS A
DELAYED OPENING. AREAS SOUTH OF
MONTEREY IS SCHEDULED TO OPEN
ON NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH.
EVERYTHING NORTH AND MENDOCINO
COUNTY IS. ANTICIPATED OPEN ON
DECEMBER FIRST. FIRST AS A
BEFORE. WE'VE BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH SEVERAL
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
DURING THIS CATASTROPHIC
DROUGHT FOCUSED ON SAVING YOUR
STATE'S ENDANGERED SALMON
SPECIES THIS PAST JULY THIS
COMMITTEE HELD A HEARING ON
DROUGHT LOW FLOWS AND CANDIDLY
DEAD SALMON WE HEARD FROM
TRIBAL LEADERS ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS AND FISHERMEN THAT THAT
THAT INTEGRATED WATER
MANAGEMENT POLICIES WAS
LITERALLY KILLING CALIFORNIA'S
ICONIC SALMON RUNS WE LEARNED
THAT IT WAS POTENTIALLY
POSSIBLE. THAT WE WOULD LOSE
ALL ENDANGERED WINTER RUN EGGS
THIS SUMMER ON THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER AND THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO HAS PLAYED OUT
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
MARINE FISHERIES SERVICE 80%
80% OF SALMON EGGS FOR THE
WINTER RUN. WE'RE LIKELY COOKED
TO DEATH ON THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER. AND WE ARE NOW HEARING
THAT ADDITIONAL 18% OF THE
REMAINING 20% JUVENILE SALMON
PERISHED DUE TO HIGH WATER
TEMPERATURES. THAT MEANS THAT
WE ONLY HAVE 2% SURVIVAL RATE
FOR THE WINTER RUN SALMON ON
THE SACRAMENTO. NOW THIS IS
WORSE THAN WHAT WE SAW IN TWO
PREVIOUS DEVASTATING YEARS IN
2000143% SURVIVAL RATE IN
2000155% SURVIVAL RATE SO WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN- AND I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HEAR THIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND I AM GRATEFUL TO THE
DIRECTOR WHO HAS BEEN WORKING
TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT IN FRONT
OF THIS CRISIS. WHAT WE'RE
HEARING IS FOR CONTINUING TO
DIG A DEEPER AND DEEPER HOLE
REGARDING THE LONG TERM
SURVIVAL OF CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC
SALMON FISHERY. ONE THING IS
FOR SURE THOUGH. WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO BRING SALMON
BACK FROM THE BRINK. OUR NUMBER
ONE GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE- PRECARIOUS
STATE OF OUR FISHERIES AND-
EDUCATE THE LEGISLATURE
RESIDENTS ABOUT THEIR STATUS.
WE HAVE AN ALL STAR LINEUP OF
PANELISTS HERE TODAY BUT BEFORE
WE GET INTO TODAY'S AGENDA I'D
LIKE TO BE A WELCOME ONCE AGAIN
CENTERED AWAY SO DO THE
HEARING. CENTER WAY SO FOR ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE ESPECIALLY
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM THE PANEL- MANY YEARS AGO
ABOUT NINE YEARS AGO WE
ACTUALLY- I BROUGHT CHUCK
BONHAM TO- SAN DIEGO AND HE
VISITED THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY. WE GOT A CHANCE TO
VISIT. THE FOUNDATION OF WHAT
USED TO BE- THRIVING SALMON
CANNERY. IN SAN DIEGO TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY BORDER WITH
MEXICO. WE USED TO HAVE A
THRIVING SALMON CANNERY WHERE
NOW WE- SCARCELY HAVE A RIVER-
WITHIN HIS MOSTLY SPEWING
CONTAMINATED WATER. INTO THE
PACIFIC OCEAN. MAN- YOU KNOW I.
YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING MANY OF
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD ON EACH ON THE TWIN RIVER
VALLEY BUT ALSO. THIS CONCEPT
THAT WE'RE LOSING- EIGHT
IMPORTANT IMPAIRMENT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR- WE'RE LOSING-
VARMINT THAT ASSISTS SUPPORTED-
VARIOUS SPECIES OF FISH
INCLUDING SALMON. SOME THAT NO
LONGER ROAM THE PLANET THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS THAT WERE ENDEMIC
TO SPECIFIC RIVERS. ALONG
CALIFORNIA THAT IT NOW ARE ARE.
DEEPLY DEEPLY IMPACTED BY.
URBAN DEVELOPMENT. ONE OF ONE
THING IS TO HAVE A RIBBON
DEVELOPMENT NOW THE THING IS
NOT TO MITIGATE. THE
DEVELOPMENT. WHICH LEADS TO THE
DEGRADATION OF A LOT OF
IMPORTANT HABITAT. SHOW UP YOU
KNOW I'M HOPING WE DO A BETTER
JOB. OF MANAGING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOURCE BECAUSE IT'S THE- IT'S
THE- THE THREAD THAT WEAVES ARE
ARE VERY DIVERSE. FABRIC OF
THIS OF THIS PLANET. AND AS WE
SEE- THE CONTAMINATION OR
WATERS COMBINED WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE SCARCELY ANY
HOPE. THAT THE THESE IMPORTANT
SPECIES WILL CONTINUE TO
SURVIVE SO- BUT YOU KNOW I POD
YOU TAKING ON THIS EFFORT AND
SEEING WHAT WE CAN DO TO
PRESERVE. WHATEVER WE HAVE
LEFT- FOR THE SIMON TO CONTINUE
TO RUN UP THE RIVER AND
REPRODUCE AND- AND RESTORE WHAT
WAS. A THRIVING REPRODUCTION OF
THE SPECIES. LOTS OF WORK HAS
BEEN DONE IN LAST TEN YEARS OF
THE LOAN ON PART OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AND OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PREVIOUS
ONE AND I JUST APPLAUD EVERYONE
THAT'S BEEN PART OF THIS
EFFORT- BUT- WE YOU KNOW THIS
THERE ARE CERTAIN. TRENDS THAT
ARE TRENDING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION WE NEED TO DO MORE
AND I WANT TO SUPPORT YOU KNOW
SO WE WORK IN THIS AREA I ALSO
APPRECIATE A LETTER THAT WAS
CIRCULATED FROM THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION I GOT A CHANCE
TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH THE
CHAIRMAN OF PIZZA OVER IN THE
LAST FEW DAYS. AND THE ISSUE OF
PLASTICS IN THE ENVIRONMENT IS
JUST ANOTHER AREAS THAT WE NEED
TO- WORK A LITTLE MORE
AGGRESSIVELY ON I ACTUALLY GOT
TO VISIT SOME LOCATIONS OUT IN
THE PACIFIC OCEAN. WHERE WE
VISITED JUSTIN ON BELIEVABLE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC DEBRIS. AND
DOLPHINS AND TURTLES WERE JUST
YOU KNOW SWIMMING IN THE STUFF-
COVERED BY IT AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DO MORE WAS
PART I PLAN TO- I'M CURRENTLY.
DEVELOP SOME LEGISLATION THAT-
CONTROL. PLASTICS I HAVE A BILL
THAT I INTRODUCED LAST YEAR
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON ANOTHER ONE. BUT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THAT WILL AT LEAST
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA TAKE CARE OF
AT LEAST WHAT IT PRODUCES THAT
IT'S NOT. IMPORTED INTO OTHER
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT AND THAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE IT IS JUST A
BIG PROBLEM. FOR ARC OUR PLANET
FOUND AND- I PLAN TO WORK ON
THAT AND HOPEFULLY- JOINT
EFFORTS WITH THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO CONTROL PLASTICS
IN THE OCEANS AND RIVERS. AND
OUR LAKES SO THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND I- APPRECIATE YOU
GIVING ME A FEW COMMENTS. NO I
SENT AWAY SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR ENGAGEMENT HERE
TODAY IT MEANS SO MUCH THAT
YOU'RE ITH US THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER SENATOR IT'S REALLY
GOOD TO SEE YOU. SO LAYS IN
GERMAN WHAT WE LIKE TO BE TO DO
IS WE'RE GONNA GET RIGHT INTO
TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO A
SCHEDULING CONFLICT DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR OCEAN AND COASTAL
POLICY AS WELL AS THE EXACT
DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THAT'S DR
MARTIN GOLD HE IS DOUBLE BOOKED
THIS MORNING SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
HE'S GONNA BE PROVIDING HIS
RESEARCH. HIS REPORT ON BOTH
THE RESOURCE AGENCY AND THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HIS AGENCY'S
AMBITIOUS STRATEGIC PLAN THE
STATE'S OCEAN SCIENCE
ENTERPRISE IN ITS UPCOMING
AQUACULTURE PLANNED IN THE WAYS
THAT THE RESOURCE AGENCIES
WORKING TO SUPPORT. FISHING
COMMUNITIES AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN THE HEARING OVER
TO CHUCK BONHAM HE'S A DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT FISH
AND WILDLIFE MR BONHAM WILL DO
A DEEP DIVE ON ALL ISSUES UP
SALMON. THE WINNER RUN ON THAT
SACRAMENTO TALKING ABOUT
DUNGENESS CRAB WE'LL ALSO TALK
ABOUT CENTRAL VALLEY WATER
POLICY BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR OCEAN AND COASTAL
POLICY MR GOLD MR GOLD WE
WELCOME YOU TODAY I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE ANOTHER. MEETING THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE GETTING TO THE
FREE LAURIE IS YOUR- MR GO. IN
AT YOU HAVE TEN SIR. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER MAGUIRE FOR
COMPANY MY SCHEDULE AND THANK
YOU SENATOR WAY SO AS WELL I'M
VERY PLEASED ABOUT PIER BEFORE
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE FOR
THE FORTY FIFTH FORTY EIGHT I'M
SORRY ANIMALS YOU GREATER
VICTORIES FORM. DOESN'T
PROTECTION COUNCIL'S BEEN
FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTING ITS
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S COASTS AND OCEAN.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE EFFORTS
PERTINENT TO THE INTEREST OF
THIS COMMITTEE ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE UNDER WAY WITH A
STRONG FOCUS. ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCE- YEAH I KNOW THE
RESTORATION I'M MORE PARTNERING
VERY CLOSELY WITH TOM
DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE- TO
CONTEND AND TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OVER THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND PILOT RESEARCH.
WITH CALIFORNIA SEA GRANT AND
RESTORATION PROJECTS AIMED AT
UNDERSTANDING THE DRIVERS OF
RECENT HELP THE CLIENTS. IN
CALIFORNIA AND EXPLORING
POTENTIAL RESTORATION
APPROACHES. I ADVISE YOU TO
PLEASE REFER TO THAT DEPARTMENT
THIS MY LIFE'S WRITTEN UPDATE
FOR MORE DETAILED SUMMARY OF
THESE PROJECTS. INCLUDING THE
RESULTS OF OUR TENT REMOVAL
EFFORTS USING URCHIN FISHERMEN
OFF THE NORTH COAST. AND THEY
COME MONTHS THE OPPOSITE WILL
BE WORKING TO DEVELOP IT IN
TERMS OF HELP ACTION PLAN ON
AGAIN- DEVELOPED IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. INTO A
FINAL ACTION PLAN WITH
PRIORITIES FOR COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIP BASED ACTION BASED
ON RESULTS OF PILOT PROJECTS AS
WELL AS SCIENTIFIC TRIBAL AND
PUBLIC INPUT- FORMER
INTERJECTED AREA HAS A LOT
GOING ON HERE CALIFORNIA'S
MARINE PROTECTED AREA. NETWORK
IS APPROACHING ITS TEN YEAR
ANNIVERSARY AND ALONG WITH ITS
FIRST DECADE ALL MANAGEMENT
REVIEW. ASIDE DMR IF YOU WELL
WELL IT SAYS THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE M. K. NETWORK IS
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
GOALS OF THE MARINE LIFE
PROTECTION ACT. WHICH IS
PROTECTING THE STATE'S NATURAL
MARINE BIODIVERSITY REBUILDING
DEPLETED POPULATIONS AND
IMPROVING OCEAN HEALTH-
CALIFORNIA'S ESTABLISHED A
STATEWIDE MPA MONITORING
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW. PHASE ONE
WAS THE BASELINE MONITORING IT
AND WE'LL- FIND IT FACE TO
WHICH IS LONG TERM MONITOR
MONITORING WHICH IS UNDER WAY-
AND THOSE RESULTS WILL BE
USEFUL. FOR THE FOLLOWING- THE
FINAL DETAIL MANAGEMENT REVIEW.
ON LOOK FOR SOME RESULTS OF-
VARIOUS DIFFERENT TECHNICAL
REPORTS BY THE PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATORS ARE TO BE MADE
PUBLIC- IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- SO THAT'LL INFORM PROGRESS
IN MEETING THE GOALS OF THE
MLBPA. ANALYSIS OF THIS MARCH
TRADE DATA BY THE PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR TEAMS AN EXPERT
WORKING GROUP AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR ECOLOGICAL ANALYSIS
AND SYNTHESIS- NCSA UCSB. WILL
BE GUIDED BY THE STATE'S MPA
MANTRA ACTION PLAN AS WELL AS A
REPORT. ALL THE SCIENTIFIC
GUIDANCE FOR EVALUATING
CALIFORNIA'S MPA NETWORK WHICH
IS AUTHORED BY A WORKING GROUP
OF THE OPC SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY
CHANT AND RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR. ANOTHER ESTATE.
CALIFORNIA MPA NETWORK REPORT
THERE'S A SCIENCE TRUST THAT
APARTMENT APARTMENT FISHING
GAME AND- BC ALL WORKED WITH
JUST S. A. T. ON THESE EFFORTS.
THERE'S A ROBUST COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY TO ENSURE THAT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PERSPECTIVES ON NPA NATIONAL
PRIORITIES DEFINITIONS OF MPAS
SUCCESS. AND ROLE OF
COMMUNITIES AND M. J.
MANAGEMENT. AT JUST SAYING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE TRIBES WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INPUT VIA FORMAL CONSULTATION
INFORMAL ENGAGEMENT AND EFFORTS
SUCH AS THE TRIBAL MARINE
STEWARDS NETWORK. WHICH IS
SUPPORTING INDIGENOUS
STEWARDSHIP AND CO MANAGEMENT
OF MJ'S FIRST FOUR TRIBES
CURRENTLY INVOLVED. IN THAT
STEWART'S NETWORK PROGRAM.
THREE LET THEM MAY BE USED TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
BETTER MANAGEMENT OF ANY NBA
NETWORK DMR AS ENTIRELY
SEPARATE- THE STAKES THIRTY BY
THIRTY INITIATIVE THIS QUESTION
COMES UP AN AWFUL LOT SO I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT YEAH
IT'S ENTIRELY SEPARATE FROM
THAT PROCESS. A MARINE
PROTECTED AREA STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP TEAM HAS NEARLY
COMPLETED THEIR AMBITIOUS AND
COMPREHENSIVE FOR YOUR WORK
PLAN. THE PLAN FOCUSES ON
FINANCE EQUITY EDUCATION
ENFORCEMENT AND MORE LOOK FOR
IT BY THE END OF THE YEAR A LOT
GOING ON IN THE NBA SPACE. IN
THE AREA OF REDUCTION OF RISK
OF WAYAND'S ETERNAL INTEGUMENT
FISHING GEAR. ON THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE CALL DEVELOPED
WITH. THE OPC F. PACIFIC STATES
MARINE FISHERIES COMMISSION.
OBJECTS WERE SELECTED TO
ADVANCE OUR KNOWLEDGE AND
EFFECTIVENESS AT REDUCING WELL
IT'S YOUR TOTAL ENTITLEMENTS
AND IMPACTS ON THE FISHING
INDUSTRY- I WAS ABOUT ONE POINT
SIX MILLION OR SO DOLLARS THAT
WERE SPENT. ON THESE ONGOING
EFFORTS THE FAIRLAWN INSTITUTE
TO ENHANCE AND INTEGRATE WELL
DISTRIBUTION DATA TO REDUCE
ENTANGLEMENT REST. CASCADIA
RESEARCH COLLECTIVE TO PROVIDE
REAL TIME WELL OBSERVATIONS AND
VALIDATE MODELS TO ASSESS AND
TAKE ON THAT RISK. AND THEN
ALSO ON MONITORING OF
LEATHERBACK TURTLE DISTRIBUTION
OF MIGRATIONS REDUCING TANG ON
THE REST WE HOPE THAT THEY'LL
BE AT THE END OF THIS- A
PRODUCT. THAT WILL BE VERY USER
FRIENDLY- FOR THAT APARTMENT-
TO TWO YEARS TO REALLY
DETERMINE REST. ON THE
OBVIOUSLY THE VERY HIGH PROFILE
ISSUE- I'VE DONE JANICE CRAB ON
MANAGEMENT. SO PRODUCTS ARE
WELL WE PROJECT WORKING CLOSE.
WITH THE OTHER TO LEVERAGE
RESOURCES BUT THEY'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
DUNGENESS CRAB WORKING GROUP.
PROVIDE REAL TIME DATA TO
CONTRIBUTE TO ENTITLEMENT RISK
ASSESSMENTS. THROUGH THE RISK
ASSESSMENT AND MITIGATION
PROGRAM THE RAMP. ALSO WE'VE
GOT SOME HOARDING APARTMENT ON
JEFF GILL NET BUYBACK PROGRAM
WHICH IS NOW FULLY FUNDED WITH
BOTH STATE AND PHILANTHROPIC
RESOURCES. AN AREA OF OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION MICROPLASTICS
WITH A RAPIDLY CHANGING CLIMATE
THE PACE AND SCOPE OF OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND HYPOXIA IS
LIKELY TO INCREASE IN THE YEARS
AHEAD. YOUR PC WILL ALLOCATE
OVER THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON
OCEAN ACIDIFICATION HYPOXIA
MONITORING AND RESEARCH FOR THE
COST OF CALIFORNIA ON- WITHIN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WE'VE
ALREADY ALLOCATED ABOUT HALF OF
THOSE RESEARCH RESOURCES. AND
PLASTICS AND MICROPLASTICS
POLLUTION THAT CENTER WASTE OF
PRODUCT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS
A GLOBAL CRISIS AND
CALIFORNIA'S WATERS ARE NO
DIFFERENT THIS YEAR THE OPC
DEVELOPEDA TOP TEN LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOCUSING ON
LARGER PLASTICS DOES GREATER
THAN FIVE MILLIMETERS IN SIZE
ALSO AS REQUIRED BY SENATE BILL
TWELVE SIXTY THREE- AUTHORED BY
SENATOR ORRIN G. NOW IT'LL BE
C. WILL COMPLETE THE NATION'S
FIRST EVER MICROPLASTICS
STRATEGIES. FOR COASTAL WATERS
THE FIRST DRAFT SHOULD BE
RELEASED BY THE END OF THE YEAR
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE PROBLEM
CHARACTERIZATION SAMPLING AND
ANALYTICAL METHODS SOURCE
CHARACTERIZATION SOURCE
REDUCTION AND TREATMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND RESEARCH
PRIORITIES. AFTER GAUGE BUT
STRATEGY AND LISTENING SESSION
OKAY SHE YOU CAN CONSULT AND
COLLABORATE WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES. ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A TRIBAL GAUGE
AND STRATEGY. I HAD A FRAMEWORK
FOR ENHANCED PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE LBC AND TRIBES ON
OCEAN AND COASTAL MATTERS. OR
HOLDING LISTENING SESSIONS THIS
MONTH TO HEAR AND DISCUSS
TRIBES PERSPECTIVES ON TWO KEY
ISSUES. BEST PRACTICES FOR
CONDUCTING OUT RECENT ENGAGING
WITH TRIBES AND RESPECTFUL AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER. AND TRYING TO
FIND OUT TRIBES PRIORITIES FOR
CLOSE ON OCEAN MANAGEMENT AND
CONSERVATION. OUTCOMES OF THESE
LISTENING SESSIONS ONE FORM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A DRAFT TRIBAL
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY WHICH
SHOULD BE COMPLETED SOMETIME IN
THE MIDDLE OF NEXT YEAR.
THEY'LL BE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSULTATION
ONCE THE DRAFT STRATEGIES
DEVELOPED. AN AREA OF
AQUACULTURE. ON THE AQUACULTURE
PRINCIPLES IN ACTION PLAN
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATEWIDE
OUT OF TRACTION PLANS UNDERWAY
AND PROCEEDING ON SCHEDULE WITH
PLANNED COMPLETION BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND C. AS IN
CALIFORNIA SEA GRANT AND CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH ADOBE STOCK-
FINALIZE MEMBERSHIP ON BOTH THE
COMMUNITY AND SCIENTIFIC WAS
SAME GROUPS AS WELL AND HELD
INITIAL MEETINGS ABOUT. THIS IS
PART OF THE PROCESS DEVELOP A
WORKING DRAFT OF THE ACTION
PLAN WITH COMPLETION OF THE
FIRST BALL DROP EXPECTED IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS. AND IT TO
MOVING FORWARD ON THE ACTION
PLAN OPC PUBLICLY RELEASED THE
GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR
SUSTAINABLE MARINE AQUACULTURE
CALIFORNIA. AT THE JAN OBC
MEETING. THESE PRINCIPLES WORK
COOPERATIVELY DEVELOPED BY THE
AQUACULTURE LEADERSHIP TEAM LED
BY SECRETARY WHITE PROFILE AND
COMPOSED OF A PROGRAM
PROGRAMMATIC STAFF. SKEWS ME OF
ALL STATE AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
THE REGULATION PERMITTING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF AQUACULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT A FISH AND
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION. BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION AND STATE LANDS
COMMISSION OPC CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL AS THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THESE
PRINCIPLES INCLUDE USING THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE ENSURING
SUSTAINABILITY BUILDING
GOVERNANCE MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIPS AFFECTED PLANNING
FISH AND EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT
AND PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND FOOD SAFETY. THE
AQUACULTURE LEADERSHIP TEAM
CONTINUES TO MEET TO COORDINATE
A COUPLE PIECE OF STRATEGY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES ACROSS ALL MEMBER
AGENCIES AND WE'RE NOW
INTEGRATING THE ANC'S GROUP.
INTO THAT PROCESS. AND THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY FRONTS WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH DR
JENNIFER NORRIS- THAT'S
RESOURCE AGENCIES DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
HABITAT. ON THE COASTAL AND
OCEAN COMPONENTS OF THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY INITIATIVES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- FROM THE
CONSERVATION OF COASTAL WATERS
ADVISORY PANEL AND AN
INTEGRATED INTO THE DRAFT.
PATHWAYS TO THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY DOCUMENT WHICH WILL
DETAIL OPPORTUNITIES AND
STRATEGIES TO ACHIEVE THIRTY BY
THIRTY IN CALIFORNIA. ON THE
OCEAN SIDE WHICH IS WHERE WERE
INVOLVED THE PATHWAY TO
CONSERVING 30% OF CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL WATERS WILL FORCE
INCLUDE THE 16% OF STATE WATERS
CURRENTLY PROTECTED WITHIN
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS. I R.
TIES FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH
FEDERAL RESOURCE MANAGER
STRENGTHENED BIODIVERSITY
CONSERVATION MEASURES. IN
CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL MARIN
SANCTUARIES. AS A REMINDER
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SIMILAR
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS AS PART
OF THE AMERICA THE BEAUTIFUL
PROGRAM. THE COLLABORATION
COORDINATION WITH NATO AND THE
SANCTUARY'S MAKES SENSE FOR THE
STATE. AND THE NATION. EXAMPLES
OF POTENTIAL MEASURES TO
CONSIDER AN ASPIRIN CENTURIES
COULD INCLUDE. MANDATORY VESSEL
SPEED REDUCTIONS PHASING OUT
THE USE OF PARTICULARLY HARMFUL
FISHING GEAR. OR MAKING
EXISTING GEAR RESTRICTIONS
PERMANENT STRENGTHENING WATER
QUALITY PROTECTIONS RESTORING
DEGRADED HABITATS. AND BANNING
SINGLE USE PLASTICS WITHIN
CENTURY WATERSHEDS ARE JUST
EXAMPLES- JUST. TO LET YOU KNOW
ABOUT SIX MON. SIXTY SECONDS
OKAY ALL RIGHTS ALL ALL OF THE
PATHWAY DOCUMENTS PROM FOR
THIRTY BY THIRTY- SHOULD BE
RELEASED EITHER BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR OR- BIG BEGINNING OF
NEXT YEAR SO LOOK FOR THAT. AND
THEN THE LAST THING ON OFFSHORE
WIND FARM WHICH IS ANOTHER AREA
THAT WERE HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
WITH A LARGE. GROUP OF AGENCIES
AND NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY-
IS THAT- JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE BUREAU OF OCEAN ENERGY
MANAGEMENT RELEASED TWO
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR CALL AREA
SOPHOMORE OBEY. AND HUMBLE AND
PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR THESE
ANNOUNCEMENTS WILL INFORM THE
PROCESS AND EVALUATION. OF
FLOATING OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT MOVING FORWARD ON
THE PROTEIN CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY TRYING TO MINIMIZE. THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO FISHERIES
MARINE LIFE AND CULTURE
RESOURCES. SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FLOATING OFFSHORE WIND
TWENTY MILES PLUS OFFSHORE IN
ALMOST ALL CASES. THE KEY THING
IS NEXT YEAR IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
WEB CONSISTENCY DETERMINATION
HEARINGS. ON TOAST TO CALL
AREAS- AND THOSE WILL PROBABLY
BE IN APRIL FOR THE NORTH
COAST. AND JUNE I'M FOR THE
CENTRAL COAST AND WE'RE
SUPPORTING THAT CONSISTENCY
DETERMINATION PROCESS PROCESS
WORKING WITH OTHERS INCLUDING
THE DEPARTMENT. ON FILLING ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT DATA GAPS
INFORMATION GAPS WORKING WITH
THE FISHING COMMUNITY. BOND AS
WELL AS ALL THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT SCIENTIFIC DATA BASES
THERE AND BRINGING ALL THAT
INFORMATION TO BEAR FOR THE
CONSISTENCY DETERMINATION ON- A
REPORT THAT REPORTS WILL BE
COMING OUT OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. SO AS YOU CAN TELL
A LOT GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. DR GOLD
THANK YOU SO MUCH ADDUCTOR GOLD
IS COMING TO US LIVE FROM THE
PANDEMIC CONFERENCE ROOM. OF
HIS FORWARDS WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE- YOU WORK SIR AT I
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO GO
YOU HAVE ANOTHER MEETING I'M TO
TURN TO. WE SO THAT WOULD SEE
IF THERE'S A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HERE A DOCTOR CALLED
IT A FEW ITEMS- QUICKLY. ON THE
ISSUE OF THE BULL KELP
COLLAPSE. WE SAW THAT GOSH I
THINK IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN. IN THE END WE
SAW IT IN YOU MENTION THIS IN
YOUR REPORT- SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN PURPLE URCHIN IN DEEP
CONCERN FOR FISHERMEN- WERE
SEEN THAT BULL COME COME BACK
ESPECIALLY IN THE NORTH COAST.
TALK WITH US ABOUT THAT.
BASICALLY IT'S THE COOLER WATER
TEMPERATURES. I THINK THAT
WE'RE SEEING AND THAT WARM
WATER BLOB THAT WE HAD. FOR
QUITE SOME TIME REALLY KILLED
OFF THE KELP. ANY PREDICTIONS
OF WHAT YOU SEE WHAT YOU SEE
HERE FOR- THAT BULL KELP WHICH
IS ICONIC FOR CALIFORNIA HERE
IN THE YEARS TO COME- CENTER
EIGHT I THINK IT'S STILL A WORK
IN PROGRESS I THINK. WE'RE
WE'RE ALL EXCITED BY ANY SIGN
OF PROGRESS SINCE THERE'S BEEN
SO LITTLE. ON IT REALLY WITHIN
THE LAST YOU KNOW SIX YEARS
PLUS. ARMED WITH THE MARINE
HEAT WAVES AND THAT THAT- CHEN
BEHRENS SAID REALLY WREAKED
HAVOC ON THE BULL KELP. ON
ESPECIALLY OFF A MENDOCINO AND
SONOMA COAST. AND SO ON IN THAT
REGARD. YOU KNOW WE KNOW HOW.
MUCH PEOPLE CARE ABOUT THIS.
NOT JUST FROM A FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT BUT JUST FROM A
CULTURAL STANDPOINT IT JUST
IT'S SUCH A HUGE PARTY
IDENTITY. ON IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT JUST AS YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYBODY. ELSE SO
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH. THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S- PURCHASE FISHING
COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS THE- NGOS
ON TO IT TO REALLY TRY TO SEE
WHETHER. YOU KNOW RESTORATION
IS GOING TO HELP ACCELERATE
THAT RECOVERY. ON AND SO ON THE
OTHER ASPECT IS WE HAVE SIX
DIFFERENT STUDIES SOME THE TOP
HELP. RESEARCHERS ON- IT
LITERALLY IN THE COUNTRY. THAT
ARE WORKING AT WHAT ARE THE
BEST WAYS TO GO ABOUT
RESTORATION MOVING FORWARD. SO
YES THE FACT THAT WE'VE HAD
COOLER WATERS ON HAS HELPED A
BIT. BUT I THINK IT'S STILL TOO
EARLY TO TELL. ON WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG
SUCCESS. OR WHETHER IT WERE
GETTING SOME PROMISING
PRELIMINARY SIGNS AT THIS POINT
AND SO- THAT APARTMENT AND
OBESITY I MEAN WE REALLY ARE
WORKING ON THIS ALMOST DAILY
TOGETHER. ON IT GENERALLY
TRACKING THAT AND TRYING TO
MOVE FORWARD. SO THAT'S THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH WHERE WE'RE AT.
GREAT UPDATE ON- ISSUES OF
COMPANY GONNA GO TO. ALL THE OF.
WIND AND- MOST FOCUS ON THAT-
HUNDRED MEGAWATT PROJECT AREA
OFF OF THE HUMBLE COAST. AND
WEAR A BOW ON THE FEDS HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED IN REGARDS TO THE
PROJECT AREA I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AND I
KNOW IT'S OUTSIDE THE TERRITORY
BUT RELATED. GETTING THESE-
THESE PROJECTS STOOD UP AND
BUILD IT'S CRITICAL BUT THE
TRANSMISSION LINES IS WHAT
WORLD WE GONNA NEED TO LOOK AT
AS AN UPGRADE. AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO GO HAND
IN HAND. DR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT AT ALL.
ALL AT ALL I WOULD SAY AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A DIRECT ANSWER
BUT YOU KNOW I. I HAVE NOT
WORKED IN THE STATE FOR A LONG
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE FOR ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF YEAR SINCE I WAS
APPOINTED. BUT I CAN TELL YOU
OF ALL THE ISSUES THAT YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT THAT WE WORK ON
OBESITY. THE ONE THAT I'VE SEEN
BE GREATEST COLLABORATION ON IT
AND I REALLY GIVES THE ENERGY
COMMISSION KAREN DOUGLAS A
GREAT JOB CREDIT FOR THIS. HAS
BEEN OFFSHORE WIND ISSUE. AND
SO WHETHER IT'S THE COASTAL
COMMISSION OR THE DEPARTMENT OR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
WE'VE ALL BEEN WORKING I AM NOT
EXAGGERATING MANY LEAST TWICE A
WEEK. TALKING ABOUT ALL OF
THESE VARIOUS DIFFERENT ISSUES
INCLUDING TRANSMISSION. AND SUB
TRANSMISSION OBVIOUSLY IS MUCH
MORE IN THE PURVIEW. OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND ON IT IS
REALLY WHAT THEIR FOCUS IS ON
AT THIS POINT. OUR FOCUS AS I
SAID BEFORE IS REALLY TRYING TO
FILL THOSE DATA GAPS- WHICH ARE
SO EXTENSIVE. I'M TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN WE DO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH OFFSHORE WIND WE DO IT AND
BY FAR THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AND SUSTAINABLE WAY
POSSIBLE. YEAH AND I DON'T
THINK SO I THINK LONG TERM
THAT'S GOING TO BE HAD IN BY
THE WAY YOUR- DOCTOR WILL
DEFINITELY RIGHT COMMISSIONER
DOUGLAS HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
TENACIOUS IN PURSUIT TO BE ABLE
TO GET. OFF SHORE WIND STOOD UP
IN THE STATE AND GRATEFUL FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THAT. I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT. THE INVESTMENT IN
TRANSMISSION LINE TO BE ABLE TO
GET THAT ENERGY INTO THE REST
OF THE CALIFORNIA GREAT. I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THAT. AND THE
OTHER ITEM AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE TALKED
WITH- THE OFFSHORE WIND
COMPANIES ABOUT IN FACT WE
HOSTED. A COMMITTEE HEARING
GOSH FOUR YEARS AGO ON THIS UP
IN THE CITY OF EUREKA AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTY. IS RATHER THAN
GOING PORT BY PORT. LOOKING AT
SOME TYPE OF SETTLEMENT WITH.
EACH OF THE PORT ASSOCIATIONS
THE FLEET SALMON FLEET- THE
CRAB FLEET WE NEED TO LOOK AT A
STATE WIDE SETTLEMENT. IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE ANY LOSS OF
FISHING GROUNDS AS WE'VE SEEN
LOTS OF FISHING GROUNDS ALL
FORWARD BY THE WAY SPECIALLY.
FOR THE MARINE PROTECTED AREAS
BUT WHAT. ARE THE LAW. ARE AT
STAKE AS WELL SO I THINK THAT'S
A- THAT WE'RE GOING NEED TO CAN.
TO PURSUE IS WE GO FORWARD. ON
THE ISSUE OF OFFSHORE WIND
CENTER WAY SO DID YOU WANT TO.
JUMP IN ON THIS IN A WAY SO. MY
QUESTION IS GONNA BE FOR THE
NEXT PRESENTER OKAY ABSOLUTELY.
THE LAST REQUIRED. SUMMER CHOIR
JUST JUST INTERJECT JUST
QUICKLY. I I'M SORRY IF I
GLOSSED OVER THAT I. EAT WHAT I
WHAT I MEANT TO SAY. I'M WORTH
THE EFFORT OF KEREN DOUGLAS AND
JIM IT AT THE END OF YOUR
COMMISSION IS. THAT THE STUDY
IS THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER IT SUPPORTS STUDIES
WHETHER THE TRANSMISSION
STUDIES ON THE LIGHT. THOSE ARE
BEING TALKED ABOUT AND THEY'RE
EITHER UNDER WAY OR THEY'RE
GOING TO BE UNDER WAY VERY VERY
SHORTLY SO I DID WANT TO GIVE
YOU SOME ASSURANCE IN THAT
REGARD. ON A VERY VERY WELL
WHERE WE HELP SECURE THE MONEY
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS IS. WELL AND- THERE NEEDS
TO BE A- OR- CALL. NOT A PORT
BY PORT POLICY. AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS I KNOW
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS.
ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIA
SUITE. THE LAST PIECE ON THE
THROAT YEAH MR SECTARIAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I KNOW YOU NEED
TO. GET TO YOUR NEXT MEETING-
IT CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
AQUACULTURE ACTION PLAN. IN
JUST THE INTERACTION YOU'VE HAD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE. IN THEIR
PROGRAM IN REGARDS TO
PERMITTING. IF YOU WANT TO JUST
TOUCH ON THAT HERE TWO MINUTES.
ON THE INTERFACE BETWEEN THE
TWO AGENCIES AND HOW THAT'S
WORKING WITH AQUACULTURE. JUST
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING OUT ON
THE PLANNING EFFORT IS BEING
DONE- WORKING WITH- WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND SO ON.
YEAH SO LOTS OF MEETINGS- WE
JUST HAD ONE A WEEK AGO WITH-
REPRESENTED FROM COASTAL
COMMISSION CASSIE PLAYFUL AS
WELL AS A CRACK SHERMAN FROM
THE DEPARTMENT ON MEETING WITH
AND SHE'S REALLY TALK ABOUT.
DEVELOPING THE ACTION PLAN AND
REALLY FOCUSING ON THAT ON THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA BOND AND
WHAT'S REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ON AND REALLY. THAT'S
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
INTEGRATE USED TO PROCESS EASE
OF USING THE PRINCIPLES RIGHT
NOW ON BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
IN THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW AND WE
WANT TO BE SMART ABOUT HOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH THAT. I'M
VERY PIECEMEAL BASIS- WITH DON
KNOTTS MUCH CONSISTENCY AS WE
NEED TO FRANKLY THERE SIR A
LACK OF RESOURCES I'M FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF STAFFING ON TO
REALLY- PROCESS APPLICATIONS.
AND DO THAT IN A SOUND MANNER
ON BUT THAT'S ONE OF THINGS
THAT'S GOING TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THE ACTION PLAN- HOPEFULLY
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE IN THE INTERIM AS WELL. SO
THE COMMUNICATION REALLY COULD
NOT BE EVEN TIGHTER THAN WHAT
IT IS RIGHT NOW YEAH AND
PROCEED TO WORK THAT THE COAST
MACHINE PUT IN REGARDS TO THE
PERMITTING- ON THAT ISSUE AT
CENTER WE SAW POLICE ON THIS
YOU KNOW I DID WANT TO GET THE
RESOURCES AGENCY PERSPECTIVE ON
THE SALMON ISSUE ON THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER. AND. SO IN.
WORDS IN PREVIOUS REPORTS WE
HER A LOT ABOUT- THE FISH THAT
WERE INTRODUCED INTO LIKE THE
STRIPER THAT WAS INTRODUCED
INTO THE AMERICAN IVER ON THE-
SACRAMENTO RIVER THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO SHARPLY TO
PREFER NATION THAT HAS. REDUCED
THE AMOUNT OF- SALMON
HATCHERIES AND THE RUNS AND SO
AT SOME POINT THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT AND
HEALTHY MIX THIS- THE STRIPER
ANOTHER APPROACH A FISH SAID-
BETTER AFFECT THOSE POPULATIONS
OF INFECTING SALMON AND THE
SMELL. AND AT SOME POINT THE
SMOKE WAS CONNECTED- THE- WATER
TRANSFERS WERE CONNECTED TO THE
REDUCTIONS A SMALL POPULATION
BUT THEY ALSO FOUND THAT
SCHREIBER WAS A PREDATORY FISH
OF THE SMELT SO. HAS ANYTHING%
BEEN DONE IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS TO ADDRESS- THE- THE FISH
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED INTO
THE RIVERS AND THE DAMAGE THAT
THEY CAUSE INTO THE NATIVE
POPULATIONS. I SENT HER AWAY SO
I THINK IT'S A GREAT SEGUE TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER WHOSE-
QUALIFIED TO ANSWER THAT I'M
ABSOLUTELY NOT AND THAT WOULD
BE- DIRECTOR BONHAM. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH GUYS SO
CERTAINLY SO YOU ALL GOOD IF WE
HOLD THAT DOES IT RUN PERFECT.
MR UNDERSECRETARY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS UNDERSECRETARY IS
ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES LATE SO
WE APPRECIATE IT SIR GOOD TO
TALK TO YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TENDING TO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MY PLEASURE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT
WAS UNDERSECRETARY FOR OCEAN
CALLS A POLICY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TO RESOURCE AGENCY
THAT WAS MARTIN GOLD ARE NOT
GOING TO BE TRANSITIONING TO.
CHUCK BONHAM TRUCK BONHAMS THE
LONGEST SERVING DIRECTOR. OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL LIVE IN STATE HISTORY
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
DIRECTOR IS WITH US. THE
DIRECTOR IS GOING TO BE HITTING
ON SEVERAL NOTES TODAY HE'S
GONNA BE FOCUSING ON THE WINTER
RUN IN THE SACRAMENTO. AND
THIS. TERRIBLE COLLAPSE THAT
WE'VE SEEN WITH THIS YEAR'S
WINNER RUN WITH ABOUT A 2%
SURVIVAL WHAT THAT'S GONNA MEAN
NOT NECESSARILY THIS YEAR BUT
FOR THE YEARS TO COME. HE'S
GONNA BE FOCUSING ON THE
DUNGENESS CRAB. FISHERY WHICH
IS A TOP TIER FISHERY HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HE'S
GONNA BE TOUCHING ON CENTRAL
VALLEY WATER POLICY OF COURSE
CLAIM IF DAM REMOVAL. HE'S
GONNA BE TALKING TO US ABOUT
THE AGENCY'S HATCHERY PROGRAMS
AND- HOW THE DEPARTMENT TOOK
PROACTIVE ACTION. ON THE
DROUGHT. TRY TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
ENDANGERED. SALMON SPECIES SO.
ON TOP OF THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AN OIL SPILL TO CHUCK
BONHAM HAS BEEN A LITTLE BUSY
HE IS FULLY CAPITATED THIS
MORNING. MR BONHAM WE WELCOME
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME YOU HAVE TEN
MINUTES SIR I'LL GIVE YOU SIXTY
SECOND PROMPT A DOCTOR BOTTOM
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
CHAIR. AND SENT AWAY SO I JUST.
WOULD SAY PERSONALLY TO BOTH OF
YOU I HAVE REALLY BENEFITED
FROM AND CHERISH THE
RELATIONSHIP OUR PARTNERSHIP
OVER THE DECADE I'VE BEEN
DIRECTOR. TWO THINGS THAT CAME
UP IN QUESTIONS WITH THE PRIOR
SPEAKER FIRST JUST AS A POINT
OF REFERENCE SENATOR MCGUIRE-
FIRE DEPARTMENT ALSO HAS BEEN
LIVING THROUGH COVETED AND HOW
IT AFFECTS OUR WORK FORCES WORK
PRODUCT SO UNDER THE FEDERAL
CURES ACT THE FIRST ROUND. WE
WERE ACTUALLY THE FIRST WEST
COAST STATE TO GET FUNDS OUT
BACK TO AFFECTED COMMERCIAL
FISHING. INDUSTRY MEMBERS WE
WERE ABLE TO GET OUT EIGHTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
BEFORE ANY OTHER WEST COAST
STATE WAS ABLE TO GET THEIR
FUNDS OUT THE DOOR. THAT
ADDRESSED ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED CLAIMS. ABOUT AN
AVERAGE OF TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
OUT- CLAIM. AND THE LAST CLAIM
WAS PAID OUT LAST NOVEMBER
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF DEALING
WITH THE SECOND ROUND OF CARERS
ARE DISASTER RELIEF SO THE
APPLICATION PROCESS IS OPEN NOW.
IT HAS ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN IT NOTE TO MIKE
CONROY AND EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
SUITE THAT APPLICATION. WINDOW
CLOSES NOVEMBER SEVENTEENTH AND
THERE WILL BE NO LATE
APPLICATIONS ACCEPTED. TURNING
TO SENATOR WAY SAYS QUESTION
ABOUT ON STRIPERS TRIED PASSING
A DELTA YES THERE HAS BEEN
ACTION IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
ACTION AND ON. WE HAVE ALL
KINDS OF FISH AND OUR ESTUARIES
IN OUR RIVERS AND CALIFORNIA
THE SENATORS REFERRING TO THE-
SACRAMENTO SAN JUAN SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA- STRIPED BASS THERE
THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR. QUITE
SOME TIME LONGER THAN YOU AND
I'VE BEEN ALIVE. IN ONE COULD
DECIDE TO DEPLOY ALL THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR
DEPARTMENT. GO INTO THE ESTUARY
AND TRY TO READ A KID ALL THE
STRIPED BASS. UNLESS YOU GET
LITERALLY EVERYONE. THE
POPULATION WILL JUST REBOUND
BACK UP TO CARRYING CAPACITY
ACROSS THE STADIUM THE
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE DOESN'T
REALLY SUCK OR- UNEQUIVOCAL
POSITION THAT IT'S THE PRESENCE
OF STRIPED BASS THAT'S
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DECLINE OF
WINTER RUN SALMON. THAT SAID
WHAT WE HAVE. BEEN DOING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. IS DRAWING SIR
AROUND CERTAIN PLACES IN THE
ESTUARY AND THE CONFLUENCE OF
RIVERS TO THE ESTUARY CALLING
THEM HOT SPOTS ENGAGING IN
TARGETED SCIENTIFIC WORK TO A
RADICALLY WITHIN THE HOT SPOT.
AND THEN ASSESSED
SCIENTIFICALLY WHETHER THAT'S
PRODUCING A POPULATION BENEFIT
FOR WINTER RUN AND OTHER
IMPERILED SALMON. TURNING TO
THE MANY THINGS I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO COVER TODAY LET'S START
WITH- THE RECENT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OIL SPILL. NO OIL
SPILL IS GOOD. THE BEST WILL
SPELL IS ZERO SPILLS A HEART
THEY HURT US ECONOMICALLY THEY
HEARD US AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
THE HARDEST ENVIRONMENTALLY. A
HARDEST AT THE PERSONAL LEVEL
SO ABOUT A MONTH AGO YOU MAY
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING AND
NOW KNOW THAT ABOUT FOUR AND A
HALF MILES OFFSHORE FROM
BASICALLY HUNTINGTON BEACH A
PIPELINE CARRYING PRODUCTS FROM
FEDERALLY MANAGED PLATFORMS IN
FEDERAL WATERS. I HAD A LEAK
THE LIKELY LEAK SOURCE IS ABOUT
THIRTEEN INCH HORIZONTAL
CRACKS. THIS PIPELINE RUNS
ABOUT SEVENTEEN AND A HALF
MILES FROM THE SHORE IN LONG
BEACH. FOUR THOUSAND FEET AT
PIPELINE WAS MOVED ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIVE FEET OFF OF
CENTER. AND THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL IT'S DUE TO AN ANCHOR
AND ANCHORAGE RIGHT. AT
THIRTEEN INCH CRACKS PRODUCED
THE SPELL A MONTH AGO. WELL WE
SWUNG INTO ACTION YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THE WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT
IS OUR OFFICE OF SPILL
PREVENTION RESPONSE WAS CREATED
I THINK IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
BY THE LEGISLATURE IT IS THE
STATE'S ACTION AGENCY TO DEAL
WITH WALLS. AT THAT MOMENT A
MONTH AGO WE ASSUME THE WORST
CASE SPILL OF ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND BARRELS OR ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE THOUSAND GALLONS
WE DID A VARIETY OF THINGS OVER
THE LAST MONTH WE SURGED A WORK
FORCE THAT REACHED NATIONWIDE.
AND BY THE END OF THE FIRST
WEEK OF THIS BILL WE HAD ALMOST
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE DEPLOYED
IN THE THEATER OF RESPONSE. WE
BROUGHT BOTH THE COUNTIES OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO
INTO WHAT'S CALLED THE UNIFIED
COMMAND. THROUGH THEIR SEARCH
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS WE IMMEDIATELY LIAISON
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION COMMUNITY
INCLUDING FOR THE FIRST TIME.
ASKING A NONPROFIT PARTNER
SURFRIDER TO SERVE AS AN
OFFICIAL LIAISON. WE DID THE
SAME WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
TRIBAL NATIONS. WE PUT BOOTS ON
THE BEACHES ALSO ON THE WATER
AND DEALT WITH IT SO WE'LL
STILL. I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T THANK EVERY SINGLE
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM MAYORS
HUNTINGTON BEACH COMES TO MIND
FOR SURE THROUGH ALL OF YOUR
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE COLLEAGUES.
TO THE CALIFORNIA CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION IT WAS LITERALLY AN
ALL OF GOVERNMENT ALL HANDS ON
DECK STATE PARKS STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. EFFORT TO DEAL WITH
THIS BILL A MONTH LATER. I'M
THANKFUL THAT. MOST LIKELY
STILL NUMBER IS MUCH LOWER FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT BARRELS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND GALLONS AND OUR IMPACT
TO WILDLIFE BIRDS MARINE
MAMMALS MORTALITY AND THE OILS
QUANTIFICATION NUMBER OF
WILDLIFE IMPACT IS BELOW ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED WHICH DOESN'T
DIMINISH THE IMPACT IS FAR LESS
THAN WE THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE A
MONTH. LET ME TURN TO WHY THIS
IS REALLY RELATED TO FISHERIES
AND SEE IF I CAN QUICKLY SHARE
SLIDE I CAN'T ALL. GIVE UP ON
THAT EFFORT. DO YOU SEE THIS
LIGHT ON YOUR SCREEN THIS SITE
IS NOW UP MISTER DIRECTOR BRAD
SO THIS REPRESENTS IN THE
HATCHED AREA A FISHERIES
CLOSURE. WHAT PURSUANT TO THE
OIL SPILL WHAT HAPPENS UNDER
LAW IS WHEN WE HAVE AN OIL
SPILL. UNDER CODE I'M REQUIRED
TO CLOSE AREAS AFFECTED TO TAKE
IN CONSUMPTION OF FISH AND SELL
JUMPERS WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A NOTIFICATION OF AN OIL
SPILL. THIS REQUIRES ME TO
INTENSELY COORDINATE AT BALLY
PA WITH WHAT'S CALLED THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT. THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER PROVISIONS WITHIN
THE CODE THAT IT TRIGGERED ONCE
WE'RE IN A SPILL RESPONSE
SITUATION WHAT YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN. IS A CURRENT FISHERIES
CLOSURE WHICH BEGAN OCTOBER
THIRD AND WAS EXPANDED TWICE
BASED ON THE BALL THE OIL
OBSERVATIONS AND TRAJECTORIES
WORKING IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE WE ARE AND THE-
FEDERAL EFFORT USING SATELLITE
IMAGERY I KNOW WHAT'S- ACTIVATE
THIS BILL TRAJECTORY. THIS IS
OUR CURRENT CLOSURE IT'S
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE. WHERE MILES THE
THING IS I IS DIRECTOR DON'T
HAVE AUTHORITY UNDER LAW TO
OPEN THIS BACK UP TO. ELIMINATE
THE CLOSURE UNTIL WE COMPLETE A
SERIES OF REQUIREMENTS WORKING
WITH THE WE ARE. THIS IS ALL
AROUND THE STREETS OF SEAFOOD
SAMPLING. AND HERE'S WHY T'S
MOST I THINK CULTURALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY IMPACTFUL RIGHT
NOW. WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
CRABS IN A MINUTE BUT THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ANALOG TO
HELP PEOPLE CHERISH THE
BEGINNING OF THE CRAB SEASON IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. IS PEOPLE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EQUALLY
LOVE THE OPENER FOR THE LOBSTER
SEASON. AND LITERALLY THE
MOMENT WE STARTED TO SWING INTO
ACTION ON THIS BILL THE WEEKEND
OF OCTOBER SECOND AND THIRD.
WAS THE SAME TIME WE WERE
GETTING READY TO OPEN THESE
WATERS TO THE LOBSTER FISHERY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SO THE
MIDDLE OF OCTOBER WE GOT OUT IN
THE WATER AND GET THE FIRST ONE
SHORT FINNED FISH AND MUSSELS
SAMPLING. OCTOBER TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY FOURTH WE DID THIS
SECOND MUSCLE SAMPLING. FROM
THE TWENTY SECOND OF THE
THIRTIETH WE DID OUR FIRST
OFFSHORE SAMPLING NEAR SHORE
DEEP TRAWL DIVERS TRAPS YOU
PFDS. ALL THOSE. TAMPA HAVE
BEEN SHIPPED TO THE QUALIFIED
LAB. NOVEMBER SECOND THIRD
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
THIRD MUSCLES SAMPLING.
SAMPLING TIME LINES ARE REALLY
DRIVEN BY TIDE SAFETY WEATHER
CONDITIONS THE SAMPLES HAVE DON
SPINY LOBSTER ROCK CRAB HALIBUT
ROCKFISH VIRGIN BAIT FISH
SPECIES MUSSELS PRAWNS REVIEWS
COMMERCIAL VESSELS AND FISSURES
TO HELP OUT HERE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. ON THIS IS
ONE OF THE FIRST BEST TIMES
WE'VE INCORPORATED IMMEDIATE
ENGAGEMENT WITH MIKE CONROY AND
OTHERS ON THE BEACH SIDE WE'VE
WORKED WITH LOCAL FISHERIES
LEADERSHIP TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO USE THEIR FORCE
DEPLOYMENT OUT CAPTURING THESE
SAMPLES HERE'S THE DEAL THOUGH
THERE'S A TURNAROUND TIME
CHALLENGE HERE BECAUSE ONLY A
FEW LAPS QUALIFIED TO DO THIS
WORK. YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DETECT TRACE LEVELS OF
HYDROCARBONS AND TEST FOR
HYDROCARBONS. RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC CONSUMPTION. THERE ARE
THINGS WE THINK WE CAN DO TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR A NEXT BILL.
LIKE HOW WE MIGHT REOPEN USING
PHASES OR HOW MIGHT WE
STREAMLINED THE SAMPLING EFFORT
BUT IT'S REALLY NOT- BIBLE
STICKS TO THINK ABOUT. BUILDING
ANOTHER LAB OR LAB CAPACITY TO
DEAL WITH THIS TECHNOMIC SO AS
OF RIGHT NOW. ALL GOES WELL
THINGS COME OUR WAY WE MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT AN ABILITY TO
DISCLOSURE DEALT WITH THEN
REMOVED AS WE GET TO THE END OF
THIS. MAYBE STOP SCHERING
SCREEN AND LATER TURNED TO. THE
NEXT TOPIC IT IS A DIRECTOR AT
IS WHEN I DO A QUICK TIME CHECK
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HIT
DUNGENESS CRAB WHEN I IN THE
DELAY IN IF YOU CAN COVER ALL
ISSUES IN REGARDS TO THE
PRESENCE OF WALES IN. WHEN THE
LATEST FLIGHTS WERE NOT TO BE
ABLE TO MONITOR WELL SITUATION
I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU HIT THE
WINNING RUN IN SACRAMENTO AND
WE CAN. OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS AS WELL JUST BECAUSE
THE TIME BUT- LONG TURNED BACK
OVER TO YOU MR DIRECTOR YEP I
WAS OLY GONNA DO THREE ISSUES
EVEN THOUGH THE LONG LISTS FROM
STUFF AND JUST DEAL WITH THE
OTHER THINGS AND CAN AND SO LET
ME TURN TO DROUGHT. AND WINTER
RUN. IT'S GRAHAM. IT'S IS WORSE
AS I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY CAREER
IT'S WORSE. RIGHT NOW THAN IT
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE LAST
ROW. NINE TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WATER YEARS
ARE THE SECOND DRIEST TWO YEAR
PERIODS IN THE HISTORICAL
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA. SO FORGET
ABOUT THE NINETEEN SEVENTY JOB
THIS IS WORSE THAN THAT ALL OF
OUR MAJOR FEDERAL AND STATE
RESERVOIRS SHASTA OR GO FULL
SOME. HAVE SEVERELY LOW STORAGE
WE ARE IN A HOLE
HYDROLOGICALLY. THE RECENT RAIN
IS SUPER THANKFUL. BUT WE CAN'T
COUNT ON IT WITH SUCH A
HYDROLOGICAL HOLE TO DIG OUT OF
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO CALL KNOW
WHAT LEVELS OF RAIN NO WAS ARC
LEVELS OF RAIN TO GET OUT OF
THE DROUGHT WERE. IN SEVEN FACE
A SERIES OF THREATS YOU'VE GOT
THE ONGOING DROUGHT CONDITIONS.
YOU'VE GOT A LONG TERM DECLINE
IN POPULATIONS. WE HAD
CONSECUTIVE DRY YEARS OR SEVEN
ZERO NINE THIRTEEN THROUGH
FIFTEEN. WE HAVE COMPETING
INTERESTS FOR SCARCE WATER.
LOOTING HOW WE MANAGE THE
SCARCE RESOURCE IS AND WE HAVE
RECENT DYNAMICS LIKE INCREASED
EFFICIENCY AND SALMON DIETS OUT
OF THE OCEAN THOSE THINGS
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATISTICAL
REPORT UK FROM OUR FEDERAL
AGENTS YOU KNOW. SURVIVAL IN
THE SINGLE DIGITS WE CANNOT GET
RECOVERED SALMON POPULATIONS IS
EVERY SEVERAL YEARS WE
EXPERIENCE A DYNAMIC WHERE WE
HAVE SURVIVALS IN THE SINGLE
DIGITS THE POPULATION IS ON ITS
LONG SLOW DECLINE SOME YEARS
WITHIN THAT ARE GOOD. AS AN
EXAMPLE THIS CURRENT YEAR HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN PRETTY GOOD FOR
FISHING- ON ON SOME OF THE
FRONTS WE HAD A FIRE THEN USUAL
RETURNS UP YOU CREEK IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE WE HAD BETTER THAN
PREDICTED FISHING IN THE
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
SPACE BUT THAT'S BECAUSE THOSE
FISH THAT HAVE JUST COME BACK.
CAME IN WERE BORN IN WAR WERE
KIND OF RUNNING THROUGH OUR
RIVERS WENT BY RIVER LEVELS ARE
HIGHER THE CURRENT DROUGHT
SITUATION IS LIKELY TO PRODUCE
VERY BAD RETURNS OF FINISH REAR
FOUR YEARS FROM NOW AND IF WE
KEEP HAVING. THESE INCREDIBLY
BAD YEARS WE WILL NOT DIG OUT
OF OUR POPULATION DECLINE
THAT'S JUST THE REALITY WE'VE
GOT TO ACCEPT THAT REALITY. SO
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THE DEPARTMENT THIS YEAR TRY TO
MANAGE THROUGH THIS YEAR. WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND A LOT OF MONEY
THANK YOU ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY EVENTUALLY
APPROVED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
WEDNESDAY ABOUT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN COVER REDIRECTING
TWENTY SIX STAFF. WE'RE GONNA
BE IN THE FIELD AROUND THE
CLOCK DOING FISH RESCUE
INSTRUCTOR MONITORING ON ALL OF
OUR SENTINEL STREETS GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
AND DO ALMOST FORTY PROJECTS
ACROSS FOURTEEN HATCHERIES.
REPLACING ALL KIND OF
INEFFICIENT OUTDATED NOT
MODERNIZED EQUIPMENT TO TRY TO
GET OUR HATCHERIES IN A STATE
THEY CAN HELP US BRIDGE NEXT
YEAR. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
MORE THAN THAT WILL TAKE ABOUT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
MODERNIZE ALL PARTS OF OUR
HATCHERY FLEETS ARE FISH
STOCKING TRUCKS AND TRAILERS
ARE FEED VEHICLES ARE FISH
FEEDERS WE WILL BE ABLE TO GET
ALL OF THAT UP TO A MODERNIZED
STATE. SHORTLY WHERE IT'S ALL
FIVE YEARS OR YOUNGER AS TO
THAT EQUIPMENT. WE NEED TO DO
MORE WE HAVE TO GO TO EACH OF
OUR HATCHERIES. AND WE HAVE A
RUNNING LIST. AND DEAL WITH CAN.
STRATEGIES WE NO LONGER CAN
COUNT ON COLD WATER FROM
RESERVOIRS COMING INTO OUR
HATCHERIES KEEPING THE WATER
COOLING. TO SURVIVE A HATCHERY
OPERATIONS WE HAVE TO COME UP
WITH CONTINGENCIES IN YOUR
DISTRICT SENATOR YOU KNOW. WITH
THE ARMY CORPS WE EFFECTIVELY
LOST TEMPERATURE CONTROLLED THE
WARM SPRINGS FISH HATCHERY AND
WE HAD TO TAKE THE REMAINING
COHO BROODSTOCK. AND SEND IT TO
A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL TO STEWARD
UNTIL WE CAN FIX THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEM. WE ARE
DEVELOPING SIMILAR CONTINGENCY
STRATEGIES FOR ALL OF OUR
ASSETS RIGHT NOW. BY THE TIME
WE GET OUT OF THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR AND ARE PREPARED
FOR NEXT YEAR. WE WILL BE
INCREASING OUR FISH PRODUCTION
JUST ON TUESDAY I ANNOUNCED
WE'RE GOING TO. LOSE ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL. BALL ROUNDED OUR
NIMBUS FISH HATCHERY IN THE
AMERICAN AS A MEASURE TO KEEP
ALIVE BEFALL RUN FOR OUR HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
OCEAN WHO STILL RELY ON. FOR
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. WE'RE GONNA
BE IN A POSITION WHERE WE'RE
PREPARED TO GET IN NEXT YEAR TO
TRUCK ABOUT SEVENTEEN MILLION
FISH. FROM THE FOUR MAJOR
CENTRAL VALLEY HATCHERIES OUT
TO OUR ESTUARIES. BUT THIS WILL
JUST BE THE BAND. IT'S TIME TO
DO THE THINGS WHICH ARE
POTENTIALLY A REAL THINGS THAT
WILL HELP US ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY NOT AVOIDING JUST
EXTINCTION. WE NEED TO GET
FRESH OUT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOR IF THEY STAY STUCK ON THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOR WE'RE
GONNA RUN OUT OF COLD WATER
YEAR AFTER YEAR LOOKING THROUGH
THE DECADES IS JUST A REALITY
DEALING WITH CLIMATE IMPACTS WE
NEED TO GET THEM INTO THEIR
HISTORICAL HABITAT. WE'VE GOT A
SIX ON THIS PASSAGE PROBLEMS IN
BUTTE CREEK AND GET BETTER MORE
SUCCESSFULLY TO THE UPPER PART
OF THE SYSTEM FASTER WE'VE GOT
TO GET DOWN THE REMAINING
THINGS WITH PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY IN BATTLE
CREEK AND MAKE BATTLE CREEK A
REFUGIO FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
SALMON AS WELL. FRANKLY NEXT
YEAR WE OUGHT ALSO GO AHEAD PUT
FISH IN THE MCLEOD RIVER ABOVE
SHASTA DAM FOR THE FIRST TIME
TO DO SOME SCIENCE IF WE CAN DO
IT IF WE CAN'T GET THE FISH
THERE WE ALREADY LEASED
DEPLOYED THE EQUIPMENT. AND GET
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TESTED OUT
SO WE CAN DO A PRETTY PROBLEM
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET SALMON
INTO OTHER TRIBUTARIES LIKE THE
FEATHER OR MAYBE THE U. BUT AS
WELL IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
CHANCE AT BEATING THIS
POPULATION DECLINE IN THE BIG
PICTURE. THOSE ARE A FEW OF THE
THINGS ON MY MIND LET ME TURN
TO CRAP AND HOPEFULLY I'LL GET
OUT OF THE WAY WITHIN THE TEN
MINUTES SO THE RECREATIONAL
TANK ATTENTIONS GRAB USING CRAB
TRAPS IN BASICALLY FROM SOME
MOMENTOUS. YOU KNOW DOWN TO
POINTS OR- I WENT. TO MAKE SURE
POINT LOOK POINT BE TEN.
RESTRICT IN A NORMAL WORLD THE
RECREATIONAL CRAB FISHERY WOULD
HAVE COMMENCED THIS NOVEMBER
SIX- THIS WEEKEND IT IS NOW
DELAYED. AND THAT CENTRAL PART
OF THE COAST IF YOU'RE UP ABOVE
THE SONOMA COUNTY LINE YOU CAN
GO AHEAD RECREATIONALLY FISH
FOR DUNGENESS CRAB. IF YOU'RE
BELOW THE POINT LOPEZ LINE YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND RECREATION AS
FAST- EVER ALONG THE COAST
RECREATIONALLY YOU CAN USE
OTHER TYPES OF FISHING METHODS.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE STAIRS
RECREATIONALLY YOU CANNOT USE
THE TRUCKS. ON THE COMMERCIAL
FRONT AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
RIGHT NOW ALL WE ARE DELAYING
THE COMMERCIAL OPENER IN THAT
MIDDLE PART OF THE STATE. THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE IS
HEADED TOWARDS POTENTIALLY A
DECEMBER FIRST. QUALITY TESTING
OF THE MEAT WHICH IS AN
ARRANGEMENT BETWEEN THE THREE
WEST COAST STATES. AND SOUTH OF
LOPEZ POINT- I'M SINGLE HAND
COMMERCIALLY FISH THE MIDDLE
PART OF THE STATE NOT YET AND
THE REASON IS WE'RE MANAGING. A
CHANGE IN OUR OCEAN WHICH FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AS
EITHER GIVEN US A DEMO LIKE
ACID DELAY FOR COMMERCIAL
FISHING WORE A DELAY BECAUSE OF
PRESENCE OF WHALES AND SEA
TURTLES. SO THE MOST RECENT
INFORMATION I HAVE FROM
YESTERDAY AROUND- WE CONVERT
MILITARY HOURS AROUND THREE PM.
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING ADDITIONAL
WELL SURVEYS WE HAVE
INFORMATION COMING IN FROM
OCTOBER THIRTY AND THIRTY ONE
FROM CASCADIA RESEARCH. SHOWING
A CONTINUED PRESENCE OF
HUMPBACK WHALES IN HIGH NUMBERS
IN FISHING ZONES THREE AND FOUR
THE RECENT STORM APPEARS TO NOT
HAVE CLEARED OUT THOSE WHALES-
SURVEYS SHOW UP TO SEVENTY NINE
WHALES IN ZONE THREE AND TWENTY
WHALES IN ZONE FOR. BOTH OF
THOSE CAN LEVELS EXCEED THE
TRIGGERS IN OUR REGULATIONS
WE'RE ALSO SEEING INFORMATION
COMING IN FROM THE MONTEREY BAY
A WHALE WATCH THAT SAYS WE'RE
ABOVE TRIGGER LEVELS WE FLEW
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT PLANE ON THE
SECOND TWO DAYS AGO. REALLY
POOR WEATHER LIMITED- VALUE OF
THAT FLIGHT BUT WE DID OBSERVE
WHALES HUMPBACKS IN SOME FREE.
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO FLY AGAIN AS
MUCH AS WE CAN. CURRENTLY THE
WEATHER FORECASTS INDICATES LOW
CLOUDS AND FOG. WHICH MAKES OUR
VISIBILITY FROM THE AIR VERY
DIFFICULT. I'M COGNIZANT OF
TIME- SOONER JUST LET ME
CONCLUDE ON THE CROP FRONT AND
SAY FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
BEEN APPLYING THIS APPROACH
THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR UNDER
FORMALIZE REGULATIONS FOR THE
COMMERCIAL FLEET. IT'S THE
FIRST TIME FOR THE RECREATIONAL
FISHERY WE KNOW THIS IS
DIFFICULT CHANGE TAKES TIME.
WHERE SHOULD HAVE OF OUR
PARTNERSHIPS ON BOTH THE
RECREATIONAL AND COMMERCIAL
FLEET. THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WHERE WE'RE
COLLABORATING EACH TIME OF THIS
YEAR TO TRY AND GET PEOPLE
FISHING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
WHILE MINIMIZING IMPACTS TO
MAJESTIC MARINE MAMMALS WHALES
AND OTHER BACKSEAT TURTLES. IN
A REPORT OF LETTING GO TOO MUCH
OVER. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
DIRECTOR THAT'S CHUCK BONHAM
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
FISH WILDLIFE WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BE TO DO IS I'M GONNA START OFF
WITH CENTER WAY SO THEN I'D
LIKE TO GET INTO SOME QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IN REGARD TO SALMON
AND CRAB A CERTAIN WAY SO.
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU AND I JUST
WANNA THANK THE DIRECTOR FOR
THAT WONDERFUL PRESENTATION.
AND I THANK HIM FOR RESPONDING
TO THE SALMON ISSUE RELATED TO-
SACRAMENTAL- JUST FOLLOWING UP
THE LOOP YOU KNOW HIGH- WE GOT
WE GOT TO SEE HOW. OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE I
GUESS- PRACTICALLY NO SALMON
ANYMORE WHERE THERE USED TO BE
AN ABUNDANT AMOUNT I'D HATE TO
HAVE THAT HAPPEN OR NORTH OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE SEE THAT
HAPPENING TO SACRAMENTO- DO DO
WE EXPECT THAT. AT SOME POINT
WE WILL NO LONGER SEE SALMON.
ALONG THE SACRAMENTO DELTA IS
US IS THAT SOMETHING THAT IS
JUST. A FLAT REALITY THAT WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT. NOW I REJECT
THAT AS A. A FATE ACCOMPLI AND
I'LL POINT TO YOUR HOME THE
REGION AS THE EXAMPLE. WHILE
THEY MAY BE FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
WE STILL HAVE SOUTHERN STILL
HAD RECESS IN WHAT ARGUABLY IS
THE BIGGEST MEGALOPOLIS IN THE
WORLD FROM- THE INTERNATIONAL
BORDER UP TO SANTA BARBARA.
SOMETIMES FISH SOUTHERN STILL
HAD HEARTY VERSIONS OF SALMON
SWIM BACK INTO. MALIBU CREEK
OR- TRIBUTE GO CREEK OR- DALY
RIVER OR VENTURA RIVER. THEY
PERSIST PERSIST OVER TIME
NATURE IS STRONG FOR JUST GIVE
HER HALF A CHANCE AND GIVING
OUR HAVE THE CHANCE INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE WE'RE GONNA TAKE
OUT SOME A DAM IN MATTEL HOT
CREEK TRIBUTARY TO THE VENTURA
RIVER AND OPEN UP ACCESS TO
SOUTHERN STILL HAD. AND IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE'RE GOING
TO COMPLETE IT'LL BE THE END OF
MAY BUT COMPLETE THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST DAM REMOVAL RIVER
RESTORATION PROJECT ON THE
KLAMATH. AND OPEN UP THAT RIVER
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED PLUS MILES
HISTORICAL HABITAT TO STAND
STILL. IF WE GIVE NATURE IN
THESE FISHES CHANCE BABY WILL
SURVIVE. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S- COMPLICATED BY THE FACT
IN MIND YOU. THESE FISH ARE
LIMITED TO LIVING ON THE TOP.
FLOOR AND DAMS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT FOR WATER IN THE
STATE WATER PROJECT ARE SO
LARGE AND INDISPENSABLE FOR
HUMAN HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE ARE
STUCK IN A SITUATION THINKING
ABOUT WATER MANAGEMENT OF THE
SCARCE RESOURCE IN A WARMING
CLIMATE. AND THESE FISH CANNOT
ACCESS HISTORICAL HABITAT I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TURN
TO THE OPTION OF PUTTING THEM
BACK ABOVE RIM DOWNS AS PART OF
OUR STRATEGY. BUT THEY SHOW AS
THEY CAN SURVIVE WE JUST HAVE
TO GIVE ME A CHANCE SO I REJECT
THE IDEA WE'RE GONNA LOSE
CENTRAL VALLEY SALMON AND
STEELHEAD. I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE RECOVERED PABLO
POPULATIONS WITHOUT A WHOLE
HECK OF A LOT OF HARD WORK. AND
TRYING THINGS AND BEEN WILLING
TO TRY AS A SOCIETY. ALSO JUST
VERY BRIEFLY A MORE POSITIVE-
SUBJECT YOU HAVE OVERSEEN- THE
KLAMATH RIVERS RESTORATION IN
THE- ELIMINATION OF THE KLAMATH
DAM- THAT THIS- LEGISLATURE
FUNDED I JUST WANTED TO SEE IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE US AN UPDATE
ON HOW THAT PROJECT IS GOING
AND- WHAT ITS CONTRIBUTION IS
GOING TO BE. GOING TO BE TWO
SEVEN RUNS. I THINK THE
CONTRIBUTION WILL BE IMMENSE I
DON'T RECALL OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD BUT THE PROJECTED MODELS
FOR FREE FLOWING RIVER AND
REBOUND OF POPULATIONS OVER
TIME IT'S QUITE LARGE. AT A
PROCESSING LEVEL WE ARE DOWN TO
COMPLETING THE ELEMENTS OF THIS
DECONSTRUCTION BUT- THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION IS
PREPARING ITS FINAL NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT
APPROVING WE HOPE REMOVAL. WE
EXPECT THAT- NEXT SPRING AND
SUMMER WE'RE COMPLETING ALL OF
THE RELEVANT STATE AND FEDERAL-
ANTI US FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS THE STATE WATER
BOARD. RECENTLY THIS SUMMER THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION APPROVED
TRANSFERRING THE LICENSE FOR
THESE DAMS FROM PACIFIC CORE
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY TO
THE CORPORATION AND THE STATES
OF OREGON AND CALIFORNIA FOR
THE EXPRESS PURPOSE OF REMOVAL.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF WORKING
WITH OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS AND
LOCAL COUNTIES TO DEAL WITH ANY
POTENTIAL IMPACTS FROM A BIG
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT MORE ON
PATH. TO DRAW DOWN RESERVOIRS
AND REMOVE THESE DAMS BEGINNING
AS SOON AS- THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SO THAT IS A VERY
OPTIMISTIC HOPE CENTER ARSON
LARGE PART BECAUSE YOUR
COMMITMENTS AND REQUIRES.
SIMPLY NUMBER ONCE AND THE
FINANCIAL FUNDING THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS
PROVIDED FOR THE PROJECT. THANK
YOU NOT FOR SAPAN I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO OUR STATE ALL THESE YEARS
AND ALL THE WONDERFUL THINGS
YOU'VE DONE. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO BRINGING YOU BACK TO
DECLINE A REBELLION PUTTING YOU
BACK ON A HORSE AGAIN FOR YOU
TO EXHIBIT. YOUR WONDERFUL EGGS
THE QUESTION SKILLS TO ALL OF
US. I'LL TRY NOT TO FALL OFF
THE NEXT TIME WE DO THAT IN THE
FUTURE. I THINK THE RUBY STORY
THERE IT WHICH I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING- SELLING
THANK YOU SO MUCH EITHER WAY SO
AND DAD PLEASE BRING PICTURE
SIR THAT'S FANTASTIC. I HOPE
THERE'S NO PICTURES THERE YOU
GO- I THINK THE FOCUS ON THE
SCENE I MEAN LOOK I THINK THAT-
WE'RE BEGINNING TO WATCH. THE
EXTINCTION OF A CONDUCT SPECIES
RIGHT IN FRONT OF OUR EYES. IN
EACH YEAR IT KEEPS GETTING
WORSE FOR SALMON HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. BUT I'M ALSO A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT ANTIQUATED
FEDERAL WATER POLICIES
CONTRIBUTED. TO THIS SPECIES
DECLINE IN OLD CEMENT. DIE OFF
BUT THAT WAS ALL OF US ARE SEEN
I HAVE A SEVEN MONTH OLD AT
HOME AND I AM VERY CONCERNED
THAT HE WILL NEVER SEE. SALMON
THAT WHEN A RUN IN THE
SACRAMENTO. SO THERE ARE
THERE'S SOME MOVEMENT PIVOTING
AWAY FROM THE TRUMP ERA
BIOLOGICAL OPINION FOR CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT WE STILL SEE THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS IN
PLACE IN THE SACRAMENTO. WHAT
DO YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT MR DIRECTOR BECAUSE I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER I THINK THERE
ARE. CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE THAT
FIRMLY BELIEVES THAT. FEDERAL
WATER POLICY HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN
ADDITION TO THE DROUGHT. AND
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE CAN'T
COUNT ON COLD WATER. IS BECAUSE
OF THE POLICIES OF THE PAST SO
MISTER DIRECTOR YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT. YES I'M
BECAUSE YOU ASK- I'LL BE
DIRECTING GIVE YOU MY VIEW SO.
AS MOST PARTICIPATING TO KNOW
TODAY REALIZE- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND OUR STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE CAPACITY OF OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL. DID CHALLENGE
IN FEDERAL COURT WHAT ARE
CALLED THE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IT'S A FANCY WORD FOR OPERATING
RULES. FOR THE- FEDERAL CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT. AND RECENTLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
AGREED AND INFORM THE FEDERAL
COURT THAT IT WILL GO BACK AND
REDO THOSE RULES. I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT OUTCOME I
THINK MANY IN THIS PHONE CALL
THAT MAY PRESENT ON SUBSEQUENT
PANELS HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
THAT OUTCOME. SO WE'LL END UP
WITH NEW OPERATING RULES THAT
GOVERN THE FEDERAL WATER
PROJECT. MY HOPE IS THAT THOSE
RULES CAN BE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION ACROSS ALL
AGENCIES BIOLOGICAL AGENCIES
AND WATER. BY AGENCIES THAT
THEY WILL ACCOUNT FOR ACTIVE
MEASURES THEY GIVE US A SENSE
OF IN ANY PLANNING CYCLE HOW
WILL HAVE PROTECTIVE THRESHOLDS
FOR SALMON AND STEELHEAD. MY
HOPE IS THAT WE'LL HAVE AN
APPROACH THAT THINKS THROUGH
THE INTEGRATION OF ALL THESE
MAJOR RESERVOIRS RELATIVE TO
COLD WATER AND HOW YOU MANAGE
RESERVOIRS. AND MY HOPE IS THE
OUTCOME WILL BE A MORE STABLE
CENTER RULES. STABLE FOR WATER
SUPPLY BUT ALSO MORE PROTECTIVE
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO. WORK THROUGH THAT IT'S
GONNA TAKE A COUPLE OF YEARS
THESE ARE NOT. PROCESS SEES
THAT SWITCH OVER NINE. IN THE
INTERIM MY OWN PERSONAL VIEWIS
NEXT CALENDAR YEAR OF THIS
WATER YEAR. MOST PEOPLE ARE ON
THE PHONE CALL I THINK REALIZE
WATER YEARS RUN FROM. YEAH END
OF OCTOBER THROUGH THE
FOLLOWING. AND I THINK NEXT
YEAR IS GOING TO BE JUST FINE
USUAL UNPRECEDENTED WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE HOUSE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A THIRD JURAI
CRITICALLY DRY HYDROLOGICALLY
ON PRESIDENT CHALLENGING YEAR.
AND WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT NEXT
YEAR MINE MINE OUTSIDE OUR
USUAL STATUS QUO MENTALITY WE
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT RISK
MANAGEMENT WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS OUR-
MOST IMAGINABLE. WORST CASE
SCENARIO AND THEN BE READY TO
DEAL WITH THAT AND I THINK WE
CAN. YEAH NO NINE AND MR GEORGE
I THINK WE WERE A 100%
AGREEMENT IN NIGHT- AND I DON'T
EVER WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
DIRECTOR OR THE AGENCY BUT- I
THINK HE WANTS TO MOVE WITH
SPEED I JUST DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE TIME. TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH TRADITIONAL RULE MAKING
PROCESS AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
SPECIES ON THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION IN IS ABSOLUTELY ON
THE BRINK OF EXTINCTION TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WAS BAD- TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WAS BAD IT
KEEPS GETTING WORSE AND NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING THROUGH A
RULEMAKING PROCESS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE STILL HAVE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS BY THE WAY
IN THE SACRAMENTO. IN THAT
WHOLE WINTER RUN- IS ABSOLUTELY
THREATENED TO GO EXTINCT HERE
IN THE COMING YEARS AND SO I
HAVE DEEP CONCERNS. ABOUT HOW
LONG THIS IS GOING TO TAKE- AND
WHAT THE RAMIFICATIONS ARE. IF
WE DON'T MOVE WITH SPEED. THAT
SO WHICH IS WHICH IS WHY FOR
NOW YEAR- I THINK OUR APPROACH
NEXT YEAR HAS TO INVOLVE
PRIVATIZATION I THINK WE AS
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO BE
THINKING FIRST ABOUT. WATER FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE CANDEAL
WITH PEOPLE HAVE WATER AT THEIR
TOP. THEN I THINK WENEED TO BE
LOOKING AT WHEN A RUN IN THE
SALMON RIVER. ARE IN THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER MANY THINKING
ABOUT TEMPERATURE CRITERIA. AND
MANAGING FOR THAT BECAUSE THESE
FISH MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
TOLERATE A THIRD YEAR LIKE THE
LAST TWO YEARS. AND AFTER WE
WORK THROUGH THAT PRIVATIZATION
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
OUR RESERVOIRS. THERE CARRY
OVER AS WE HEAD INTO THE
FOLLOWING CALENDAR YEAR AND
THEN DEALING WITH ALL THE VERY
IMPORTANT USES OF WATER OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY OUR
WILDLIFE REFUGES BUT WE'RE
GONNA NEED SOME. FORM OF
PRIVATIZATION THAT ALLOWS US TO
LOOK AT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THEN TRY TO FOCUS IN
AFTER THAT ON THESE WINTER RUNS
**** THAT'S MY- 100% I THINK
THE OTHER CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS IS. NOT WITHIN.
THE DIRECTORS. PURVIEW IS THAT
YOU KNOW THE STATE. I HAD
IMPLEMENTED NEW WATER FLOW
RULES BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN YET WE HAVEN'T
IMPLEMENTED THOSE NEW WATER
FLOW RULES THAT WOULD PROVIDE A
COLD WATER SOURCE- AND IN THE
MEANTIME. I'M GONNA KEEP GOING
BACK TO WHAT WERE SEEN AND
AGAIN THIS IS OUTSIDE OF THE.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE SPECIES
GOING EXTINCT EXTINCT IN FRONT
OF OUR EYES RIGHT NOW- AND IT
IS ICONIC FISHERY IN THE STATE
IT IS ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE
THAT WE MOVE WITH SPEED WE HAVE
RULES THAT WE COULD USE. A AND
FOR SOME REASON HAVE NOT BEEN
ENACTED INTO DEEP CONCERN WE'LL
ALSO HEAR FROM- ENVIRONMENTAL
AND CONSERVATION LEADERS IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS IN OUR NEXT
PANEL FOCUS ON THE DROUGHT
CRISIS IN SALMON FISHERIES IN
AND I DON'T WANNA LEAVE THIS
DISCUSSION LET ME SIMPLY BEING
CRITICAL BECAUSE I GOTTA SAY
DIRECTOR BONHAM HIS TEAMMATE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE QUITE FRANKLY OF
PROVIDING THE DEPARTMENT WITH
THE FUNDING THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE WITH SPEED TO BE
ABLE TO SAVE THIS SPECIES WITH
A BAND AID APPROACH RIGHT
HEARING ABOUT TRUCKING
LITERALLY SEVENTEEN MILLION.
FISHERY HATCHED SALMON AND
PUTTING THEM IN THE ACTUARIES
TO ENSURE THEIR SURVIVAL IS
CRITICAL BUT IT IS NOT A LONG
TERM STRATEGY FOR SUCCESS AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT LONG TERM POLICY
CHANGES OBVIOUSLY LOOKING
HEALTH ND SAFETY OF RESIDENTS
FIRST BUT THEN ALSO FOCUSING ON
THIS ICONIC FISH SPECIES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. I I'D LIKE TO-
JUST BECAUSE THE TIME MISTER.
DIRECTOR I'D LIKE TO JUMP TO.
ALL ISSUES OF IS. LOOK I'M JUST
GOING TO BE BLUNT TONIGHT I
DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL BUT
I'M VERY NERVOUS MISTER
DIRECTOR ABOUT HITTING THAT
THANKSGIVING MARKET- FOR-
DIGENIS CRAB. WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE MAJORITY DUNGEONS CRABS
CONSUME BETWEEN- THANKSGIVING
AND THE END OF THE YEAR- YOUR
CRYSTAL BALL NOW SIR AND I KNOW
YOU DON'T LIKE MAKING
PREDICTIONS. BUT I THINK IT IS
IN A FULL COURT PRESS TO TRY TO
BE ABLE TO GET THIS FISHERY
OPENED. AT A MINIMUM AT A
MINIMUM- FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON
WHEN IT COMES TO- CHRISTMAS.
THE NEW YEAR AND HANUKKAH- BUT
I'M NERVOUS IN REGARDS TO THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA MONTEREY
BAY AS WELL AS A CINEMA IN
MARIN COUNTY'S. BECAUSE OF THE
PRESENCE OF WALES IS THAT A-
CORRECT ASSESSMENT IN REGARDS
TO HITTING THESE GIVING BUT
REALLY TRYING TO PUSH FOR THE
HOLIDAY SEASON FOR CHRISTMAS.
I'M NERVOUS LIKE YOU YEAH. I'VE
LIVED THROUGH THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WITH YOU- I THINK RIGHT
NOW. WE JUST NEED TO ACCEPT THE
CALENDAR SPACE BETWEEN NOVEMBER
FOURTH. AND THANKSGIVING IS
SHRINKING AND THERE'S A LT OF
STUFF WE HAVE TO DO ON OUR
SIDE. RELATIVE TO THAT KIND OF
THANKSGIVING MARKER WE NEED TO
KEEP GETTING IN THE AIR AS MUCH
AS WE CAN FOR AERIAL SURVEYS
THAT TAKES GETTING UP THERE
WEATHER PERMITTING PROCESSING
THAT DATA WE NEED TO KEEP OPEN
THE OTHER INFORMATION STREAMS
LIKE CASCADIA. WHALE WATCH BUT
THEN WE WOULD NEED TO PROCESS
ALL THAT INFORMATION. WE HAVE A
RISK ASSESSMENT. MOMENT ON THE
CALENDAR WITH THE COLLABORATIVE
WORKING GROUP COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL CONSERVATION
GROUPS IS CURRENTLY SCHEDULED I
THINK FOR NOVEMBER A- WE NEED
TO THEN. ENGAGE THE WORKING
GROUP WE NEED TO TURN AROUND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE NEED TO
GO BACK OUT FOR NOTICE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY THE RULES AND
LAWS WORK. EVEN IF WE GOT SUPER
FORTUNATE AND THE WHALES AND
TURTLES OF ACTUALLY DEPARTED.
IT WOULD STILL BE A VERY TIGHT
SQUEEZE TO TRY TO GET ALL THAT
DONE BEFORE THANKSGIVING IT'S
POSSIBLE. WE SHOULD HOLD OUT
HOPE THAT HOPE IS NOT A
STRATEGY. SO I THINK
SIMULTANEOUSLY AT THE
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE AN EYE ON
THANKSGIVING BUT WE ALSO HAVE
AN EYE ON YOU KNOW THE END OF
DECEMBER I THINK ANNIKA'S MUCH
EARLIER THIS YEAR BUT LET'S SAY
MID IN DECEMBER STARTED THE NEW
YEAR. SADLY A COUPLE OF THE
LAST CYCLES WE'VE MISSED ALL
THE HOLIDAY SEASON. GETTING A
NEW YEAR. SO WE HAVE AN EYE ON
THANKSGIVING BUT WE ALSO HAVE
AN EYE ON THAT DECEMBER PERIOD
AND IF WE CAN'T GET
THANKSGIVING WE ARE TRYING TO
WORK TOWARDS DECEMBER. YOU KNOW
THIS- WE HAVE TRIED THIS
SEVERAL TIMES THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND WHEN THE DEPARTMENT.
GEARS OUT I'M A GUYVER WAY
BALANCE WHALES AND GET THE
FLEET SOAP AND OCCASIONALLY THE
FLEET HAS DECIDED THEY DON'T
WANT TO GO FISH. SO I'M SUPER
NERVOUS WE'LL TRY THIS AGAIN
AND THE FLEET. CURRENT IS IN
THE EYE WITH A FINGER AT THE
END OF THE DAY SO WE'VE GOT TO
WORK THROUGH IT TOGETHER. HAVE
ANY CHANCE OF GETTING BOATS OUT
COMMERCIALLY IT'S TIME FOR THE
END OF THE YEAR HOLIDAYS LET
ALONE THANKSGIVING YEAH WHAT
I'M HOPING IS BECAUSE- FROZEN
STOCK HAS BEEN DEPLETED BECAUSE
THE BLEAK YEAR LAST YEAR- THERE
ISN'T A LOT OF. SUPPLY LEFT- IN
FREEZERS FOR FROM PROCESSORS
WHICH MEANS I'M HOPING THAT
PRICE YEAH I'M JUST GOING TO BE
VERY BLUNT HERE MISTER DIRECTOR
I'M HOPING THAT PRICES AT A
GOOD POINT SO THAT THE FLEET
CAN GO OUT ABOUT ONCE WHALES
HAVE MOVED SOUTH FOR THE
WINTER- AND WE CAN GET THIS
SEASON KICKED OFF. BECAUSE I
THINK THT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
UNDERTONES OF THIS TOO IS
OBVIOUSLY THE FLEET HAS DONE
ALL THEY CAN AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU BECAUSE THE FLEET IS
STEPPED UP BIG TIME TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE STATE TO
INSURE THAT THERE ISN'T A
PRESENCE OF WHALES AND THEY
BROUGHT THAT FOR THEMSELVES AND
BY THE WAY WE'LL ENTANGLEMENTS.
ARE DOWN AND MENTALLY OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS I THINK WE'RE
AT LIKE SIXTY SEVEN OR SEVENTY
TWO JUST FIVE YEARS AGO I THINK
WE HAD ONE OR TWO LAST YEAR- MR
DIRECTOR I MEAN IT IT'S DOWN
CONSIDERABLY- AND I'M HOPING
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A GOOD
PRICE YEAR SINCE THERE REALLY
ISN'T ANY STOCK LEFT I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD ON THAT
MISTER DIRECTOR THIRTY SECONDS.
TWO THINGS ELSE WE HAVE TO KEEP
IN MIND WE DO HAVE SOME HOT
CRAB SAMPLES IN THE SPACE OF
DEMONIC ACID I UNDERSTAND THAT
SURROUND THE RUSSIAN RIVER
MOUTH. I THINK WE HAVE ONE AT
EIGHT PM ONE THAT COULD YOU
KNOW FACTOR INTO HOW WE OPEN.
THE NORTHERN PORTION OF ZONE
THREE. AND THEN- FOR THE LIFE
OF ME I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT
MYSELF- I KNOW MY SECOND
THOUGHT IS REMEMBER BECAUSE OF
S. B. EIGHTY WE WILL NOW HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL NUANCES ON
GIVING RECREATIONAL AS SOME
DIFFERENT PRE SOAK AND HEAD
START THAT COULD FACTOR INTO
THE POTENTIAL FOR US GETTING
COMMERCIAL OPEN BY THANKSGIVING.
I'M GONNA WORK WE'RE GONNA WORK
THROUGH AN HOURLY WE'RE ON THE
PHONE ALL DAY LONG THIS TIME OF
THE YEAR I CAN SET MY WATCH TO
IT. AND I THANK YOUR STAFF
CONSULTANTS AND YOU PERSONALLY
AND EACH MEMBER OF THE FLEET
BECAUSE IT'S THAT DATED A
CONVERSATION THAT GIVES THE
CHANCE TO BE CREATED. YEAH I
KNOW YOU ACTUALLY READ VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE HARDWORKING NO
OPPENHEIM WHO DOES THE GOOD
WORK AS A CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AND- IN
FACT AT THE TRACTOR AND I'M
GOING TO BE ON A CALL LATER
TODAY. TALKING ABOUT ALL ISSUES
OF SALMON AND CRAB AND I DO
APPRECIATE HIS AVAILABILITY AND
HIS TEAM TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH ANALYTICS IN A WAY SO
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MR DIRECTOR WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU A CLOSING
WORDS HERE. AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE ON THE MOVE TO
OUR NEXT PANEL. ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS MISTER DIRECTOR. TAKE
CARE YOURSELF EVERYONE- IT'S
BEEN A HECK OF A COUPLE YEARS
AND I GOT INTO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK SPACE
BECAUSE THE SALMON ACTUALLY
TOOK SALMON LAW IN LAW SCHOOL
AS I PUT MYSELF THROUGH LAW
SCHOOL. AND I KNOW THAT IT CAN
FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN THE BLEAKEST
MOMENTS. WE CAN DO THIS
CALIFORNIA SHOWS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. SO LET'S NOT LOSE THESE
FISH THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT CHUCK BONHAM
DIRECTOR FISH WILDLIFE VERY
GRATEFUL MR BRYANT THANK YOU
FOR MAKING YOURSELF AVAILABLE
AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE IN
REGARDS TO THE DELAY- IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. SO YEAH
HE ENDED IT THE DIRECTOR ENDED
IT TALKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
THAT WE SAVE THIS ICONIC.
FISHERY HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE IN OUR NEXT PANEL IS
GONNA BE FOCUSED IN ON THE DRUG
CRISIS IN SALMON FISHERIES SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM JOHN MCMANUS IS
PRESIDENT OF THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION. WILL THEN
HEAR FROM GEORGE BRAD SHOT HE'S
PRESIDENT OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND THEN WE'LL-
ROUNDED UP WITH DOUG- BGG HE'S
AT HE'S SENIOR ATTORNEY FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MR
MCMANUS FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY. MR MCMANUS IS BACK WITH
US TO PROVIDE REALLY A LIVING
COLOUR UPDATE ON THE PLIGHT OF
SALMON INTERSTATE NO ONE DOES
THESE PRESENTATIONS BETTER HE
DOES A DEEP DIVE QUICKLY AND IS
ABLE TO MOVE THROUGH A LOT OF
INFORMATION. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO MR MCMANUS AND
OF COURSE TO THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION THEY HAVE
BEEN TENACIOUS IN THEIR
ADVOCACY. FOR NEW WATER RULES
FOR CHALLENGES ON THE SECOND
AND ON SO MANY OTHER
TRIBUTARIES IN WATERSHEDS
ACROSS THE STATE MR MCMANUS
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE WITH
US YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES. YOUR
PRESENTATION IF YOU DON'T MIND
KICKING OFF THE DRUG CRISIS. IN
SALMON FISHERIES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SENATOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. THE COMPANY NOT
PRETTY GOOD SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE SEE YOU CLEARLY IS WHAT
WELCOME. STRAIGHT FIRST- I
WOULD LIKE TO A- SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS OF- DIRECTOR BOTTOM
ABOUT THE NEED TO CONSIDER
TRAPPING ALL PROGRAMS TO GET
FISH ABOVE WRITTEN DOWNS- AS A
NEXT STEP WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO
SEE A PROPOSAL. COME FORWARD-
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON HOW TO
DO THAT- DIRECTOR BOTTOM
MENTIONED- BATTLE CREEK WELL
NOT SO MUCH BATTLE CREEK BUT
THE MCCLOUD RIVER ON THE
SACRAMENTO. YEAH THERE ARE
CERTAINLY SPOTS ON- BUTTE CREEK
THE FEATHER RIVER AND THE YUBA
RIVER. ALL WOULD INVITE THAT
TYPE OF ACTION SO I JUST WANNA
SAY THAT SOUNDS GOOD TO US AND
WE WOULD LOVE TO PARTICIPATE
I'M GONNA TRY AND SHARE MY
SCREEN RIGHT NOW. AND ARE YOU
SEE IN MY POWER POINT YOU ARE
NOW UP AND RUNNING IF YOU WANT
TO GO TO FULL SCREEN WE CAN SEE
IT CLEARLY THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
SEMANAS. GONNA TRY HERE- DID
YOU SEE THAT YOU ARE GOOD IN
GOLDEN PLEASE PROCEED SO THAT'S
WHO WE ARE I'M NOT GONNA TAKE A
LOT OF TIME THERE'S SO MANY
TOPICS TO COVER I JUST HAD TO
NARROW IT DOWN HOPEFULLY TO
JUST A FEW TODAY FIRST OF ALL
WE'D LIKE TO ASK- THE HELP OF
THE COMMITTEE IN GETTING A
REPORT EVENTUALLY FROM CDFW ON
THE LOSS OF FALL RUN THIS YEAR
WE EXPECT THERE WILL BE- PLENTY
OF REPORTS ON THE LOSS OF THE
LISTED WINTER AND SPRING RUN WE
DON'T GET THOSE SAME TYPE OF
REPORTS ON FALL RUN WITHOUT
ASKING FOR ON. THIS COMMITTEE
DID THIS ONCE BEFORE THE LAST
DROUGHT WE'D ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE PURSUE THAT AGAIN. I
WANT TO SHIFT OVER NOW AND SAY
A FEW WORDS ABOUT THE FEATHER
RIVER. COME TO OUR ATTENTION
THAT THERE IS A REALLY BAD-
DISEASE PATHOGEN IN THE FEATHER
RIVER CALLED C. SHASTA. IT'S
THE SAME DISEASE PATHOGEN THAT.
ANNUALLY TAKES OUT. ALL KINDS
OF JUVENILE SALMON ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER. I'VE COME TO
FIND OUT IT'S PROBABLY AS
PREVALENT AND PERHAPS EVEN MORE
SO IN THE FEATHER RIVER. AND IT
AFFLICTS A JUVENILE FISH ON
THEIR WAY OUT OF THE RIVER AND
ITS LETHAL- IN A RECENT SURVEY
I WAS TOLD THAT. OF FISH TRAP
TO THE UPPER FEATHER RIVER AND
RE TRAPPED A MERE FOURTEEN
MILES DOWNSTREAM. ONLY 50% OF
THEM SHOWED UP FOURTEEN MILES
DOWNSTREAM THE REST FOR LOST.
AND THOSE TRAPPED DOWNSTREAM
WERE ALL INFECTED WITH C.
SHASTA SO. THE CHANCE THEY
NEVER MADE IT OUT TO THE OCEAN.
THE FEATHER RIVER HATCHERY IS
TOLD US THIS YEAR THAT THEY'LL
PRODUCE AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION FISH OVER
AND ABOVE NORMAL QUOTA- TO
MITIGATE FOR DROUGHT WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT. WE'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT BECAUSE OF THE C.
SHASTA. THAT THE FEATHER RIVER
HATCHERY CONSIDER PRODUCING
THIS ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE MILLION EVERY YEAR GOING
FORWARD. THE C. SHASTA THE
FEATHER RIVER IS PROBABLY DUE
TO A WATER TEMPERATURES OF LOW
FLOWS WHICH IS WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OTHER RIVERS AND THAT CAN BE
DIRECTLY TRACED BACK TO
OPERATION. OF LAKE ORVILLE
ORVILLE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES SO WE WOULD
SUGGEST AS PART OF A FULL
MITIGATION RESPONSIBILITY- THE
HATCHERY CONSIDER PRODUCING
THESE ADDITIONAL FISH GOING
FORWARD. ALSO RIGHT NOW THE
HATCHERY THERE TO FILL THE
RIVERS RELEASING ABOUT A
MILLION HATCHERY FISH INTO THE
FEATHER RIVER ANNUALLY- THIS IS
BEEN GOING ON FOR ABOUT FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS THE CODED WIRE TAG.
DATA FROM THESE VICIOUS PRETTY
CLEAR WE'RE LOSING A MALL.
BETWEEN PREDATION AND C.
SHASTA. THIS IS A- A WASTE
BASICALLY. BEFORE FIVE SEVEN
YEARS AGO THESE FISH FOR TRUCK
TO THE BAY AND CONTRIBUTED TO
THE FISHERIES BUT THEY NO
LONGER DO. SO WE'D LIKE TO ASK
FOR CONSIDERATION THAT THIS
PRACTICE EITHER BE ELIMINATED.
OR THIS ONE MILLION FISH
RELEASED BE GREATLY PARED DOWN
TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
FISH AT THE MOST. THAT SHOULD
SUPPLY THE STATISTICAL VALIDITY
FOR ANY DATA- THAT IS BEING
GATHERED FROM THIS PRACTICE. I
WANT TO SHIFT DOWN TO SPEAK
BRIEF WE HAVE- WERE FISHER. IN
IT OR SAN. BAY THE TRADITIONAL
AND HISTORIC RELEASE LOCATIONS
AROUND VALLEJO. OVER THE LAST
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS FISHER BEEN
RELEASED OUT OF SAUSALITO.
ENOUGH DATA HAS NOW BEEN
COLLECTED BUT WE CAN SEE
CLEARLY. THAT SAUSALITO RELEASE
FISH SURVIVE IT ABOUT TWICE.
WHAT THE FISH RELEASED IN
VALLEJO SURVIVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS- PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT STARTING TO CONSIDER
MOVING RELEASES FURTHER WEST.
BUT WE WANT TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THAT. IT'S NOT CLEAR OTHER THAN
THE LOGISTICS THAT VALLEJOS
CLOSER AND HAS. EASY FACILITIES
TO WORK IT IS NOT CLEAR WHY WE
SHOULDN'T BE MOVING ALL OF OUR
RELEASES FURTHER WEST. IT GIVES
US BASICALLY. THE EQUIVALENT OF
EE OUR HATCHERY PRODUCTION
SIMPLY BY KEEPING THE TRUCKS ON
THE ROAD JUST A FEW MORE MILES
AND GETTING THEM OUT NEAR THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE- I WANT TO
SWITCH AGAIN AND SPEAK REAL
BRIEFLY ABOUT CODED WIRE TAGS.
THESE ARE THE LITTLE BITS OF
WIRE- THAT- IN PLACED INTO THE
SNOUT. OF JUVENILE SALMON. THE
SALMON HAVE TO BE ABOUT THREE
INCHES LONG. IN ORDER FOR THE
MACHINES TO DO THIS IN MASS
QUANTITIES TO HANDLE THEM BUT
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU'RE
GROWN THREE INCHES BIG ENOUGH-TO RECEIVE THAT TAG. YOU'RE
BURNING UP THE CALENDAR YOU'VE
GONE FROM WINTER INTO SPRING.
AND IF THESE FISH RLEASED INTO
THE SACRAMENTO BASIN BY APRIL
YOU'VE GOT- AGRICULTURAL WATER
DIVERSIONS- REDUCING THE
QUALITY OF THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
FOR THESE FISH TO GET OUT. AND
YOU ALSO HAVE PREDATORS LIKE
STRIPED BASS AND START TO SWIM
UP INTO THE RIVER AND GOBBLE
THESE FISH. SO THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION HAS
PARTNERED THIS YEAR WITH US
FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE OF
THE COLEMAN NATIONALHATCHERY
TO TRY A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
COLEMAN HATCHERY WILL PRODUCE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION FISH
THIS YEAR BUT INSTEAD OF
GROWING ABOUT TO THREE INCHES
AND TAGGING THEM. WE'RE TAKING
TISSUE SAMPLES FROM THE ADULT
FISH THE PARROT FISH THAT'S A
SHOT OF ME UP BUT- CALLED IN A
FEW WEEKS AGO. THOSE TISSUE
SAMPLES WILL BE ANALYZED FOR
THEIR DNA. AND THREE YEARS FROM
NOW WHEN THE OFFSPRING SWIM
BACK UP TO THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
AND SHE SHE WAS SAMPLED. A DNA
ANALYSIS WILL BE DONE ON A MAN
WILL BE ABLE TO COMPARE WHICH
OF THOSE RETURNING FISH WERE
BORN FROM- THE FISH BEING
RELATE THAT'LL BE RELEASED THIS
COMING SPRING AT ABOUT TWO
INCHES OF. INSIGHTS AND ONE OF
THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
RELEASING HIM AT TWO INCHES IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RELEASED
IN PROBABLY IN EARLY TO MID
FEBRUARY. WHEN THE RIVER IS
STILL RELATIVELY HIGH. SO THIS
IS AN EXCITING PROJECT YEAH AND
IT MAY BE ONE FOR STATE
HATCHERIES TO CONSIDER.
REPLICATING AND I WILL STOP
THEIR- THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MCMANUS WE'RE GONNA GET BACK TO
YOU WITH QUESTIONS IN JUST A
FEW MOMENTS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT YEAH THAT'S ON
THE BAND'S PRESS IN THE GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HEAR. FROM THE
FISHERIES- IN THE FLEET IN HIS
NAME IS GEORGE FRANCHISE PRESS
IN THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
OF FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION.
HE'S GONNA TELL US WHAT HE'S
SEEN OUT ON THE WATER- AND
AGAIN JUST A REMINDER EVEN
THOUGH WE MAY HAVE A GOOD
SALMON SEASON THIS YEAR- THE
MORE WE SEE A DAYDIE OFF. FOR
THE WINTER RUN MEANS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
SO MR BRANCH ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECONDS
FROM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK SIR. THANK YOU THANK YU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
HERE- YOU KNOW LIKE YOU SAID
I'M COMMERCIAL SALMON
FISHERMEN- BASED OUT OF
CRESCENT CITY CALIFORNIA BUT-
I'D LIKE TO START OFF WITH A
BRIEF. REPORTS IN THE WATER
THIS SEASON- YOU KNOW WE SAW
GREAT OCEAN CONDITIONS UP AND
DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST. ARE
CONDUCIVE TO SALMON SURVIVAL-
YOU KNOW THIS SEASON STRUCTURES
WERE DRASTICALLY CUT BY. UP TO
FIFTY PERCENT- FROM THE
HISTORICAL DATES WITH. NO ZERO
OUR COMMERCIAL AND ABOUT A
MONTH RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
ON THE CLIMATE MANAGEMENT ZONE-
YOU KNOW CATCH ENDED UP BEING
ABOVE. YOU KNOW WHAT THE MODELS
PREDICTED- YOU KNOW HOWEVER
LIKE CHUCK SAID. THOSE WERE
FROM. THOSE WERE FROM THE OLD.
FISH THAT WERE ABLE TO SURVIVE
IN THE LAST WET CYCLE. SO YOU
KNOW THAT. IN TURN IS IT GOING
TO BE YOU KNOW. WHAT WILL BE IN
THE OCEAN NEXT YEAR. AFTER
THAT- YOU KNOW. I THANK YOU
FOR. YOU KNOW A LOT OF. THE
ISSUES THAT CHALK MENTIONED-
YOU KNOW AFTER YOUR FORMS AND
YOU KNOW IN FIRST DR UPDATES.
ARE ALL FALL ON DESPERATELY
NEEDED- YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T
HEARD A WHOLE LOT OF TALK ON
THE KLAMATH. ON YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK ON
CENTRAL VALLEY SHOW ALL GIVE A
BRIEF KLAMATH UPDATE- THE OTHER
WAS. OBVIOUSLY AGAIN A LARGE C.
SHASTA FISH KILL ON YOU KNOW
THIS SPRING ON THE KLAMATH
SYSTEM ITSELF. WHICH ULTIMATELY
LED FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
CDFW TWO TRUCKS FISH FROM IRON
GATE OUTREACH TO OTHER
FACILITIES TO HOLD THEM OVER-
WHICH PREVENTED CERTAIN DEATH-
BY THE TIME YOU KNOW THAT THEY
WERE. READY AND ACCLIMATED
INSTALL CHAD- LIKE JOHN JUST
MENTIONED YOU KNOW ENCODER WIRE
TAG. THOSE FISHER STILL
CURRENTLY BEING HELD IN
FACILITIES- YOU KNOW TO BE
RELEASED. SHORTLY WHEN THERE
IS. NO BETTER RIVER CONDITIONS.
EARLY REPORTS- FROM THE THIS
YEAR FROM THE ANGLER- YOU KNOW
ON THE RIVER. WAS THAT THERE
WAS A DECENT RETURN TO FINISH
ON THIS FALL. HOWEVER THOUGH
YOU KNOW THE CLIMATE SYSTEM YOU
KNOW IT IS STILL IN AN OVERALL
VERY POOR STATE- YOU KNOW THIS
CONTINUES FOR THE NEED OF WHAT
DIRECTOR BONHAM MENTIONED- ARM
NO. MORE WE NEED TO HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
YOU KNOW IMPROVING THIS REVERSE
CONDITIONS ON DAM REMOVAL-
WHICH SHE SPOKE ABOUT WAS AND
IS POTENTIALLY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST. BENEFIT SURE NO
BENEFITS SO WE COULD HAVE BY-
HELPING FLUSH OUT THAT SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW OPEN UP. ON WHAT
HE REFERENCED YOU KNOW UPWARDS
OF THREE HUNDRED MILES OF
SPAWNING HABITAT UPSTREAM ON.
NO BUT THERE'S NOT NO THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S YOU KNOW SHOULD
NOT CONSIDER OUR CONCERNS ON
THE KLAMATH RIVER WE HAVE LARGE
CONCERNS WITH BASALT COLO ON
YOUR OWN A LARGELY LIVE IN THE
TRIBUTARIES OF THE KLAMATH-
YOU'RE ON THERE'S OVERWHELMING
CONCERNS WITH. THE CO HOST ON
KUDLOW THAT ARE IN THE SCOTTISH
JOHNSTON TRIBUTARIES- DUE TO
YOU KNOW VERY POOR HABITAT AND
THE LACK OF. OF WATER QUALITY
AND LACK OF FLOW FROM YOUR- IN
THIS LAST YEAR THERE WAS SOME
SOME TALKING AND SOME- MINIMUM
LOWER REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR THE
SCOTTISH ROSTER RIVER WHICH YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS I'M AWARE OF WAR
MARSHALL VOLUNTARY ON YOUR
GREAT STEPS FORWARD BY. I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
CONVERSATION ON POTENTIALLY
MAKING THOSE MANDATORY AND
SETTING CRITERIA ON WHEN. WHY
AND HOW. ARE ALL ON DO WE NEED
TO LOOK INTO POLICIES- YOU KNOW
IN IN THE RIVER SYSTEMS
OURSELVES- YOU KNOW. REVIEW
WHAT IS WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING ON NEW AGREEMENTS LIKE
A SAFE HARBOR AGREEMENT ON THE
SHOP STOCK- THE ALL GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT YOU KNOW. JUST
RELOOK AT STOP AND SEE WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS ACTUALLY HELPING
SH MOM THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF CONVERSATION BETWEEN
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS-
SURROUNDING THE SALMON ISSUES-
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF AND
FORMING A COALITION- IN RIVER
AND OCEAN STAKEHOLDERS. TO
HELP- FORMER COP- HELP HOLD
FORMAL CONVERSATIONS WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES ARMONK
POTENTIAL IDEAS TO. HELP OUR
SALMON SPECIES. I YOU KNOW IDEA
IN AND HAS BEEN TOUCHED ON BY
DIRECTOR BONHAM AND BY. JOHN
MCMANUS BEFORE ME- YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO MAXIMIZE THE EFFICIENCY
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
HATCHERY OPERATIONS- YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN AROUND TWENTY YEARS.
SINCE THERE HAVE NO BEEN
UPDATED AND NOT JUST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK TRUCK
DIRECTOR BONG WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHICH IS GREAT TO HEAR ALSO THE
POLICIES ON OF THEIR OPERATIONS
IN THE STRATEGIES OF RELEASE-
YOU KNOW GIVEN DROUGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE GLOBAL WARMING. YOUR
RADIC WEATHER CONDITIONS. ON
YOUR JUST MAKES SENSE TO OPEN
THE BOOKS BASICALLY AND LOOK
BACK INTO WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S
NOT WORKING YOU KNOW WHAT HAS
WORKED IN THE PAST- AND LOOKING
TO THE FUTURE. SO THAT WE COULD
YOU KNOW. HOPEFULLY HI- SALMON
IN THE FUTURE- THE THOROUGH.
THIRTY SECONDS YES PLEASE ALL
RIGHT ARM NO ONE OF THE MAIN
IDEAS AND STRATEGIES THAT HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT- YOU KNOW IS
THE IDEA OF A HYBRID EDGE
FRYING A SMALL RELEASE WHICH
WILL. BE CENTRALLY TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF LIQUID NO JOHN DID
A LITTLE PRESENTATION ON OF YOU
KNOW GETTING FISH INTO THE
RIVER SYSTEMS MIGHT BE
NATURALLY WOULD AS IF THEY YOU
KNOW SPAWNED OUT OF THE GROUND
WAR. EARLY IN THE YEAR YOU KNOW
LATE JANUARY FEBRUARY TIME
FRAME ON WHEN RIVER CONDITIONS
ARE THE BEST THING WHEN THE C.
SHASTA PARASITES- YOU ARE
DORMANT AND YOU KNOW TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF NATURE WHEN NATURE
IS THERE TO HELP US- BUT THEN
ALSO USING YOU KNOW THE SMALL
RELEASE STRATEGIES WHICH HAS
SUSTAINED THE FISHERY SENSE
AROUND TWO THOUSAND- YOU KNOW
AND THE ABILITY TO TRACK. WHEN
THOSE CONDITIONS ARE PRESENT
AND ARE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I
THINK COORDINATION LIKE WAS
MENTIONED BETWEEN WATER D. W.
R. AGENCY STAFFER RELEASES CALL
FLOWS ARM DON'T MAKE SENSE. ARE
STANDARDIZING THE APPROACH FOR
TRUCKING THE FINISH ON YOUR WIN
IN RIVER CRITERIA IS MET OR
WHEN IN RIVER. CONDITIONS ARE
SO POOR THAT- YOU KNOW THEY
WON'T MAKE IT ON. THANK YOU MR
BURCH I'M VERY GRATEFUL- THANK
YOU SO MUCH I AM. TRULY
APPRECIATE MY BRATCHER TO AT
BOTH ON THE NORTH COAST AND
THROUGH THE STATE HE'S PRESENT
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION- WELL
OBVIOUSLY MISTER ROGERS MAY
HANG IN WITH US TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. IN NOW
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM DOUG OBG HE SENIOR
ATTORNEY FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL- YOU
WE ALL KNOW WHEN HE'S PRESENTED
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE
BEFORE HE'S GONNA BE PROVIDING
AN UPDATE ON CALIFORNIA'S. SAME
SITUATION TALK ABOUT THE WATER
MANAGEMENT PROCESS AND ITS
IMPACTS ON FISH. FISHERIES IN
OF COURSE- THE ENVIRONMENT
WATERSHEDS MISTER BIJOU WE
WELCOME YOU BACK. IN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK SIR YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR IN FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT KIND
INVITATION AND IT REALLY IS AN
HONOR TO BE HERE AND PRESENTING
IT. BUSY CREATOR FISHERIES
FORUM REALLY ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE HERE FOR A
HEARD FROM THE DIRECTOR TODAY
CALIFORNIA SALMON ARE FACING A
BLEAK FUTURE WITH MANY RUNS
FACING EXTINCTION IN THE COMING
YEARS IF WE DON'T CHANGE
COURSE. EARNING NOT ONLY THE
FISH BUT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES FISHING COMMUNITIES AND
ALL THOSE WHO CARE ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH. BUT THAT STORY HAS NOT
YET BEEN TOLD HAS NOT BEEN
WRITTEN AND THAT OUTCOME IS NOT
A FATE ACCOMPLI. THE FOCUS OF
MY TESTIMONY TODAY WILL BE ON
CHINOOK SALMON IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DEVASTATING SITUATION PASTING
DATA. NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES.
AND THE SAME THEY DEPEND ON IN
THE KLAMATH BASIN INCLUDING
THE- CONTRAST RIVERS. MANY OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT SAME INCREASE
IN THOSE STREAMS. ARE THE SAME
AS THE PROBLEMS WE FACE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY LACK OF ADEQUATE
INSTREAM FLOWS IN EXCESS OF
WATER TEMPERATURES LARGELY
CAUSED BY OVER ALLOCATION OF
WATER RIGHTS AND UNSUSTAINABLE
WATER DIVERSIONS. AND THOSE
ADVERSE IMPACTS ARE ARE FAR
MORE SEVERE IN DROUGHT YEARS
LIKE THIS. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE ARE FACING
DEVASTATING MORTALITY THIS
YEAR. YESTERDAY I RECEIVED AN
UPDATE FROM THE FEDERAL
NATIONAL. MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE ESTIMATING THAT. THEY
NOW ESTIMATE THAT 75% OF THE
HIGHLY ENDANGERED WINTER RUN
CHINOOK SALMON WERE KILLED THIS
YEAR SOLELY BY LEGAL WATER
TEMPERATURE. AND WHEN YOU ADD
IN THE ADDITIONAL MAN MADE AND
NATURAL MORTALITY IT APPEARS
THAT ONLY 122% OF THESE
ENDANGERED BABIES DEMONSTRATE
JUST THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF
THEIR LIVES. AND MIGRATE DOWN
TO THE REQUEST THE REGION DAM
IN THE UPPER SACRAMENTO RIVER.
MEANS EVEN FEWER OF THEM WILL
SURVIVE THEIR MIGRATION DOWN
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER THROUGH
THE DELTA THREE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY. AND THEN SPENDING TWO TO
THREE YEARS IN THE OCEAN BEFORE
RETURNING TO SPAWN. THAT'S
BECAUSE THE SCIENCE IS VERY
CLEAR. THAT LOWER CLOSING THESE
RIVERS MEANS FEWER FISH
SURVIVING. AND IT'S NOT JUST
THE ENDANGERED SALMON RUNS THIS
YEAR WE'RE LIKELY TO ALSO SEE
SEVERE TEMPERATURE MORTALITY OF
FALL RUN CHINOOK SALMON WHICH
ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
STATEMENT VICTORY. AS WATER
TEMPERATURES IN THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER EXCEED FIFTY NINE DEGREES.
DURING THE LAST ROUTE WE
STOPPED CATASTROPHIC MORTALITY
OF PAUL RUN WATSON 3% PAID A
PRICE OR BUY ONE. SHE IT'S MASS
MORTALITY IS NOT SIMPLY TE
RESULT OF DROUGHT CONDITIONS
WHICH ARE STILL HERE THIS YEAR.
BUT IS REALLY ALSO A FUNCTION
OF OUR ANTIQUATED WATER RIGHT
SYSTEM AND THE LACK OF
ENFORCEABLE PROTECTIONS FOR
SALMON UNDER STATE FEDERAL LAW.
INSTEAD OF MAINTAINING ADEQUATE
WATER TEMPERATURE TRISTAN IS
REQUIRED UNDER WATER RIGHTS
ORDER NINETY DASH FIVE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE STATE
WATER BOARD ALLOW THE STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS TO DRAIN
SHASTA RESERVOIR OTHER UPSTREAM
RESERVOIRS IN ORDER TO ALLOCATE
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION ACRE
FEET OF WATER TO THE
CONTRACTORS. LEAVING SALMON
WITHOUT THE COLD WATER THEY
NEED TO SURVIVE. THAT MASSIVE
MORTALITY WAS AUTHORIZED BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S TWENTY
NINETEEN BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS.
WHICH PURPORT TO ALLOW THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT TO KILL
1100% OF THE ENDANGERED SALMON
IN THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS
BEFORE THE BIOLOGICAL OPINION
WOULD BE VIOLATED. THAT TRULY
AND QUITE LITERALLY HAS A. PLAN
FOR EXTENSION OF OUR SALMON
RUNS. WHAT'S IS THAT THESE
DECISIONS MEANS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAVE EXTREMELY LOW WATER STORED
IN OUR RESERVOIRS. TO GO INTO
THIS YEAR. AND WHILE THE LATE
OCTOBER STORM WAS IMPRESSIVE IT
HARDLY MADE A DENT IN MOST OF
OUR RESERVOIRS MOST OF WHICH
ARE STILL AT NEAR RECORD LOW
LEVELS. OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
DRY AS PREDICTED BY THE LONG
RANGE WEATHER FORECAST
CONDITIONS FOR SALMON ARE
LIKELY TO BE EVEN WORSE THIS
YEAR. BUT EXCESSIVE MORTALITY
DUE TO LEGAL WATER TEMPERATURES
LOOK CLOSE. DROUGHTS ARE
INEVITABLE AND PERSONABLE AND
SENATORS HAVE SURVIVED DROUGHTS
FOR MILLENNIA. BUT THE IMPACTS
OF DROUGHT OR NOW MORE SEVERE
FIRST CAME IN THEY WERE
NATURALLY BECAUSE OF THE
EXCESSIVE. TEMPERATURES AFTER
THE LAST ROUND ENDED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
STATE WATER BOARD ADMITTED THAT
THE WAIVER OF DELTA WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS TO TEMPORARY
POSITIONS AND THE FAILURE TO
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE TEMPERATURE
WELL BELOW SHASTA DAM WAS QUOTE
NOT SUSTAINABLE PROFESSIONAL
WILDLIFE AND THAT CHANGES TO
THE DROP PLANNING RESPONSE
PROCESS ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE ARE NOT
UNREASONABLY IMPACTED IN THE
FUTURE AND TO ENSURE THAT VERY
SPECIES DO NOT EXTEND AND QUOTE
UNFORTUNATELY NOTHING HAPPENED
THE STATE DID NOT PREPARE FOR
TRIAL IN SINCE THEN AND INSTEAD
OF THE STATE'S RESPONSE SEEMS
TO BE THE SAME AS IT WAS A MOLE
IN THE LAST ROW. PROTECTION THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO LEAVE
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS TO
PROTECT SALMON AND OTHER
SPECIES AND SIMPLY PRAY FOR
RAIN. AND THAT IS NOT A PLAN.
THAT SAID THERE ARE SOME OF
PROGRESS YOU KNOW FOR INSTANCE
THAT YOU HEARD THE STATE WATER
BOARD DD ADOPT EMERGENCY.
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT. THE
HOME IN CHINOOK SALMON IN A
SCOTTISH AFTER REVERSING THE
PROTECTIONIST KAMIN AND KNOWING
YOUR PRE. BUT THESE MINIMUM
STREAM FLOW REGULATIONS WILL
DISAPPEAR WITH THE END OF THE
TRIAL THEY'RE NOT PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS. AND AT THE SAME TIME
MANY OF THE SO CALLED PRE
NINETEEN FOURTEEN WATER RIGHTS
HOLDERS FOLLOWING CLAIMS THAT
THE STATE WATER BOARD CAN'T
CURTAIL THEM. AND THAT THEY
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
EFFECTIVELY THE WATER STREAMS
TO PROPEL THEIR WATER RATES.
ALSO IN GOOD NEWS AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE DIRECTOR. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OUR COALITION OF
FISHING AND CONSERVATION GROUPS
ARE MOVING FORWARD IN
OVERTURNING THE DROP IN MY-
ADMINISTRATION'S BLATANTLY
UNLAWFUL BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS.
HOWEVER THE STATE INVESTOR
PROPOSED INTERIM OPERATIONS FOR
NEXT YEAR IS THAT WHILE THEY
ARE BETTER THAN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. FAILED TO PROTECT
SALMON AND OTHER ENDANGERED
SPECIES. CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SYSTEM IS IN DIRE NEED OF
REFORM IN INCLUDING OUR DEEPLY
INEQUITABLE WATERING SYSTEM.
STAYS PROMISED FAR MORE WATER
RATES N THE REGION AN AVERAGE
YEAR LET ALONE IN A DROUGHT
YEAR AND AT THE SAME TIME THE
STATE WATER BOARDS THAT FAIL TO
ESTABLISH INSTREAM FLOW
REQUIREMENTS TO PROTECT SALMON
IN OUR RIVERS. IN PERMITS. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN I RIGHT
AFTER RIGHT BEFORE I STARTED
ENERGY SEE THE STATE WATER
BOARD BEGAN THE REGULATORY
PROCEEDING TO UPDATE WATER
QUALITY AND MINIMUM FLOWS IN
THE BATTLE TO WATERSHED. AND
YET IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT
PROCEEDING IS STILL YEARS AWAY
FROM BEING CONCLUDED. WITHOUT
NEW OBJECTIVES FOR SACRAMENT
ORDER INFLOW DELTA OUTFLOW AND
IN DELTA FLOWS. SANDERS AND
HAVE NOT UPDATED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. AND WE
ARE PLEASED THAT ST RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED IT'S FINALLY GOING TO
START MOVING FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENT THE UPDATED INTEREST
INSTREAM FLOW REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE PALMER ST STANISLAUS RIVERS
THAT WERE ADOPTED BY THE
WATERBOARDING TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ENDING THREE YEARS OF
NEGOTIATIONS OVER. EIGHT POINT
FIVE BARTER AGREEMENTS THAT
WOULD HAVE FAILED TO PROTECT
SALMON AND THE SERVERS BUT THE
STATE CONTINUES TO DELAY THE
STATE WATER PORTS REGULATORY
PROCESS TO UPDATE THE REST OF
THE STANDARDS AND THE DATE OF
THE PLAN IN PURSUIT OF SO
CALLED VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
BASED ON MAGICAL THINKING ABOUT
WHAT SALMON NEED. AND WHAT THE
STATUS QUO'S DROP DIRE YOU
STILL HAVEN'T BAYERN MENTALLY
HARMFUL PROJECTS LIKE THE
PROPOSED SITES RESERVOIR IN THE
DELTA CONVEYANCE PROJECT THAT
WOULD MAKE CONDITIONS EVEN
WORSE FOR SALMON BY DIVERTING
EVER MORE WATER FROM OUR TAPS
IT ALL THIS IS. ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS HERE THANK YOU. AS YOU
GREATER OFTEN SAID FISH NEED
WATER. THOSE WHO BENEFIT FROM
THE STATUS QUO ARE INEVITABLE
WATER POLICY ACTIVELY TRY TO
MAKE WATER POLICY MORE
COMPLICATED THAN IT IS HIDING
BEHIND JARGON AND ACRONYMS TO
DISCOURAGE THE PUBLIC. AND
DECISION MAKERS FROM ASKING
TOUGH QUESTIONS. TOUGH
QUESTIONS WHY SOME COMMUNITIES
LAST YEAR WATER. OR EVEN ANY
WATER IN THEIR TAPS. WELL
STEWART RESNICK CONTROLS MORE
WATER THAN CITY INTERCITY
REALLY ISN'T IN A YEAR. TOUGH
QUESTIONS WHILE NEW ALMOND
ORCHARDS ARE BEING PLANTED IN
THE DROP WITHOUT ANY SURFACE
WATER SUPPLIES FOR THE TRAINING
OUR WATER. CALIFORNIA'S MORE
THAN TWO MILLION ACRES OF
IRRIGATED ALMONDS PISTACHIOS
AND WALNUTS. USE MORE WATER
THAN ALL THIRTY NINE MILLION
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA COMBINE.
TOUGH QUESTIONS LIKE WHETHER
STATE DOES NOT HAVE A REAL TIME
REPORTING OF WATER DIVERSIONS
RELYING ON PAPER SUBMISSIONS
THAT ARE SEVERAL YEARS OLD. I'M
THERE I'LL- SHE WAS RIGHT AS HE
WAS WITH SO MANY THINGS LIKE
ALL OF US AND WE NEED WATER NOT
MAGICAL THINKING. TO STAVE OFF
EXTINCTION RESTORE SALMON HELP
UNDERSTAND RUNS A PROTECT THE
TRIBES IN FISHING JOBS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT DEPEND ON
THEIR HEALTH. STATE WATER BOARD
NEEDS TO ESTABLISH LONG TERM
MINIMUM FLOWS AND OTHER
REGULATORY PROTECTIONS. ARE
REVERSION FISHERIES IN THE
BATTLE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST BY THE FACT
THAT CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANT
TO SEE IF THEIR WAY SO. HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER MR B.
G. MR MCMANUS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
YOU LOOK IN YOUR CRYSTAL BALL
AND THEN I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT- COMING OFF OF THESE
DRACONIAN INTEGRATED FEDERAL
WATER POLICIES. NUMBER ONE-
WHAT'S YOUR PREDICTION. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- IN TWO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YEAR- IN ESPECIALLY
FOR FISHERIES NUMBER ONE. IN
THE NUMBER TWO IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TWO THREE FOUR YEARS TO BE
ABLE TO TRANSITION INTO THESE
NEW FEDERAL WATER LOSS. IN THE
MEANTIME. VETR WATER RULES IN
THE MEANTIME I SEAMEN ARE GONNA-CONTINUE TO SUFFER. SO EVEN IN
THE INTERIM STEP IN EVEN IF WE
GOT RID OF THESE FOLLOWING THAT
WE- THAT WE GOT RID OF THESE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS. TO MR BG
ON THOSE TWO ITEMS YOUR
PREDICTION AND THEN TALK TO US
ABOUT THAT INTERIM PERIOD
BETWEEN. WHERE WE'RE AT NOW
STEPPING AWAY FROM THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS IN THE
WATER POLICY IN ADOPTING NEW
RULES- AND THEN MR MCMANUS.
THANK YOU IT'S A GREAT. AND ONE
OF US CAN ACT PREDICT WHAT THE
HYDRAULIC IS GOING TO BE LIKE
NEXT YEAR. IT DOES NOT LOOK
GOOD AND AS A DIRECTOR NOTED
AND AS I NOTED. WE HAVE A HUGE
DEFICIT IN TERMS OF RESERVOIR
STORAGE- BECAUSE WE TRAIN THE
RESERVOIRS TO MEET WATER
DELIVERIES THIS YEAR. AND IT
MEANS THAT IF NEXT YEAR IS DRY
AS PREDICTED. WE'RE LIKELY TO
SEE ANOTHER TERRIBLE YEAR
UNLESS WE CHANGE COURSE AND I
THINK WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
THAT- YOU KNOW. AS I MENTIONED
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE TALKING ABOUT
INTERIM PROTECTIONS IN OUR
FEDERAL COURT LITIGATION. WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THOSE
PROTECTIONS DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH-
AND THAT'S JUST FOR THIS NEXT
YEAR. YOU KNOW I THINK STEPPING
BACK YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT IS BEING INVOKED
HERE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
FAILED TO UPHOLD ITS LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS TO PROTECT SALMON
NOT JUST THE ENDANGERED RUNS
BUT FALL RUN CHINOOK SALMON AS
WELL. AND THOSE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS IN ESA PROTECTIONS
DON'T PROTECT THE BALL RUN GET
SOME INS INCIDENTAL ANCILLARY
BENEFITS FROM PROTECTING THE
ENDANGERED GROUNDS BUT NOTHING
THAT'S FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY ON
THAT AND THAT HAS TO CHANGE.
YOU KNOW THAT IS THE STATE
WATER BOARDS JOB THAT'S THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT FISHING
GAMES JOB TO SAY WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT ALL SALMON
RUNS NOT JUST THE ENDANGERED
RUNS AND I THINK YOU KNOW I AM
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IMPROVE PROTECTIONS AND
THEN IN THE NEAR FUTURE- THANKS
TO LITIGATION BY OUR COALITION
OF THE CFA ENERGY C. GOLDEN
STATE SALMON ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS- AS WELL AS THE
LITIGATION BY CITY CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE NEED TO REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS AND FRANKLY THE PURSUIT
OF ONTARIO AGREEMENTS HAS
REALLY DELAYED THE STATE
BOARD'S ADOPTION OF MEANINGFUL
PROTECTIONS THAT WILL LAST NOT
JUST DURING THE DROUGHT BUT TO
ENSURE WE HAVE ADEQUATE
PLEASANT TEMPERATURES IN ALL
YEARS BECAUSE AS A DIRECTOR
SAID WE CAN'T JUST PROTECT THEM
IN THE DROUGHTS AND LET THEM
SUFFER ANY OTHER YEAR SINCE WE
CAN'T LOSE THEM AND IT ROUTES
AND THEN PRETEND LIKE THE OTHER
YEARS YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE
THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH WBG
SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATURAL DEFENSE COUNSEL. MISTER
MCMANUS SUPPORTS OR SIR. THANKS
SO- THE DAMAGE HAPPENING NOW-
FALL RUN. TYPICALLY PEAK UNDER
SPOTTING IN MID OCTOBER AND THE
TEMPERATURES IN THE UPPER
SACRAMENTO BASIN RIGHT NOW OR
IN THE FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE
DEGREES THEY NEED SOMETHING
COLDER THAN FIFTY FIVE ANYTHING
NORTH OF FIFTY FIVE WE'RE
LOSING THOSE SAKE SO THE DAMAGE
IS OCCURRING RIGHT NOW AND WHAT
IT MEANS TO ME IS EVEN IF IT
RAINS CATS AND DOGS THROUGH THE
WINTER. THERE ARE GOING TO BE
THAT MANY JUVENILE SALMON
COMING DOWN THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER NEXT SPRING BECAUSE
YOU'RE SIMPLY NOT GOING TO
SURVIVE- OUT OF THE GRAVEL OUR
NUMBER ONE OR NUMBER TWO HAVING
SAID THAT YOU KNOW WE SAW-
SPRING ROAD RETURNED TO BUTTE
CREEK THIS YEAR IN REALLY GOOD
NUMBERS ACTUALLY- MOST OF THEM
DIED PRIOR TO BEING ABLE TO
SPOT BECAUSE OF HOT WATER.
HOWEVER SOME SURVIVED YEAH I
THINK IT WOULD BE WHO BOASTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD GET WITH
THE WATER RESOURCES BOARD AND
PREPARE FOR CURTAILMENTS. OF
DIVERSIONS ALONG BUTTE CREEK
FOR NEXT SPRING GET THE
SURVIVING JUVENILE SPRING RUN
SAFELY DOWN AND OUT OF BUTTE
CREEK AND DOWN THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER TO THE OCEAN SO THAT
pANOTHER POINT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO VISIT- DOUG MENTION THE
TEMPORARY URGENCY CHANGE
PETITIONS THESE ARE THE- THE
PETITIONS. BASICALLY THAT THE
WATER DIVERTERS TAKE TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD GET RUBBER
STAMPED WHETHER THEY NEED TO
VIOLATE- WATER RULES AS FAR AS
I CAN TELL THE WATER BOARD HAS
BEEN APPROVING THESE THINGS
WITH BASICALLY LITTLE OR NO
COST TO THE WATER CONTRACTORS.
WHAT WAS THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT EVERY TIME YOU WANT
TO GET A TCP APPROVED IT'S
GOING TO COST YOU SOMETHING IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT MIGHT GIVE
SOME PAUSE TO THE WATER
CONTRACTORS TO MAKE THEM THINK
THROUGH HOW OFTEN THEY WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE WELL AND ASKED
FOR A SPECIAL DISPENSATION.
FROM THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
VIOLATEWATER STANDARDS. ONE
FINAL POINT IS- IN THE
FISHERIES WE WILL BE LOOKING TO
THE HATCHERIES TO PROVIDE. A
BANDAID A BRIDGE TO KEEP. THE
ON THE RECREATIONAL FISHERIES
BOTH OF THE OCEAN AND INLAND- A
FLOAT OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS WILL BE LIVING ON
HATCHERY FISH IS WHAT IT BOILS
DOWN TO. SO I'LL STOP THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A GREAT
RESPECT MENACE I WANNA BE A GO
TO MR BATCHER MISTERBRAD
SHOT. AS PRESIDENT OF THE
FEDERATION. BUT THEN ALSO A
CRESCENT CITY RESIDENT. EVEN
MENTIONED- THE DAMS COMING
DOWN- ONLINE- THE CLAIM IF AND
HOW C. SHASTA IMPACTED. SALMON
ON THE KLAMATH ISSUES
DEVASTATING. LONG TERM. YOU
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS TEAM
WILL PROCESS IS GOING TO HELP
OBVIOUSLY THE ENTIRE WATERSHED
BUT THE SPECIES LONG TERM
SURVIVAL MR BRATCHER. YEAH THE
DAM REMOVAL PROJECT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AROUND AND YOU
KNOW I THINK HAS. BEEN VETTED
OUT THAT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
REMOVING THOSE STAGNANT POOLS
OF CONTAMINATED WATER AND- IN
OLD HOT WATER ABOVE- YOU KNOW
THE TOP END OF THIS RIVER
SYSTEM WILL. WILL ULTIMATELY
ALLOW THE RIVER TO BE COOLER
AND YOU KNOW THE DEEP POOLS
WHICH THESE FISH NEEDED. FOR
SAFE HARBOR FOR GOING OUT NOT
ONLY UP TO GO TO THEIR SPAWNING
GROUNDS BUT IT ALSO FOR COMING
DOWN AND- YOU KNOW MORE SO ON
THEIR OUT MIGRATION WHEN C.
FASTER THAN YOU KNOW THE RIVER
CONDITIONS WARMING NOT SEE
SHASTA BECOMES PREVALENT. DOWN
AND YOU KNOW REMOVING- YOU KNOW
THOSE DOWNS IN IN ALLOWING THAT
RIVER TO FLOW AGAIN YOU KNOW.
WHAT ULTIMATELY NO CLEAR OUT
THOSE. CALLS IN AND ALLOW THEM
TO HAVE SAFE PASSAGE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS GEORGE BRATCHER HE
IS PRESIDENT OF THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION BUT WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MISTER BRAD SHOT
MR OBG MR MCMANUS UP FOR THEIR
REPORT HERE TO THE JOINT
COMMITTEE AT THE FORTY EIGHTH
ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER FISHERIES
FORM THEIR FOCUS TODAY'S BEEN
DROUGHT CRISIS IN SALMON
FISHERIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GERMAN UP FOR YOUR WORK FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY IN FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY AS ALWAYS WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE. PLAYS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GONNA BE
MOVING FORWARD TO THE OUTLOOK
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO DUNGENESS CRAB
SEASON HE HEARD A PREVIEW BY
DIRECTOR BOTTOM HERE JUST A BIT
AGO THE HOPE WOULD BE TRYING TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE SEASON OPEN
BY THANKSGIVING BUT- BEING
CANDID RIGHT- IT'S LOOKING MORE
LIKE HITTING THAT. CHRISTMAS
NEW YEAR HOLIDAY SEASON AND
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR
THE LONG TERM WELL BEING OF
THE- THE FISHERY AND WE HAVE A
FULL REPORT HERE FOR YOU ON-
AND ALL STAR PANEL SWEEPING
ALTAR PANELS CAN PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE PROSPECTS OF HER
UPCOMING JUDGES CRAB SEASON AND
WE'RE GOING TO KICK OFF WITH IT
DR CARISSA ANDERSON SHE IS ONE
OF THE BEST- SHE'S ONE OF THE
BEST. WHEN IT COMES TO ALGAL
BLOOMS AND WE SEEN ALGAL BLOOMS
IN IMPACT THAT IT'S HAD ON THE
INDUSTRY SHE'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL OCEAN
OBSERVING SYSTEM SHE'S GOING TO
PRISON IN AN UPDATE ON THE
STATE OF THE SCIENCE FOR
PREDICTING HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS
IN SCALING THE PREDICTIONS TO
INFORM DECISION MAKING THE
MAKING AND- OUR DOCTOR.
ANDERSON IS ALSO GOING TO FOCUS
ON THIS YEAR. SHE BRINGING HER
CHRIS BALL WE ARE WE GONNA SEE-
ARE WE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
HIGH TEST BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
DEMOCRACY. THAT WE HAVE THE
QUESTIONS SHE HAS ALL THE
ANSWERS DOCTOR ANDERSON- WE
WELCOME YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK. THAT YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT INDIA WHERE IS
THAT CRYSTAL BALL IN THE
OFFICE. OKAY YEAH IT'S MY
CHILDREN'S ART BEHIND ME I
GUESS- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME YEARS AND REQUIRE- I
WILL BLAST THROUGH MY SLIDES
AND GONNA SHARE THEM BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME SO
WELL I WANTED TO MAKE JOKES
ABOUT. LAST TIME I SPOKE WITH
DURING THE BLOB AND I WAS A
BLOG BECAUSE IT IS PREGNANT AND
ALL THAT KIND OF THING I'M
GOING TO TRY. OKAY THE REAL
QUICK I WE IN THIS ONE CAN I
GET YOUR TIME YOU GOT TO TELL
US ABOUT- THE KIDS. YEAH
THEY'RE CUTE THIRD BOOK TWO
BOYS FIVE NINE. IF YOU ARE BUSY
I CANNOT IMAGINE I HAVE A SEVEN
MONTH OLD AND- CENTER WAY SO
HAS OLDER KIDS AND KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH. GET
THROUGH IT. OKAY SO THIS IS A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT I WILL WALK
THROUGH TODAY IN FIV MINUTES-
I'M GONNA PUT ON MY GLASSES I
CAN SEE IT BETTER BUT I'M GONNA
TRY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT ALL
THE WORK WE'RE DOING. WHAT DOES
THAT HERE NOW LOOK LIKE WHERE
WE HAD IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
AND ALSO GIVE YOU KIND OF MY
CRYSTAL BALL. ASSESSMENT SO.
ONE THING I JUST REMIND
EVERYBODY WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR YEARS ON IMPROVING LEAD
TIMES FOR HAVE. JUST THROUGH
PURE SAMPLING- YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE OF THE HAPMAP DATASET.
THE WEEKLY DATASET HAVE SPECIES
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW THE GAS THE
CONCENTRATION I REALIZE IS. DUE
TO LACK OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONES- FROM NOR CAL
YOU PRETTY MUCH JUST HAVE SANTA
CRUZ WHARF THAT REPORTS ON A
WEEKLY BASIS. AND BUT THESE
DATA ARE ALL AVAILABLE ON THE
SCHOOL'S WEBSITE ON. THIS
WEBSITE WE TRY TO GET OUT AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN WE HAVE A
LIST SERVE. AS WELL FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO BE ON A QUICKER
ALERT TIME FOR THIS. WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALL KINDS OF TAX AND
NOT JUST NOT YET NOT JUST TOO
MUCH TO ASK WE'RE TRYING TO
EXPAND THAT OUT. THAT IS
ONGOING AND NOT HAS ALSO FED
INTO THE C. HARM PREDICTIONS SO
THIS WAS THE MODEL THAT I
WORKED ON STARTING IN GRAD
SCHOOL. BUT WE DID WHAT'S
CALLED PASS. THROUGH THE VALLEY
OF DEATH INTO OPERATIONS OVER
THE LAST. MANY YEARS EVEN SINCE
I SPOKE TO YOU IS NOW AN
OPERATIONAL MODEL WITH NO CLOSE
WATCH SO IT GOES OUT THROUGH
THEIR CHANNELS ON A DAILY
BASIS- SINCE THANK YOUS WE WORK
IT UP PUT IT OUT. OUR PORTALS.
BUT IF AS A REMINDER THAT'S
GIVING YOU EIGHT NOW CAST AS
WELL AS A THREE DAY FORECAST.
PROBABILITY A SIGNATURE-
BALLOONS OF PARTICULAR NOTE
GOSSIPING OVER A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD JUST HIGH TRESTLE.
AND SO THEY'RE DOING A LOT OF
GOSSIPING OVER ANOTHER
THRESHOLD SO WE- SHOULD
PROBABLY DEFINE THE THRESHOLDS
BUT REGARDLESS WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING. IS ANIMATION OF WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE. I WHERE
YOU CAN SEE THAT NOW I WOULD
CALL YOU. THIS DEMONIC. NOT I
TEND TO. THE MOVE PART FOR
MYSELF BECAUSE I SEEN THAT HAS
THE BEST SKILL. THE BEST
ACCURACY OVER THE YEARS AS I
VALIDATE THIS AND SO- I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT THESE MODELS
HEAVILY RELY ON STUDENTS AND
HIS DATA LIKE RADAR. AND THOSE
ARE THE SAME DATA. TO GIVE YOU
THE SURFACE CURRENTS THAT YOU
MIGHT CONSULT YOUR OUT. ON ON
THE WATER BUT THEY ALSO GO INTO
ARTS YOU WANT SOME TRACTOR.
EARLIER ABOUT THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT HEAR THEY ALSO GO INTO WILL
STILL TRACK IT JUST WANT TO
POINT THAT OUT. TRADITIONAL
DATA. ON THE CELLULAR DNA
THERE'S A CRYSTAL BALL PARK-
AND THIS IS THE PART WHERE I
REALLY HOPE THE MODEL HAS ZERO
SKILL. BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
SHOWING THAT THE NORTH COAST
FROM ABOUT SEPTEMBER TO OCTOBER
WHEN I LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
CELLULAR. CASTED IT SHOWS. HOT
SPOT HOT SPOT HOT SPOT ONLY FOR
THE NORTH COAST MEANING KIND OF
MINUTES YOU KNOW COUNTY AND
WORKS ON- AND I. I HOPE THAT
THAT'S NOT TRUE AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT MEANS ABSOLUTELY
YES. BUT IT IS. NOT A GOOD
SIGN. GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THAT
THE DEMO GASES THAT IS ON THE
SURFACE WATERS DOES MAKE ITS
WAY INTO THE VENT THOSE. TRAPS.
IF IT'S THERE FOR A LONG. TIME
ON THIS IS IT LOOKS LIKE IF YOU
GO THERE. CLOSE WATCH. ON THEIR-
THAT. WHAT YOU SEE THIS IS THE
KEY. OF DEAL OUTPUT YOU WOULD
GET. ON WITH THE WARMER COLORS.
HIGHER RISKS. OKAY SO THE NEXT
THING WE'RE DOING- I'VE BEEN
PUTTING THIS OUT THROUGH SCREWS
FOR A LITTLE WHILE NOW I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
KNOWS ABOUT IT. YOU WANT TO GET
ON THE LIST SERVICES PRETTY
NICE THING IT'S NOT A FORWARD
LOOKING THING PRINCIPLES AND IT
GIVES YOU A RETROSPECTIVE. WHAT
DID THE C. HER MODEL SAY LAST
MONTH- WHAT DID. WHAT HAPPENED
REVEALS YOU'RE GETTING DATA.
EVERY MARINE MAMMAL STRANDING
CENTER. BUT IN TERMS OF
FISHERIES WE GET. AS MUCH DATA
AS WE CAN FROM C. PH AND WE HOT
MEXICAN. FISHERIES DATA. BUT IT
GIVES YOU A SENSE OF WHAT.
THEIR SAMPLING LOOKS LIKE AND
THE HOPE IS THAT WELL THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF. FISH SPECIES IN
HERE EXCEPT FOR THE BEAT WE
WILL INSTALL THE ADVISORIES FOR
THE STATE. WHAT IT DOES DO IS
HELP OU CALIBRATE WHAT THIS
MODEL LOOKS LIKE RELATIVES
ANYTHING YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THE SPATIAL- REGION YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN TIME SKILLS. AND
HELP YOU FIGURE OUT WHETHER
THIS MODEL IS. WORKING FOR YOU
OR NOT DOES IT REFLECT THE
REALITY THAT YOU SEE ON THE
GROUND OR DOES IT- SO THIS IS A
PRETTY COOL TOOL- WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TO. FULL
INSTRUMENTS FUNDED BY. SECTION
COUNCIL WE'RE GETTING THESE
ROBOTIC. MICROSCOPES COMMITTING
SUICIDE ABOUT. EVERY PEER IN
THE STATE INCLUDING TRINIDAD
HERE SOON- BUT A GUY HAS AN
INTAKE. AT THEIR MARINE LAB
THAT WILL BE USING. BUT THESE
TELL YOU IN REAL TIME EVERY
THIRTY MINUTES. USING MACHINE
LEARNING KIND OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION ALGORITHMS FOR THE
CLINTON. WHAT'S THERE NOT
TOXINS BUT IT TELLS YOU. WHAT
IS THERE EVERY THIRTY MINUTES
SO YOU KNOW IF SOMETHING IS
RAMPING UP OR RAMPING DOWN- AND
IT WILL BE CO LOCATED WITH ALL
KINDS OF OTHER SENSORS TO TELL
US WHETHER. OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
IS ALSO PLAYING A ROLE AND I'M-
THE INCREASE OR DECREASE OF
CERTAIN SPECIES. WE'RE HOPING
THIS IS GONNA BE REVOLUTIONARY
FOR THE MODELING THE MODELING
WE'RE PUSHING FORWARD IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS ONE IS
THE KIND OF MECHANISTIC FIRST
PRINCIPLES HOW WIDE IS DOING
OKAY AWESOME. PRODUCTION HAPPEN
WHAT TURNS IT ON. TRYING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN THROUGH MODELS
USING THREE DIMENSIONAL MODELS
BUT THEN ALSO SOMETHING THAT I
STARTED WORKING ON IN SANTA
CRUZ WE'RE NOW DOING THIS WITH
THE UCLA TEAM BUT TRYING TO
GET. THAT FIRST PRINCIPLE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW NUTRIENTS
OR STOMACH ACID PRODUCTION INTO
THESE MODELS. WE MORE REALISTIC
PREDICTIONS NOT OUT PRIME TIME
YET BUT WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
AND CLOSER. WE CAN ALSO THINK
AROUND WITH THE INTERACTIONS
WITH OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
HYPOXIA AND MODELS LIKE THIS
WHICH IS WHAT MAKES THIS KIND
OF MODEL PARTICULARLY COOL. SH
THE OTHER THING WE'RE DOING
THIS ACTUALLY WILL BE PROBABLY
THE COOLEST OF ALL OF THIS WHEN
IT COMES TO IMPROVING THE
MODELS WHICH IS. NOW THAT- A
GROUP HERE STRIPS. DISCOVER THE
GENETIC BASIS FOR DINNER GAS
PRODUCTION WE CAN TAKE A LOT
ALL OF OUR INSTRUMENTATION AND
GO OUT INTO THE FIELD AND
ACTUALLY LOOK. WHEN THIS NEW
TRAIN GOES UP DOES THAT GENE
TURN ON- AND THEN THAT WILL
GIVE US THE SKILL WE NEED
MOVING FORWARD WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THOSE MEASUREMENTS. AND
PARAMETRIZED MODELS BETTER THAN
WE CAN REALLY SAY ON THESE ARE
THE CONDITIONS THAT TURN THIS
ON IS THAT TELLS WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE ANIMALS. IT ALSO HAPPENS
TO CRAB NO AND THAT'S THE PART
WHERE I THINK THAT'S OUR
ACHILLES HEEL. WE HAVE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN TRYING TO
TACKLE THIS USING AGAIN MACHINE
LEARNING. AND THE APPROACH HERE
HAS BEEN REALLY PRACTICAL TAKE
THE C. HARM OUTPUT IT SAYS THIS.
IS THE RISK FOR DEMOCRATS IN
THE WATER. I THEN TAKE ALL OF
THE- WE HAVE FOR TOMORROW.
ROUTES AND ALL THESE OTHER.
SPECIES ON ROCK CLUB. STREET IS
YOUR CLAIMS YOU NAME IT. AND
TRY TO CONSTRAIN STATISTICALLY
HOW DO YOU GET FROM THOSE IN
WATER CONCENTRATIONS OR RISK
ASSESSMENTS. TO THE RISK FOR
THE ANIMALS- I KNEW THESE PLOTS
ARE TINY THEY'RE HARD TO READ
BUT ON THE RIGHT WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IS. IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE DO THAT AND WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE FOR DUNGENESS CRAB
ANOTHER SPECIES. THROUGH SPACE
AND TIME WE HAVEN'T PUBLISHED
THIS YET. IT'S NOT OPERATIONAL
MODEL YET. BUT IT LOOKS PRETTY
GOOD AND I THINK THIS IS THE
NEXT THING ON THE HORIZON FOR
US TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE-
HOW DO WE MOVE TOWARDS. WHAT WE
CARE ABOUT WHICH IS THE FISHERY
SPECIES. THIRTY SECONDS. I'M
PRETTY MUCH DONE I THINK SO I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT.
ALL OF THESE TOGETHER ARE IN
OUR TOOLBOX NONE OF NONE OF
THESE THINGS ALONE IS GOING TO
GIVE US THE ANSWERS THAT WE
NEED BUT I THINK. WE WANT TO
REALLY GOOD CRYSTAL BALL WE
HAVE TO TACKLE THIS. FROM ALL
DIFFERENT ANGLES SO THAT'S IT
AND THESE ARE ALL OUR FUNDING
SOURCES AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU HAVING HERE. STOP SHARING
MY SCREEN. THANK YOU SO YOU'RE
ALWAYS PLEASURE ARE GRATEFUL I
GOT TRAINS INSTEAD HANG IN WITH
US HERE AND TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE- BUT BEFORE WE GET
INTO QUESTIONS OF COMMENTS WE
WANNA HEAR FROM OUR OTHER
PANELISTS. OUR NEXT PANELIST IS
BEEN CLAD HE'S PRESIDENT. OF
THE CALIFORNIA COAST CRAB
ASSOCIATION WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
PARTNER. WITH MR PLATT ON SO
MANY ISSUES AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
HE IS WORKING THE ASSOCIATION
IS WORKING TO ASSIST THE COVER
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
IN. THE INDUSTRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO SEVERAL. READ ON
SEVERAL REGULATORY FRONTS THAT
WILL. HELP PROTECT. ENDANGERED
SPECIES SUCH AS TURTLES AND
WHALES- AND ENSURE THE LONG
TERM VIABILITY AND THE CRAB
FISHERY. THAT HE'S GOING TO BE
SPEAKING TO US ABOUT HIS
OUTLOOK FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DUNGENESS CRAB SEASON. MISTER
PRESIDENT WELCOME TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US. I GUESS SOME GOOD NEWS IT
IS LOOKING LIKE I'M GONNA KNOCK
ON WOOD MISTER PRESIDENT INDIA
YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG. HOPEFULLY SOME GOOD NEWS
ON PRICE- AND- BECAUSE WERE
DEPLETED IN STOCK- BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE WHALES- IN
THE BAY AREA AT CINEMA COUNTY
AREA. THAT'S DOING. A BIT OF A
DELAY BUT TO PLANT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE
AND I'M PRESENTING THESE
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE NINE
MEMBER BOARD OF. THE CALIFORNIA
COAST CRAB ASSOCIATION. AND OUR
MEMBERSHIP WHICH IS COMPRISED
SOLELY OF CRAPOUT OWNERS
CAPTAINS AND CRAP OURS FROM
ALGAL- TO CRESCENT CITY. WELL
COMMUNICATION SINCE THIS TIME
LAST YEAR BETWEEN GFW CENTER
REQUIREMENT CRAB FISHING STREE
HAS IMPROVED. THE TROUBLE
SHOOTING CONTINUES TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT MAJOR LOSSES OF
TIME AN AREA FROM THE NEW RAMP
REGULATIONS. SINCE THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AND CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY VERSUS
BONHAM THE ALL THE CRAB SEASON
HAS ALL BUT DISAPPEARED. AND
THE SPRING EARLY SUMMER SEASON
HAS CLOSE ON AVERAGE TWO TO
THREE MONTHS EARLY EARLIER THAN
TRADITIONAL. THE CRAB FISHING
INDUSTRY IS EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP. IN PART
DUE TO THESE CLOSURES. RAYMOND
DIED SEPT SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THREE YEARS AND THERE'S NOW A
SERIOUS SHORTAGE OF CREW
AVAILABLE TO WORK ON CRAB ****
OR FOR SHORE SIDE PROCESSING
AND DISTRIBUTION. COUPLED WITH
SEVERAL HISTORICALLY LOW
BINDING SEASONS HIGH FUEL
PRICES AND OTHER FACTORS
UNRELATED TO THE WALES IS TOUGH
TIMES FOR OUR FISHERY. MY
QUESTION TODAY IS HOW CAN CDFW
THE JOINT COMMITTEE OF THE
FISHING INDUSTRY ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES BEFORE MORE FAMILIES
LOSE BUSINESSES MANY WHICH HAVE
BUILD. I HAVE A FEW IDEAS. ONE
WITH A ROBUST AND GROWING
POPULATION WHALES FEEDING IN
MIGRATING UP FOR COACH IT IS
HARD TO SEE HOW THE RARE
INTERACTION WITH COMMERCIAL
DUNGENESS CRAB HERE WHICH
CONTINUE TO WARRANT THE MAJOR
CUTBACKS BY CDFW OF TIME AN
AREA IN THE FISHERY SHE DIDN'T
W. CLAIMS TO HAVE BUILT
FLEXIBILITY INTO THE RAFFLES IF
SO THEY SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PUT THE TIME IN THE
AREA BACK INTO THE FISHERY. ON
THE ONE HAND THE NATURAL MEAT
THE NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE HAS ALREADY GIVEN CDFW
PERMISSION TO RAISE THE LEVEL
HUMPBACK INTERACTIONS IN THE
VICTORY BASED ON A REVISED
POPULATION REPORT THAT PUTS THE
NUMBERS AROUND THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN IT WAS ESTIMATED
WHEN THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
WAS MADE BETWEEN G. D. AND C.
F. W. HIGHER TRADERS FOR
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS AND SOFTER
MORE TARGETED ACTIONS AND
STATEWIDE CLOSURES ARE NOT ONLY
ALLOWED IN RAP. WHICH SHOULD BE
USED IF SHE EVER TRULY WANTS TO
HELP MAINTAIN A BIBLE CRAB
FISHING INDUSTRY PRESSURES CAN
BE TARGETED AND ONLY THE
FISHING ZONES WERE ELEVATED
RISK HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AND
COULD BE A DEATH RESTRICTION
INSTEAD OF A CLOSURE. OR SIMPLE
FLEET ADVISORY. TRIPLE C. A. IS
ALL WORKING ON AN ALL. DO YOUR
TEST PURPOSE FOR LAW LINING.
WHICH COULD WERE VERTICAL LINES
AND LOT OF FISH AT TIMES OF
YEAR AND SO ON. YES WHERE WHERE
ELSE MAY NOT WORK WHERE WHALES
MAY BE PRESENT. ANOTHER WAY TO
GET THAT WE CAN HELP KEEP THE
FISHERY OPEN IS BY FINDING
FUNDING AND STAFF TO HELP
CONTINUE AND EXPAND TRIPLE C.
H. BASSIL BASED SERVICE. THE
PILOT PROJECTS CONDUCTED IN THE
NORTH AND SOUTH FISHING ZONES
LAST SEASON. THROUGH OUR OWN
VESSELS CAN PROVIDE TIMELY
REPORTS ON WELL DISTRIBUTION
WHEN CDFW CANNOT GET PLANES IN
THE AIR. WE REQUEST THE JOINT
COMMITTEE HELP SECURE FUNDING
FOR AN ONGOING SURVEY PROJECT.
THREE CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL
CRAB FISHERY SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO BE CHARGED UNFAIRLY
FOR EVERY CONFIRMED
ENTANGLEMENT WITH AN
UNIDENTIFIABLE YOUR CHILD.
WHILE NEWLY MANDATED BY THE
MARKETS FOR THE FIX YOUR
pDIRECTION SIMPLE LINE MARKING
FOR FISHERY WOULD B THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND PRACTICAL WAY
PRACTICAL WAY TO IDENTIFY GEAR.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE SHOULD ASK
YES W. AND THE DEJECTED
PRIORITIZED MANDATED LIVE
MARCHING. THE TROUBLE SHE WAS
GLAD TO SEE THAT BOTH THE
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
SECTORS OF OUR FISHERY STEPPED
UP LAST SPRING DO YOU FEED
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR WHICH
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED USE OF POP
UP ROPELESS GEAR. THE CRAB
FISHERIES UNIFORMED POSES
DANGER IS RIDICULOUSLY
EXPENSIVE AND IMPRACTICAL YOUR
PROTOTYPE IF EVER IMPLEMENTED
IN THE FISHERY IT WOULD CREATE
FAR WORSE IN TANGO ARREST
YOU'RE OPERATING. LOSS MUCH
HIGHER THAN. GEAR RESULTING IN
SERIOUS OCEAN POLLUTION THAT IS
SUBMERGED FAR WEST COAST YOU'RE-IN OUR PRISTINE NEAR SHORE
ECOSYSTEMS. THE TROUBLE SHE HAS
SENT A LETTER TO CDFW
REQUESTING REQUEST YOU'RE NOT
BE INCLUDED IN THE DRAFT
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT
APPLICATION TO NETWORKS WHICH
WILL BE RELEASED THIS MONTH. WE
ALSO REQUEST THE JOINT
COMMITTEE HEALTH PRACTITIONERS
TREE OPPOSE ANY FUTURE ATTEMPTS
TO PASS A ROBUST MANDATE AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. IT IS CLEAR
TO US AND. SHOULD BE BY OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS. A ROBUST
MANDATE ROOM OUR SAFE INSISTING
FISH WHILE. ENTANGLEMENT REX TO
MARINE MAMMALS. SPEAKING OF
PRISTINE COASTAL WATERS THE
WIND ENERGY PRODUCTS BEING
AGGRESSIVELY PROMOTED BY THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU CAN MORE BAY COULD
INTRODUCE SERIOUS DANGER TO
BOTH FEEDING AND MIGRATING
WHALES AND FOR THE FISHING
FLEET WE REQUEST THE STATE
CONDUCT DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF
THE POTENTIAL THREAT TO MARINE
LIFE. DIMENSIONAL SAFETY AND
ALSO ASSESS THE LIKELY ECONOMIC
IMPACTS TO THE EFFECTIVE
FISHERIES AND COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. THE CCC A WILL
CONTINUE TO REMIND THE STATE
THAT WILL DIGENIS CROWDS ARE
MOST WIDELY SHARED AN
ECONOMICALLY IMPORTANT VICTORY
IT IS IN A SERIOUS JEOPARDY
NOW. WE MUST FIND WAYS TO
RETURN SIGNIFICANT TIME AREA TO
OUR SEASONS IF WE ARE TO
SURVIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A PIPE BREAK GRATEFUL A
PRESENT IN THE CALIFORNIA COAST
CAMPUS INITIATION SUPPLY IT'S
GOING TO HANG OUT WITH US TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE TODAY. THAT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
MIKE CONROY MICRON RAISED THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF THE
PACIFIC COAST- FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION VERY
EASY FOR ME TO SAY MR CONROY.
UNFORTUNATELY MR CONROY IS ALSO
A DODGERS FAN BUT WE'LL FORGIVE
HIM FOR THAT- IN HE'S CAN
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW. OF THE
ASSOCIATION'S PERSPECTIVE ON
CONCERNS FOR THE CRAB FLEET. AS
WELL AS WITH RIGHT WHALE
ENTANGLEMENTS. MR CONVERT WE
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YET YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
ON THE THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
THANKS ISN'T SURE YOU CAN HEAR
ME YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD AND
CLEAR SIR. FIVE PERFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
THE NON BEING A DODGER FAN. YOU
SAVE ME THE TROUBLE OF BRINGING
IT UP. AGAIN GOOD TIMES. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERMAN WIRE FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKE CONROY THEN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION FOR SOME BUSINESSES.
CREATIONS I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHING GEAR WORKING GROUP. AT
THE OUTSET I WANT TO THANK YOU
CENTER REQUIRED FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP YES THE EIGHTY
SIGNED INTO LAW MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS WILL DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE STATE'S COMMERCIAL.
DUNGENESS CRAB HARVESTERS AND
PROCESSORS THAT DURING YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH DIRECTOR
BOTTOM YOU MENTIONED PRICE I
CAN REPORT THAT THE DYNAMICS OF
THE FISHERY IN THE MARKET FOR
THE FISHERY THIS YEAR ARE
VASTLY DIFFERENT. THAN THE
FLEET IS EXPECTING A MUCH
HIGHER PRICE FOR THE HOLIDAY
MARKET SHOULD THE FLEET BE
ALLOWED TO UNTIE. AS YOU KNOW
MISTER CHAIR THE WORKING GROUP
WAS ESTABLISHED IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IT DOESN'T
ADVISORY BODY TO THE CDFW.
ALONG WITH OTHER STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO ADDRESS THE
RISK OF ACTIONABLE SPEECH IN
ACTUAL SPECIES ENTANGLEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHING YEAR. ACTUAL SPECIES
BEING DEFINED AS HUMPBACK AND
BLUE WHALES AND OTHER BACKS YOU
TROUBLES. I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T OFFER CALLED MR
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF THEIR
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE COMMERCIAL
FISHING INDUSTRY. THE
REGULATIONS IMPLEMENTING THE
RISK ASSESSMENT MITIGATION
PROGRAM HAVE CAUSED GREAT
CONFUSION AMONGST INDUSTRY IN
THE DFW HAS MADE THEMSELVES
AVAILABLE. TO EXPLAIN BOTH THE
REGULATIONS AND THE NUANCES OF
RAM TO INDUSTRY I SPECIFICALLY
WANT TO CALL OUT DIRECT BONHAM
CRAIG SHUMAN SAKE MASTER. RYAN
BARKLEY. JOINT AGREEABLE
CHRISTIE YOU HOUSE AND OTHERS
FOR THEIR TIME AND PATIENCE. I
ALSO WANT TO APPLAUD THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE FISHERY FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THE PROCESS
AND UTILIZING BEST PRACTICES.
WHICH IS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT
THAT ONLY ONE HUMPBACK WHALES
CONFIRMED TO HAVE BEEN
ENTANGLED IN CALIFORNIA
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS CRAB GEAR.
IN EACH OF THE LAST TWO YEARS
IN EACH OF THOSE RELEASED
SUCCESSFULLY. I WILL REMIND YOU
THAT ONLY FIVE YEARS AGO THAT
NUMBER WAS REPORTED AS TWENTY
TWO. I WOULD ASK THE
LEGISLATURE ACKNOWLEDGE
SUCCESSES OF THE FISHERY
PARTICIPANTS. IN REDUCING SUCH
INTERACTIONS. IS B. O. DISPUTE
THAT IT. KEY DRIVER OF THE
STATE'S CHIEF ECONOMY. THE
COMMERCIAL BIG CRAB FISHERY
WILL FOREVER BE CHANGED. AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM MR PLATT
THERE'S SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF THIS FISHERY AND
TURN THE FISHING COMMUNITIES
DEPENDED UPON DUNGEON THIS
CRAP. MY TIME ON THE WORKING
GROUP HAS BEEN RELATIVELY SHORT
I BEGAN PARTICIPATING AT THE
TAIL END OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
SEASON. HOWEVER DURING THAT
TIME IT IS CLEAR THAT FURTHER
REFINEMENT OF THE RAMP AND ITS-
PROCESSES ARE NECESSARY.
PERSONALLY I QUESTION WHETHER
THE CURRENT PROCESS JUST
TRAINABLE. BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
UTILITY OF THE WORKING GROUP AS
IS EVIDENCED BY THE NUMBER OF
VACANCIES. AND CONFIDENCE IN
THE PROGRAM UNDER UTILIZATION
OF TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX IS A
COMMON COMPLAINT. I AM
ENCOURAGED THAT RAMP TO POINT
OUT WILL BE A REALITY MY HOPE
IS THAT COMES TO FRUITION
SOONER THAN LATER. CFA REMAINS
COMMITTED TO PARTICIPATING IN
AN EFFORT TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL OF THE
STATE'S CRAP OUR RESEARCHERS. I
WANT TO REITERATE THE QUEST
THAT YOU ARE REQUESTED YOU
HEARD FROM BEN REGARDING
SECURING FUNDING FOR VESSEL
BASED SERVICE. WHICH PROVIDED
USEFUL DATA MARINE
CONCENTRATIONS LAST YEAR. THOSE
SURVEYS PERFORMED BY
PARTICIPANTS IN THE TROUT
FISHERY AUGMENTED APARTMENTS
AVAILABLE DATA SOURCES AND WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING
NUMBERS IMPLICATIONS OF ACTUAL
C. SPECIES TO HELP INFORM RAMP
AND THE WORKING GROUP'S
DELIBERATIONS. INFORM MAKING
PROCESSES REQUIRED CORRECT AND
COMPLETE DATA. AND ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO SUPPORT DATA
COLLECTION EFFORTS SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED. I DO WANT TO SPEND
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT SORT BOXES AND TABLES. IF
YOU'VE EVER WATCHED DEADLIEST
CATCH YOU'LL SEE THE CREW
MEMBERS DON'T CONTENTS OF A
CRAB POT ONTO A TABLE REALLY
THEN PICK OUT CROWDS WHICH ARE
ILLEGAL TO POSSESS FEMALES ARE
UNDERSIZED CRABS AND RETURN
THEM TO THE WATER. MOST OF ON
OFF CALIFORNIA TRAVELERS
UTILIZE A SWORD BOX FOR THE
SAME PURPOSE FISHING GAME CODE
SECTION EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. READS
IN PART EXCEPT AS OTHERWISE
PROVIDED NO DUNGENESS CRAB LESS
THAN SIX AND A QUARTER INCHES
IN LENGTH AND NO FEMALE
DUNGENESS CRAB MAY BE TAKEN OR
POSSESSED. UNDER THE LETTER OF
THE LAW THE CRAPPER COULD BE
CITED FOR MERELY HAVING AN
UNDERSIZED FOR FEMALE CRASHING
HIS ARE TRAPPED INTO BEING
FOUND SUCH CRAP. IN HIS OR HER
SOARING BOX. BEEN INFORMED A
LONG FORCE ACTION IN WHICH A
TRAVERSE IS BEING CHARGED WITH
VIOLATING THAT CODE SECTION
BECAUSE UNDERSIZED CRABS WERE
ON THE SHORT BOX. THIS IS
CAUSING CONCERN IN THE INDUSTRY
GIVEN THE WIDESPREAD USE OF
SORT BOXES IN THE FISHERY. I
WOULD ABSOLUTELY JUST LET YOUR
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
INDUSTRY TO DEVELOP APPROPRIATE
LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
CERTAINTY TO HARVESTERS THAT
UTILIZING SHORT SORT BOXES HI
HE TEMPORARILY PROCESSING
OTHERWISE ILLEGAL TRAPS. WILL
NOT LEAD TO ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. MR PLUS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED THE CONCERNS
SURROUNDING THE TREATMENT OF IN
CHAINS I DON'T FIND YOUR TYPES.
HAS BEEN NOTED ONE POSSIBLE WAY
TO REDUCE COSTS IS SUCH
ATTAINMENTS. WOULD BE TO
DEVELOP TOOLS THAT ALLOW FOR
EASIER IDENTIFICATION OF WHICH
FISHERY. AND ENTANGLEMENT
SHOULD BE ATTRIBUTED TO. WHY
PROBLEM IS THAT NTANGLEMENTS
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE BLUES WHICH
CAN BE USEFUL IN IDENTIFYING
THE CULPRIT. OTHER STATES ARE
CONSIDERING LINE MARKING AND
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE USEFUL IN CALIFORNIA.
THIRTY OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD
REQUIRE ME TO PARTICIPANTS IN
THE OTHER STATES TRAP FISHERIES
BUT IT MAY BE TIME TO START
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANKS. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S MY CON
RIGHT BERRY GRATEFUL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION MIKE'S GONNA BE
HANGING WITH US AS WELL WE'RE
GONNA BE OPENING T UP. FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND JUST A
BIT BEFORE WE DO WE'RE GONNA
INVITE. JANE HUMBERSTONE WITH
IT SHE'S THE FISHERIES PROJECT
DIRECTOR WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. MYTH NUMBER SEWN
SHE'S GONNA OUTLINED HOW THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY'S PARTNERED
WITH FISHERMEN AND MANAGERS TO.
DEVELOP INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
REDUCE INTEGUMENT WRIST THE
WHALES WE JUST HEARD THERE'S
BEEN A MASSIVE REDUCTION- IN
REGARDS TO A FEW TO SEVERAL
DOZEN A YEAR. TO ONE LAST YEAR-
IN ITS B. IS BECAUSE OF THE
LEADERSHIP. OF THE FLEET IT'S
BECAUSE THE LEADERSHIP. OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SO MANY
INVOLVED- THAT WE'RE HERE
TODAY. BUT SHE'S GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT SHE'S BEEN
FOCUSING ON HOW TO BE A
REDUCED. ENTANGLEMENT RISKS
INCLUDING THE WORKING GROUP
RISK ASSESSMENT AND MITIGATION
PROGRAM. AND OF COURSE THE
INDUSTRY LED PRESEASON SURVEY
WHICH WILL GET INTO MORE JUST A
BIT. TERMS DON'T WELCOME THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US AT
THE FORTIETH ANNUAL SEE GREATER
FISHERIES FORM THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I REQUIRE THEY
COMMITTEE MANNERS THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S PANEL- AS YOU NOTED THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WORKS WITH.
GERMAN RESEARCHERS OF MYSTERY
MANAGERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE WORLD TO INCREASE
THE RESILIENCE OF OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS AND COASTAL
ECONOMIES TO SUSTAINABLE
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT. AND TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS IN A
CHANGING CLIMATE. MEASURES NEED
TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS
FASTER MORE EFFECTIVELY. IN
RECENT YEARS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHERY HAS EXPERIENCED VERY
SERIOUS ECOLOGICAL ECONOMIC
IMPACTS FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
RELATED ENVIRONMENTAL
DESTRUCTION. THIS INCLUDES A
SUDDEN INCREASE IN WAYLAND
SENTIMENTS. AND THESE
CHALLENGES OF THIS FISHERY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS SIMPLY INCREASES
CLIMATE READINESS ADAPTIVE DATA
DRIVEN MANAGEMENT. AND SINCE
HE'S BEEN WORKING AS PART OF
THE DUNGEON IS STRUCK THIS YEAR
WORKING GROUPS ON A RANGE OF
APPROACHES TO REDUCING CANNOT
REST WHILE SUPPORTING A
THRIVING FISHERY. AND MANY OF
THESE ARE NON REGULATIONS
INCLUDING IMPROVED GEAR MARKING
TO FIGURATION OFFICIAL AND LET
US RECOVERY PROGRAM IN A FIRST
OF ITS KIND RISK ASSESSMENT AND
MITIGATION PROGRAM. THAT SEEKS
TO PROACTIVELY RESPOND TO AN
EMAIL ADDRESS. AND IT'S REALLY
THANKS TO THE DEDICATION OF THE
STANDARD IS PROBABLY AND THE
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT FROM THE
OPC. LEGISLATURE AND CDFW. AND
WE ARE HERE DEVELOPING
MANAGEMENT MEASURES AND WE'RE
SEEING THAT THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING TO BETTER OUTCOMES
FOR MALES AS YOU SAID SENATE
REQUIRE WELL INSTRUMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS
CRAB HERE IN RECENT YEARS HAVE.
ON IT AND- SOME OF THE STATE
PURSUES AN INCIDENTAL TAKE
PERMIT. ONGOING EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE MEASURES WILL BE
CRITICAL. HOWEVER AS YOU'VE
ALSO HEARD MANY OF THESE
MEASURES ARE TYING DATA AND
RESOURCE INTENSIVE ESPECIALLY
THE ROUTE WHICH REQUIRES
FREQUENT COMPREHENSIVE DATA ON
RAIL SEA TURTLE AND FISHING
ACTIVITY ACROSS THE GROUND. I
WENT TO A DIFFERENT AREAS
MISSING OR INCOMPLETE COVERAGE
IT FORCES DECISIONS THAT MAY BE
OVERLY RESCUE NO RAILS ARE
UNNECESSARILY CONSTRAINED
OPPORTUNITY. AND THESE DATA
GAPS MAKE IT HARDER FOR US TO
LEARN FROM THE PAST AND IMPROVE
DECISION MAKING IN THE FUTURE.
FINALLY UNCERTAINTY AND RISK
ASSESSMENT AND DECISION MAKING
TIME LINES THANK THE
CHALLENGING TO COLLECT
CONSISTENT DATA AND CHALLENGING
FOR FISHING INDUSTRY BUSINESSES
TO PLAN. SO IN SHORT WE SEE
THAT DATA IS THE ENGINE OF THIS
AMBITIOUS ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AND WE NEED TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS NECESSARY FOR THIS
ENGINE TO RUN EFFICIENTLY AND
RELIABLY AS A CORNERSTONE OF
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION PLAN.
SO I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT YOUR
PRIORITIES TODAY TO GET US
THERE. ONE IS THAT WE NEED TO
LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY FOR BETTER
FASTER DATA ON FISHING EFFORT.
CDFW IS COMMITTED TO FLEET WIDE
MONITORING YEAH. TO HELP KEEP
OUT ON THE WATER IN THE
PRESENCE OF WALES WITH
MANAGEMENT TOOLS SUCH AS STOCKS
RESTRICTIONS WHICH MIKE AND I
HAVE SPOKEN TO. HOWEVER FOR EM
DIFFICULT SCHOOLS THE PROGRAM
MUST BE DESIGNED TO DELIVER THE
RIGHT INFORMATION AT THE RIGHT
TIME WHILE ALSO BEING COST
EFFECTIVE. TMC IS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE DEVELOPING AND AMP
PROGRAMMING THE WEST COAST
GOUNDFISH FISHERY ANDWE'VE
LEARNED THAT GETTING IT RIGHT
WILL REQUIRE A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS. THAT MUST BEGIN WITH
CLEARLY DEFINED MANAGEMENT
OBJECTIVES INCLUDE FISHERMEN
AND THE TESTING EMBEDDING OF
TOOLS AND DELIVER RELIABLE DATA
MANAGERS. SECOND ASSISTANT
SPOKEN TO WE NEED TO LEVERAGE
PARTNERSHIPS TO FILL CRITICAL
DATA GAPS ON THE LOCATION OF
WHALES AND ENABLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER MANNER. WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THE PILOT THAT WE
PARTNERED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COAST PROPOSITION ON LAST YEAR
TO DESIGN IT I LIVE IN INDUSTRY
WIDE SURVEY. THE PILOT WAS
REALLY SUCCESSFUL WE- WE IN
FACT THE SERVINGS ON ONE LED TO
THE FIRST EVER USE OF ADULTS
RESTRICTION UNDER THE RAMP BY
FILLING A KEY DATA GAP. AND WE
SEE THAT THIS MODEL CAN
UNIQUELY COMPLEMENT OTHER DATA
SOURCES INCLUDING EMERGING
SPECIES DISTRIBUTION MODELS THE
PHONE BILL GRAHAM MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS WHILE ALSO
INCREASING INDUSTRY CONFIDENCE
AND ENGAGEMENT. HOWEVER
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT AND EXPAND THIS
TRIAL AS PART OF A BROADER
MONITORING STRATEGY. SO WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING REQUEST FOR
THESE INDUSTRY SURVEYS INCLUDED
IN THE DUNGENESS CRAB TASK
FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS LAST WEEK.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL
TO THE ONGOING PROTECTION OF
WHALES AND LONG TERM HEALTH OF
THE DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERY IN
THE MANY COMMUNITIES THAT%
DEPEND ON IT. THE CLIMATE
IMPACTS THOSE AN URGENT THREAT
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
FISHERIES. SO WE MUST ALSO BE
VIEWING THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
AND AN URGENT ONE TO OUTLINE A
HOLISTIC TRANSFORMATION OF ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S DISTRICT DATA
COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS. SO WHILE THERE MAY BE
DIFFERENCES IN THE CHALLENGES
EACH FISHERY FACES CLIMATE
READY FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
CALLS FOR SOME BROADLY APPLIED
BOOKING GRADIENTS. BY CLEARLY
DEFINED DATA NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES LEVERAGING
TECHNOLOGY LIKE DIGITAL
RECORDING TOOLS AND EXPANDED
USE OF PARTNERSHIPS TO FILL
DATA GAPS. AND JUST LIKE THE
CRITICAL ROLE THIS COMMITTEE'S
LEADERSHIP AND VISION HAS
PLAYED IN ADVANCING SOLUTIONS
THE WELL TAKE A ISSUE.
TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA'S DATA
SYSTEMS. REQUIRE COMMITTED
LEADERSHIP AMBITION. SOMETHING
CLOSE WE APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
DEDICATION OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED COLLABORATION. WITH
CDFW THE OPC FISHERMEN
SCIENTISTS AND NGOS. AS WE
CONTINUE TO PURSUE DATA DRIVEN
MANAGEMENT TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
MARINE LIFE AND FISHERIES.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THIS SUMMER SOME SUMMERS ON IS
THE FISHERIES PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS. IN THE TICKET RIGHT
INTO IT HERE WE TALKED ABOUT.
THIS PILOT REGARDS THIS SURVEY
THAT REALLY GIVES ON THE GROUND
OR ON THE OCEAN ICE- ON WHERE
THE WHALES ARE AT AND WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE DIRECTOR EARLIER
TODAY EVEN THOUGH THE STATE.
HAS PURCHASED AN ADDITIONAL
AIRCRAFT TO BE ABLE TO DO-
AERIAL SURVEYS OF WALES- OIL
SPILLS YOU NAME IT- WE'RE GONNA
NEED EYES AND EARS OUT ON THE
OCEAN AND THAT'S WHAT- MR PLATT
IN DECEMBER SOME IS BEEN
WORKING ON- SO LET'S. GET INTO
THAT A LITTLE BIT I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A RECOMMENDATION COMING
FROM THE WORKING GROUP. BUT
MISS HAMMER STONE IN ALL GO TO
MR PLAN TO TALK ABOUT THIS AS
WELL. I BELIEVE WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE WORKING GROUP ON THE
BUDGET NUMBERS AND WHAT THAT
REQUEST WILL BE- AND I THINK
WAITING FOR AN OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO. EXPLORE AS
WELL I MISS. SOME OF YOUR CAKE
IS OFTEN WILL GO TO MISTER
PLAQUE. HAPPY YOU KNOW WHEN I
DO BELIEVE I'M SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
TO GO SOME NOT. THAT I'M
CORRESPOND TO THE COST AND FOR
THE PLANNING OF A VESSELS ON
THE WATER. I'M IN SO I THINK WE
CAN PROVIDE AND DOESN'T FOLLOW
UP INCLUDING WITH AND TO DO
THAT AND THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
RESOURCES THAT GOES INTO THE
PILOT. ON TO THE PROGRAM. AND
THE TOTAL COST OF THAT WILL
DEPEND ON HOW MANY SURVEYS WERE
DOING- PER YEAR BUT WE'VE GOT
SOME ESTIMATES OF. OF WHAT A
GOOD. SECOND YEAR PILOT WOULD
LOOK LIKE- IN ADDITION I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT ALL
THE OTHER IN KIND SERVICES AND
THAT. YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL BEEN
KIND OF STRUGGLING TOGETHER IN
PROVIDING INCLINE- BUT IN THE
LONG TERM WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS- YOU KNOW STILL
COORDINATION SERVICE SAYS- THEY
CAN BE AVAILABLE AND THE LONG
TERM. AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH CDFW TO THAT TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW. IF THEY HAVE
INCREASED STAFF CAPACITY- TO
SEE WHAT ROLES WE CAN WORK OUT
IN TERMS OF THE DATA CENTER
SYSTEM MANAGEMENT SO. THERE'S A
FEW THINGS TO KEEP IN MIND ONE
IS KIND OF. MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING FAIR
COMPENSATION TO THE FISHERMEN
WHO ARE- YOU KNOW SPENDING TIME
AND GAS MONEY OUT THERE ON THE
WATER- BUT THERE'S OTHER ROLES
ON ALL THE COORDINATION THAT IT
TAKES TO ENGAGE OUR SCIENTIFIC
ADVISORS. FOLKS OUT ON THE
WATER ON THE SAME DAY. WHEN WE
HAVE THE RIGHT WINDOWS AND THEN
TAKE ALL THE DATA THAT'S COMING
IN AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ABLE
TO BE USED. TURN AROUND QUICKLY
AND HOUSTON RAMP DECISION
MAKING. THANK. YOU SO MUCH I
MISS A PACK COMMENTS ON THIS.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW. THANKS FOR I
DON'T HAVE A WHOLE. TO SAY. JAN
IS REALLY COVERED A LOT OF IT-
I HEARD HERSELF IN JOHN
GONZALES WHOSE ARE- PROCESSOR
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE BOARD OF
THE TRIPLE CA REALLY DID A
FANTASTIC JOB WITH THEM THE
PILOT PROGRAM AND- THEN THE
FISHERMEN THAT. ARE
VOLUNTEERING TO. TO DO THIS-
YOU KNOW ARE ARE ARE REALLY
DOING IT BECAUSE- THEY'RE
TRYING TO HELP C. F. W. AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE FILL IN THE DATA
GAPS DOWN. AND PROVIDE AS MUCH
REAL TIME DATA AS POSSIBLE- SO
THAT THEY MAY BE ABLE TO USE
SOFTER MANAGEMENT. TOOLS LIKE
CHEF RESTRICTIONS IN THE SPRING
INSTEAD OF CLOSING THE WHOLE.
STATE OR THE WHOLE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE SO-
WE ARE MOTIVATED- PRIMARILY BY
TRYING TO EXPAND OUR SEASONS
BUT WE ARE ALSO. MOTIVATED BY
HAVING THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE AND WE WERE WILLING TO-
YOU KNOW EVER WE WERE WILLING
TO LIVE OR DIE BY THE SWORD AND
THAT SORT IS. THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE SO- IF WE CAN
DO YOU KNOW IF WE CAN PROVIDE
THE DATA THAT HELPS KEEP THE
SEASON OPEN A LITTLE LONGER
EVERY SEASON. OR HELPS
CONVINCE- THE STATE THAT IT'S
SAFE TO FINISH INSIDE A CERTAIN
DEPTH. RESTRICTION AT CERTAIN
TIME OF YEAR AND CERTAIN
FISHING ZONES AND THEN WE'RE
OFF FOR- THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
REALLY STEPPED UP IN JUNE IN
PARTICULAR HELPING PROVIDE.
TEMPORARY FUNDING FOR OUR PILOT
PROJECTS THE GUYS DON'T.
REQUIRE A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY TO
GO OUT THERE YOU KNOW SOME OF
SOME OF THEM ACTUALLY TOOK THE
MONEY THEY WERE. GIVEN FURTHER
EXPENSES IN JUST STARTING YOU
KNOW BACK TO THE SITUATION SO
WE CAN LOG YOU GET STATE FIVE
THIRTY FOUR- SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR AN INFLATED BUDGET
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE. THE
LEGISLATURE AND- CDFW COMMIT TO
THE PROGRAM COMMITTEE. STAFF
YEAH. IT STILL SOURCES OF
FUNDING. AND LET IN LAST YEAR
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH.
ARE A I- AND X. ALL THE
POSSIBILITIES UNDER THE RAMP
WALK THAT FLEXIBILITY ALLOWS-
SO WE'RE ALL FOR IT AND I'D
LIKE EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT MIKE
HAS BEEN. VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS IDEA FROM THE FIRST TIME I
BROUGHT IT UP IN A PRIVATE
MEETING. I HAD ALSO I WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT- IT KNOWLEDGE.
THAT THE SENATOR HAS REALLY
HELPED THE FISHING INDUSTRY
LATELY AND HELPING TO- APPLY
PRESSURE ON CDFW TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
UNIDENTIFIABLE CURE. TYPE ISSUE
AND THAT IT'S- A FAIRLY SIMPLE
PROBLEM THAT CAN BE SOLVED ON.
THE STREET SHOULD NOT BE
CHARGED UNFAIRLY FORTY SEVEN
AND IDENTIFY YOUR- INTERACTIONS
SO- WE REALLY HAVE HAD BETTER.
COMMUNICATION WITH THE STATE
AGAIN WITH- STOMP THE
FISHERIES- COMMITTEE AND IN
PARTICULAR. A SENATOR MCGUIRE
AND THINGS ARE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO I WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT PUBLICLY MIKE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS FIVE LOVE WORKING WITH
YOU- IN VERY GREAT WOULD BE TO
WORK WITH YOUR MEMBERS AS WELL.
IN A IN THE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT I KNOW WHAT WE'RE
RUNNING A LITTLE BIT TIGHT ON
TIME BUT- MISAPPLIED. BUT
YOURSELF MISTER CONNERY BROUGHT
UP THE FACT IN REGARDS TO IT
LET'S JUST SAY THERE'S A WHALE
AND BY THE WAY- THIS FISHERY
DUNGENESS CRAB STEP FORWARD
PROACTIVELY TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH US TO BE ABLE TO PASS
LEGISLATION. ON GEAR TRAP
RETRIEVAL. IS WELL AS GEAR
MARKINGS AND NOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS IF A WELL FOR
EXAMPLE SWIMS UP FROM THE
SOUTH. FROM MEXICO OR SWIMS
FROM THE NORTH TO THE SOUTH
COMING. IN FROM ANOTHER STATE.
DAISY I- IN TANGO IN- GEAR AND-
SEE. OR THE FED CAN'T IDENTIFY
THAT GEAR IS IT AUTOMATICALLY
FALLS ON THE JUDGE'S CRAB
FISHERY. THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
FAIR ESPECIALLY SINCE- THE
DUNGEONS CRAB FISHERY THE FLEET
HAS STEPPED UP. TIME AND TIME
AGAIN TO BE ABLE TO. MARK THEIR
GEAR AT PURCHASE THERE LAST
YEAR BACK IN TO RETRIEVE LOST
YEAR I THINK THAT IS THERE'S A-
THERE'S A LOOPHOLE IN
ESPECIALLY WHEN STAKES ARE SO
HIGH- IF A MARINE MAMMAL IS
ENTANGLED. IN THEY CAN'T FIGURE
OUT WHERE IT CAME FROM IT
AUTOMATICALLY FALLS IN THE
FISHERY MR CONROY THEY'LL GO TO
MR PLATT- YOUR COMMENT ON THAT
I KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ALL WORKING ON. TO BE
ABLE TO GET THIS THING FIXED.
THANKS FOR THAT. QUESTION THE
CENTER REQUIRE IT IT IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND HOPEFULLY WITH A
YEAH. BUT THE NEXT VERSION OF
RANT RANCH TWO POINT OH YOU
KNOW WE CAN INCORPORATE MORE
UPDATED SCIENCE IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS OF WELLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND WITH MY MARKETING
YOU KNOW THAT YOUR
IDENTIFICATION THAT PASS
THROUGH THE STATE LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS
OF UNKNOWN ENTANGLEMENTS WILL
ACTUALLY BE REDUCED AND GIVEN
THAT HOPEFULLY THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS ON. THE CRAB FISHERY
WILL BE REDUCED AS WELL- IT'S
ONE OF THOSE UNFORTUNATE
RESULTS AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT IS SHE HAS BEEN
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
WORKING GROUP IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THOSE UNKNOWN
ENTANGLEMENTS IN AN EFFORT TO.
IF WE CAN'T RULE OUT. THE DEEP
CRAP FISHERY AS A POTENTIAL
CULPRIT THEN THAT WON'T COUNT
AGAINST YOU CRABTREE. AND WE
SAW THAT WITH A SPERM WHALE
THAT WAS ENTANGLED I THINK IT
WAS IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY.
DOT UP SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA JUST
JUST LOOKING AT THE PICTURES OF
THE OFFENDING HERE ITSELF YOU
CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT IT WAS
MONOFILAMENT BASED AND COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ATTRIBUTED TO THE
DUNGEONS CRABTREE. SO THAT ONE
EVEN THOUGH IT REMAINS UNKNOWN
WAS NOT DID NOT COUNT AGAINST
THE G. TROUT FISHERY SO.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO. FURTHER
VET THESE UNDER UNTANGLE
INCENTIVE POSSIBLE. RULE OUT
THE DEPRESSED FISHERY ALL THE
BETTER. THANK YOU M. S. FIVE.
YEAH I WOULD- ECHO WHAT WHAT
MIKE HAS TO SAY ABOUT THAT AND-
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST GLARING
PROBLEMS WITH THE ORIGINAL
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT- WHICH
INCLUDED A CHARGE FOR
UNIDENTIFIED TYPE CONTAINMENT
SO- GIVEN THAT DATA MEETING TO
RAP OR WE'RE HAVING TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO- CORRECT THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE IT CAN SERIOUSLY
LIMIT THE COMMERCIAL FISHERY
FOR NO GOOD REASON. THE WAY IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
LEFT TO MENTION THAT THE OTHER
PIECE OF THIS YEAR'S. D. THE
FISHERY IS ALREADY DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF CLEANING UP
THEIR OWN HERE HERE THAT COULD
LATER BECOME AN IDENTIFIABLE
BECAUSE OF MONSTER MOVIES OR-
MOVIES THAT HAVE BEEN BROKEN
OFF FOR- SUBMERGED- GEAR. SO-
INITIALLY AND EVEN MORE SO
TODAY WE ARE IN THE HABIT OF
BRINGING IN ANY ABOUT IT- THAT
WE SEE WHILE WE'RE FISHING
DURING THE SEASON AFTER ALWAYS
BEING BROUGHT TO THE DOCTOR IN
SEASON. BY CRAP ABOUT SOULS AND
PEOPLE OR PEOPLE THAT ON THE
CRAB TRAPS GET CALLED IN THE
COMING PICK UP THEIR EAR. AT
THE END OF THE SEASON- I THINK
FOR THE LAST MAYBE FIVE OR SIX
YEARS NOW- THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND OTHER HAPPEN
BABY ASSOCIATION WERE PARTNERED
IN A LOST YEAR RECOVERY PROGRAM.
IT STARTED AND HOW BASED SIX.
IN SPANISH AS SAN FRANCISCO.
BAY AND FURTHER NORTH. AND
HOUSE OF LAST YEAR- ARE
ASSOCIATION BEGAN TO SPONSOR
THAT- IT'S STILL STATEWIDE
CONDOMINIUMS IN INFANCY BUT-
THE IDEA IS THAT AS SOON AS THE
SEASON IS OVER WE HAVE-
RETRIEVAL TEAMS IN EVERY PORT.
EASTER GUYS THAT ARE HIRED TO-
GO OUT AND GET PAID FOR EVERY
LOSS HOT THAT THEY FIND SO
WE'RE DOING. ALMOST A 100% YOUR
RECOVERY NOW THERE'S VIRTUALLY
NO LOST YEAR- AS AS LONG AS WE
CONTINUE TO BE ALLOWED TO GO
OUT AND GET THESE PARTS AND
THEY WILL I BELIEVE IT'LL
IMPROVE EVERY YEAR. I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT BE A- THE NEXT
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE IN TERMS
OF CRACK HERE IS. IS FINDING
MORE FUNDING AVAILABLE- FOR
THESE LOST YOUR RECOVERY
PROGRAMS SHOULD NOT BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. AT A LOCAL
ASSOCIATIONS- DURCH DIE THIS
SUCH A BIG ISSUE THE LAST YEAR
BUT TO ACTUALLY DIED. IT IS- IT
IS LITERALLY OUR JOB TO CLEAN
UP OUR SIDE OF THE STREET. WE
ARE MOTIVATED TO DO THAT- BUT
IT WOULD REALLY HELP IF THE
STATE WOULD GET BEHIND IT AND
WE COULD HAVE MORE CONSISTENCY
IN THAT EFFORT. AND BE ABLE TO
GET YOU A 100% OF YOUR
RETRIEVAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PLATT AND VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THOSE COMMENTS RIGHT THERE
PRESENTLY CALIFORNIA
CONSCRIPTED SITUATION. I WANT
TO GO TO OUR FINAL- QUESTION IN
THAT TOO DOCTOR ANDERSON DR
ANDERSON. WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL OCEAN
OBSERVING SYSTEMS. DOCTOR
ANDERSON TEN YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIANS REALLY DIDN'T HEAR
ABOUT DEMO CASSIDY AND DEMO
CASTED. THE CHALLENGES THE DEMO
GASOLINE FOR EXAMPLE HARMFUL
ALGAL BLOOM. UP DOES FOR DATE
FOR IN PARTICULAR FOR- THE
DUNGENESS CRAB INDUSTRY WHERE
LET'S GET RIGHT TO THIS IS A
QUESTION WE GET A LOT FROM
REPORTERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WHERE'D IT COME FROM IS
IT RELATED TO WARMING- OCEAN
CAN. IS IT RELATED TO CLIMATE.
DOCTORS IN YOU DON'T MIND
GIVING A AN ABC. ON USED OKAY.
IN WHY IS IT SUCH A FORCE NOW-
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FISHER.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION I'LL TRY
TO BE QUICK- BECAUSE IT'S A BIG
ONE AND YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME. SIGNATURES
AND NATURALLY OCCURRING DIET
TIME IN OUR SYSTEM. IT'S HARDLY
NEW- THERE'S A INTERESTING
EVIDENCE THAT SOMEWHERE IN. THE
EARLY NINETIES IT DID SORT OF
TURN ON AND MUCH HIGHER
ABUNDANCE THAN IT USED TO BE
ALTHOUGH THIS THIS STILL STANDS
FOR DEBATE- BUT WE HAVE LOOKED
AT. TIMES OR IS IT THE MOST
ACCESS TO THE BEST WE CAN IN
LIKES YOU CAN ACTUALLY LOOK IN
THE SEDIMENTS AND SEDIMENT
TRAPS AND GET THE DEMO LIKE
ACID OUT OF THEM. AND WE'VE
DONE THAT AND SEEN IT REALLY
DOES RAMP UP AROUND THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND NINE I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IT SEEMS LIKE TEN
YEARS AGO WAS WHEN WE REALLY
STARTED HEARING ABOUT IT. IT
WAS REALLY THE BLOGGING YOU
START HEARING ABOUT IT BUT- IT
WAS A PROBLEM AND THEY WERE HOT
SPOTS IN OUR CHANNEL WAS ALWAYS
A BIG HOT SPOT AND THAT'S WHERE
I STARTED WORKING ON IT- YOU
CAN GO BACK TO THE NINETIES AND
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS AND SEE
SOME DRAMATIC CASES OF BIRD AND
SEEN THEM ALL. WE'RE TELLING
THE EVENTS OKAY SO THAT BEING
SAID. AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
TIME WHAT WE STARTED TO NOTICE
IN THIS TIME SERIES WAS THAT
WHERE IT USED TO BE THREE TO
FOUR YEAR OCCURRENCE NOW IT'S
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. YOU CAN
COUNT ON IT FOR THE MOST PART
SOMEWHERE IN CALIFORNIA- AND
WHY THAT IS WE'RE NOT A 100%
SURE BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS INCLUDING
NOT JUST TEMPERATURE. BUT THE
WAY THAT THE NUTRIENT CHEMISTRY
HAS CHANGED IN THE OCEAN AND-
THAT NUTRI CHEMISTRY CHANGES IN.
RESPONSE TO LARGE SCALE
PATTERNS. THE R. CAN. TO ITS-
IN. PACIFIC CAN BELIEVE. SO
THESE ARE PATTERNS THAT CHANGED
WHEN- WHEN CIRCULATION PATTERNS
CHANGE OVER A LARGE AREA LIKE
THE PACIFIC AND NORTH PACIFIC-
WHY THAT WOULD BE WELL THERE'S
A LOT OF HYPOTHESES OUT THERE
ABOUT HOW IT DOES. CONNECT BACK
TO THE BIGGER GLOBAL PROBLEM OF
CLIMATE CHANGE- THE EXACT
MECHANISMS FOR HOW WE END UP
WITH THE DIFFERENT- KIND OF
NUTRIENT WATER THAT FUELS ARE
APPALLING IS DIFFERENT IT'S
HARD TO SAY. SO WE ARE HOMING
IN ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
HYPOTHESES WARMING IS ONE OF
THEM THE MOVEMENT OF SPECIES
WITHOUT WARNING- NOT ALL
SIGNATURE ARE. CREATED EQUAL IN
THE SENSE THAT SOME ARE REALLY
HOT COMPARED TO OTHERS- AND
THOSE HOT ONES SEEM TO BE
RESPONDING MAYBE- A LITTLE MORE
DON'T. WARMING AND THERE IS
EVIDENCE AND ALL KINDS OF
RESEARCH THAT. WARMING AND
INCREASED. OR DECREASED PH IN
THE WATER IT'S THE HARMFUL
ALGAL SPECIES ARE THE REALLY
TOXIC ONES THAT TEND TO RESPOND
THE MOST. WHAT I. NOT A 100%
SURE BUT- IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THERE IS A CONNECTION AND THAT
MIGHT BE WHY. WE CONTINUE TO
SEE THE SMART FORWARD AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. WHEN I
STARTED WORKING ON THIS AND ONE
OF THE REASONS I MENTIONED THE
THRESHOLDS WHEN I MENTIONED THE
MODEL SO THAT WE MIGHT NEED TO
REVISE THOSE. WHAT MADE A
REALLY HIGH PARTICULATE DEMO
GAS CITY EVENT IN OUR MINDS.
AND LET'S SAY AROUND THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS WEST FIVE HUNDRED
NANOGRAMS PER LITER. NOW DURING
THAT THE BLOCK WHEN I FIRST
TESTIFIED WITH YOU- WE WERE
MADE ME REALIZE HOW MOBILE IS
NOW A NEW HOT SPOT WE HAD
NEVER. SEEN THAT BEFORE MAYBE
BECAUSE WE WEREN'T MEASURING.
BUT WE STARTED TO GET WATER.
CONCENTRATIONS ON THE LEVEL OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND ANAGRAMS
LEADER AND MORE SO YOU CAN JUST
SEE THE SCALE OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. JUST HOW
DRAMATICALLY THINGS HAVE
CHANGED. SINCE YOU KNOW TWO
DECADES AGO ENTERTAINERS AND I
KNOW WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE
LATE BUT YOU JUST QUICKLY. E.
SO YOU YOU ALSO. BELIEVE THAT.
THERE COULD BE LAN BASE.
MATERIAL THAT FLOW. OUT INTO
THE OCEAN IS ALSO CAUSING THIS
JUST IF YOU DON'T MIND GIVE US
SOME SNIPPETS ON YOUR
HYPOTHESIS ON THIS. I WOULD
JUST CAUTION AND SAY WELL I
THINK- LAND BASED NUTRIENTS CAN
PLAY A ROLE I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A COST FOR THE KIND OF
CHANGES WERE SEEN HER SAY WHAT
I THINK. THE ROLE THAT THEY
PLAY IS THEY COULD PROBABLY
POSSIBLY MAKE AN EVENT MORE
TOXIC- THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
IF YOU HAVE AN EXTENT STUDENT
YOU BLEW THE WATER LET'S SAY
MODERATE PAIN YOU GET A BIG.
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER EVENT A LOT
OF FLOW FROM SANTA PANCHA WROTE
THAT THOSE CELLS CAN TRAIN MORE
TOXIC- AND THAT HAS TO DO AGAIN
WITH MUSIC BOX NOW THE IDEA
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH RIVER FLOW
ALL THE TIME THAT WHENEVER WE
SEE A GIVEN THE MOST ACCIDENTS
BECAUSE OF LAND BASED NUTRIENTS
THAT'S NOT QUITE RIGHT- THEIR
SYNERGISTIC. AND THEY CAN WORK
OFF OF ONE ANOTHER BUT I WOULD
SAY IT'S A BIGGER ISSUE THAT'S
DRIVING THE TREND THAT YOU
REFERENCED IN YOUR QUESTION
EARLIER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
DOCTOR ANDERSON THAT WHAT A
FANTASTIC PANEL- TALKING ABOUT
THE OUTLOOK FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DUNGEONS CRAB SEASON THANK YOU
THAT'S DR KRISTA ANDERSON WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO BEN
PLATT MY CON RIGHT. JEANNE
HARBOR SEWN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY ALL
STAR PANEL AND ALL ISSUES AT
DUNGENESS CRAB- I GOTTA TELL
YOU MICHAEL WHO WE WORK
TOGETHER HERE AND HE'S DONE
SUCH A GREAT JOB GOODNESS-
HEARING GOING. HE'S READY FOR
SOME DUNGEONS CRAP AT IS WHAT
HE'S TELLING ME SO- LET'S GET
THIS THESE BOATS OUT IN THE
SEASON OPEN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE MAKING SURE THAT WELLS
ARE SAFE OF COURSE. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
FORWARD TO OUR FISHERY
COMMITTEE NOVEL CULTURE PROGRAM
REPORTS THAT WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS NEXT
PANEL. WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING-
UPDATES FROM AT THIS PANEL ON
IMPORTANT FISHERY PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GOING TO GET RIGHT INTO
IT BECAUSE- SHOW FISHER. HAS
ANOTHER MEETING AND I DO
APOLOGIZE BUT FISHER WERE
RUNNING BEHIND SHE IS WITH THE
ALL STAR ADMINISTRATIVE TEAM OF
THE DUNGEON SCRIPT TASK FORCE
HE'S GONNA PROVIDE US AN UPDATE
ON THE CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS
CRAB TASK FOR STATUS. AND WHAT
IS AHEAD- HERE. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO MISS FISHER THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE ASIANS I
KNOW YOU GOING TO PUT. IN YOUR
BECAUSE REAL SO I'LL TURN THE
FLOOR- OVER TO YOU. KNOW THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR WELL. YEP YEP
THAT'S I THOUGHT I THOUGHT. I
WAS ON MUTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INTEREST. AND IN THIS
A GREAT SEGUE FROM THE LAST
PANEL. AND SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON BEHALF THE D. C. T.
S. SINCE THE LAST. UPDATE THIS
COMMITTEE IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY. THE C. T. S. MAY TWO
REPORTS THE JOINT COMMITTEE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE OPC IN THE FISHING
GAME COMMISSION. AND THESE
REPORTS INCLUDE RECOMMENDATIONS
BASED ON THE TASK FORCE'S
DISCUSSIONS HELD IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY AND MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ON BEHALF OF THE DC
CHAP ABOUT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY CHAIRMAN
CHOIR FOR YOUR RESPONSIVENESS
TO DCHS RECENT RECOMMENDATIONS.
WHICH AS YOU KNOW FROM. THE
BASIS FOR A SPEEDY. BLACK WEEK
I. A HOC TWENTY SEVENTH AND
EIGHT THE DCT ASK NOT TO
DISCUSS PRIORITY TOPICS. AND
SPEED MINISTRY OF TEAM IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A REPORT
INFORMED BY THAT MEETING THAT
WILL BE SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON OR BEFORE JANUARY
FIFTEENTH ONCE IT'S BEEN
REVIEWED BY THE DCT ASK. BUT
I'D LIKE TO USE THIS TIME TO
JUST PROVIDE SOME- TO SHARE
SOME OF WHAT THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS AND REQUESTS
ARE THAT YOU CAN ANTICIPATE IN
THAT REPORT. SO THE MOST RECENT
ACCOUNTING OF THE TENSIONS CRAP
ACCOUNT PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT ISSUED MY LIFE WAS
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISHING SEASON. AND
SIMILAR TO PREVIOUS
RECOMMENDATION THE DCF MADE A
REQUEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE AN ANNUAL ACCOUNTING
ATTENTION IS CRAP ACCOUNTS AS
MANDATED BY FISHING GAME CODE
SECTION EIGHTY TO SEVENTY SIX
POINT FIVE. THEY ALSO ASKED IF
THERE WERE EVER RECOMMENDED
THAT IF THERE WERE ANY EXCESS
FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNTBEYOND
WHAT IS REQUIRED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH WE UNDERSTAND
TO BE A TWO YEAR RESEARCH. THAT
THE DC TF REQUESTED BEASTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE COMMERCIAL
TRAP. COMMERCIAL CRAB TRAP
LIMIT PROGRAM BE REDUCED TO
REFLECT THE REVENUE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM. WITHOUT
CREATING MORE OF A SURPLUS. THE
DISEASE HAVE ALSO REAFFIRMS
THAT RECOMMENDATION FROM
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
THEN TO THE CURRENT NINETY SIX
HOURS YOU'RE SERVICING
REQUIREMENTS FISHING GAME CODE
SECTION NINE THOUSAND FOUR. TO
ALLOWING NINETY SOAK TIME IN A
LIE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RECREATIONAL
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERY. DCF
APPRECIATES THE CONCERNS THAT
SOME OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS HAVE SHARED ABOUT THE
INCREASE SERVICE INTERVAL
HOWEVER AT THE DEJECTED STATE
THAT THERE IS. NO EVIDENCE THAT
AN INCREASE SERVICEABLE
BELIEVED TO MARK YOUR LAST-
DEAR DISPLACEMENT OR AN
INCREASING TENANT RISK. THEY
ALSO STATED THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF TOOLS THAT ARE EITHER
IN PLACE OR WILL BE IN PLACE IN
THE FUTURE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS ABOUT TRACKING LAST
YEAR AND SOME OF THOSE THINGS
ARE- BY WEEKLY REPORTING THAT
IS SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE MANDATING OF
ELECTRONIC MONITORING BY THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SEASON. AND
A LOST FISHING GEAR RECOVERY
PROGRAM THAT TAT AND PLAQUES
REFERRED TO EARLIER WHERE
PERMIT HOLDERS ARE. CHARGED FOR
CAN'T RECOVER AFTER SEASON. IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUE OF IN TANDEM
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RAMP FIFTY CTF DEVELOPED TO
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE VERY
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT YOU HEARD
EARLIER IN THE LAST PANEL. THE
DISEASE HAVE EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATION AT THE FISHERIES
PENALIZED BY UNIDENTIFIED GEAR
INVOLVED IN AN ENTANGLEMENT AND
THE DC CHIEF RECOMMENDED THAT
THE TENSIONS PRACTITIONER
WORKING GROUP DISCUSSING
CONSIDER THE COST BENEFIT PLAN
MARKING. FOR ALL FIXED YOUR
FISHERIES AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE
FOR THE DUNGENESS CRAB TASK
FORCE'S DISCUSSION. AND THIS
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT WILL
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE ATTENTION
THE FUTURE- IN THIS MOMENT I
THINK THAT THEY'RE STILL MORE
DISCUSSION NEEDS TO BE HIGH.
HOWEVER THE DC CHIEF IS
REQUESTING SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON DATA INPUTS TO
INFORM THE RAMP AS WE HEARD
FROM THE PRIOR PANEL. THESE
INDUSTRY WIDE SURVEYS THAT-
TROUBLE CA THE CALIFORNIA COAST
CROWD ASSOCIATION AND THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY COLLABORATED
ON. THE PC CHASSIS IS A LOT OF
VALUE IN THE EAST. AND THE DC
TF RECOMMENDS CONTINUING THOSE
SURVEYS TO GENERATE RELIABLE
USEFUL INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
GAINED AN OFFICIAL DATA SOURCED
BY. ME BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
INFORM THE RAMP. DCF REQUESTED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IDENTIFY
CONSISTENT FUNDING SOURCE TO
SUPPORT THIS DATA COLLECTION
LONG TERM. AND LASTLY THE DTF
DISCUSSED THE NEED FOR MORE
GUIDANCE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
LAW ENFORCEMENT DIVISION ABOUT
HOW TO LEGALLY FISH WITH THE
USE OF A STARBUCKS. SO MIKE
JUST MENTION TO SOMEONE TO GO
IN IN THE LAST CANDLE BUT- DUE
TO A PENDING LEGAL ISSUE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WAS UNABLE TO FULLY ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION BESIDES ANSWERING
LAMINATE. CLARIFYING QUESTIONS.
WHILE FORMAL RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS TOPIC WILL NOT BE
FORWARDED AT THIS TIME SOME DC
CHAPTER MEMBERS REQUESTED THAT
THE TOPIC HE REVISITED ONCE THE
LEGAL ISSUE IS RESOLVED AND
THERE CAN BE A MORE
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. IN THE MEANTIME
THE DC TFT PROVIDES AN INFORMAL
GUIDANCE ON THE ISSUE AND THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE IN THE FINAL
MEETING SUMMARY THAT WILL ALSO.
BE MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
VERY SOON. I'M IN CLOSING ON
BEHALF OF THE DC ASK AND IT'S
TEAM THANK YOU SENATOR IN THE
COMMITTEE YOUR POSITIVE AT THE
DC GUIDANCE TO DATE AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
UPDATE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE NEXT NINE
MINUTES ALL RIGHT THERE WE GO
JOHN IS GOING TO SAY THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR US AND THAT
SORT BOX ISSUE. I'M JUST BEING
BLUNT AND IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU
MY OPINION WE GOT TO GET THIS
FRIGGING THING FIGURED OUT AND
I THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS OUT
THERE AND- NO OPPENHEIM WHO YOU
KNOW WELL IN AS INTERIM CHIEF
CONSULTANT WILL BE FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOU ON THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
REGARDLESS IF CDFW CAN ENGAGE
OR NOT THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GET- FIGURED OUT HERE THIS
YEAR SO I AGAIN COMMON SENSE
APPROACH. ON THIS ITEM. AND
THERE WERE SOME TASK FORCE
MEMBERS THAT THAT DO YOU WANT
TO SEE SOMETHING AND- THEY'RE
NOT SURE IF IT'S A LEGISLATIVE
FIX OR IF ITS GUIDANCE Q. L.
TO. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION ON HOW TO INTERPRET
THE LAW. BUT SOME FOLKS SAID
YOU KNOW THAT THEY WERE JUST
HESITANT TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION WITHOUT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW THINGS ARE
GOING TO PLAY OUT AND
ABSOLUTELY HERE THE CONCERN
THAT. YOU FOLKS DON'T WANT TO
BE CRIMINALIZED FOR YOU KNOW
HOW THEY HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
FISHING SINCE. THEY STARTED
FISHING THERE'S ROOM TO
ABSOLUTELY- WE WILL DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT- IS WELL AND
I HAVE THAT ON MY- FOLLOW UP
AND I KNOW MISTER OPPENHEIM.
WILL ALSO BE FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT. THAT IS MISS FISHER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA JUST CRAP TASK
FORCE. AND AGAIN IT IS OUR
FAULT WE'RE RUNNING LATE THIS
FISHER THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL. THAT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA NEED TO CUT OUT FOR
ANOTHER MEETING SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WE'RE NOW TO BE MOVING FORWARD
TO MR LEVEL MR LEVEL IS A
HARDWORKING AQUACULTURE
COORDINATOR FOR THE CAPTAIN
APARTMENT. THAT FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE WELCOME MR LEVEL
TWO COMMITTEE YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT WHEN YOU
GET TOWARDS THE END. MR LEVEL
GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR AND I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
ARE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
KIND WORDS AND- HELLO SENATOR
HUESO APPRECIATE YOU INVITING
ME TO SPEAK. AQUACULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA IS DIVERSE BACKTEST
SETTINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN URBAN AND RURAL LOCATIONS
FROM DESERTS TO MOUNTAINS
INLAND VALLEYS TO COAST
FRESHWATER AND MARINE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE'S
PRODUCE FISH SHELLFISH AND
SEAWEED FROM MANY DIFFERENT
CONSUMERS AND BENEFICIARIES
INCLUDING THE DELIBERATE
RESTORATION OF SPECIES AND
HABITATS. EXCEPT FOR PRODUCERS
IN CALIFORNIA FOUND AND
CULTIVATED A VARIETY OF
SPECIALTY NICHES SHOWING A DEFT
ABILITY TO A CHALLENGING
LANDSCAPE OF HIGH COSTS AND
GLOBAL COMPETITIVE FORCES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS ALL THIS
IN THE DECADES BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AQUACULTURE PRODUCERS
ARE RESILIENT AND OUR FLYING
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE RECENT
MARKET AND SUPPLY CHAIN
DISRUPTIONS TO IMPROVE. RETOOL
AND RETRAIN FINE TUNE A SAFE
AND SECURE OUR SEAFOOD SUPPLY
WHILE PROVIDING DIRECT AND
ANCILLARY BENEFITS TO
ECOSYSTEMS. FISH PROCESSING
CAPACITY OF FARM RAISED PRODUCT
IN CALIFORNIA HAS RECENTLY
GROWN. MODESTLY BUT WHAT WAS
THERE BEFORE HAS FOUND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND UNDER
CURRENT MARKET CIRCUMSTANCES
FAVOURING LOCAL PRODUCT. AMID
CURRENT I'M SORRY AMID
RECURRING DROUGHT HERE IN THE
WEST MARINE AQUACULTURE WHICH
USES NEARLY ZERO FRESH WATER TO
DELIVER ITS MUCH NEEDED
PRODUCTS AND BENEFITS.
DEMONSTRATES BOTH CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
SCARCE FRESHWATER RESOURCES. AS
WELL AS VULNERABILITY TO
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS AND
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES TO ADAPT
TO THESE CHALLENGES FOR EXAMPLE
REGISTERED COMMERCIAL ARJUN
RANCHING IS NOW HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA. DRIVING THE REMOVAL
OF OVER POPULATED SEA URCHINS
FROM DECIMATED KELP BEDS INTO
LAND BASED AQUACULTURE SYSTEMS.
EMPLOYING A DIRECT ECONOMIC
INSTANT INCENTIVES THAT
RESTORES KELP HABITAT. OR AT
LEAST WE HOPE SO. THE PROCESS
ADDS VALUE BY FEEDING HOLLOW
ORIGINS TO PRODUCE VALUE WHAT
LOONY IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
WHILE REMOVING GRAZING PRESSURE
SO THE KELP BEDS CAN RECUPERATE.
SPEAKING OF KELP SEAWEED
FARMING IN CALIFORNIA IS
TRANSITIONING FROM ARE INDEED
TO COMMERCIAL SCALE WITH
INITIAL PERMIT APPROVALS FOR
ONE OPERATION IN SANTA BARBARA.
AND DEMONSTRATIONS SHOWING
PROGRESS FROM HUMBOLDT TO LOS
ANGELES TO SAN DIEGO.
DELIVERING MORE RESPONSIVE
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT AND CUTTING
BLUE TAPE WITH A CLEAR AND
SIMPLE LICENSING PATHWAY IS
WHAT ENABLES PRODUCERS TO
INNOVATE ADAPT AND GROW WITH
MORE REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY.
WHILE MAINTAINING THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFEGUARDS. CALL
IT DREW US ALL OCCUR. AND
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE HAS HELPED
BRIDGE MANY IN THE AQUACULTURE
INDUSTRY WHO SUFFERED LOSSES
BUT AS WE LOOK AHEAD IN A
STRONGER POSITION FOR
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY LOCAL SEAFOOD
RESILIENT WATERFRONT
COMMUNITIES. PROSPERS BLUE
ECONOMIES AND HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ENABLE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN PERMITTING PROCESSES AND
OBTAINING SOCIAL LICENSE TO
OPERATE CREATES STEEP BARRIERS
TO ENTRY. HAS THE EFFECT OF
SELECTING NOT FOR EQUITY BUT
FOR THE FINANCIAL INSURANCE OF
ALL OF THE LARGEST AND DEEPEST
POCKETED ENTERPRISES.
RESPONSIVE ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
REQUIRES A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
CAPACITY IN TERMS OF STAFF
NUMBERS AND EXPERIENCE.
AQUACULTURE PROGRAM CAPACITY ON
BOTH FRONTS IS CONSTRAINED IN
OUR STATE AGENCIES. AND WE HAVE
THE OBJECTIVE MEASUREMENTS OR
METRICS OF SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING THAT CONFIRM THE
SHORTFALLS WITHIN VISUAL WHILE
I RECEIVE REGULAR CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS VOICING CONCERNS.
ABOUT TIMELY IN RESPONSE TO
DELIVERY OF SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC. WE SIMPLY CAN'T BE
ACCOMPLISHED AT CURRENT
CAPACITY. OUR REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SCHEDULED AFTER THE
FIRST OF THE YEAR. VITA DISTANT
DETAILS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUILDING CAPACITY ALSO INCLUDES
BUILDING KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE AS WE RELY ON
INCREASINGLY SPECIALIZED SKILLS
TO DESIGN CONSTRUCT OPERATE AND
OVERSEE AQUACULTURE SYSTEMS
WITH THEIR LAND OR OCEAN BASED
THE CONCEPT OF PROFESSIONAL OR
VOCATIONAL CERTIFICATES AND
STANDARDS SHOULD HAVE A PLACE
IN BUILDING FURTHER CONFIDENCE
IN SAFE AND RELIABLE FACILITIES
AND THEIR OPERATIONS. I'M
PLEASED TO REPORT A GROWING
EFFORT TO BUILD EDUCATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AT
MULTIPLE LEVELS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. INCLUDING SANTA MONICA
AND FEATHER RIVER COLLEGE'S
CAMPUS IS A MARINE LABS
THROUGHOUT THE CSU AND UC
SYSTEMS. USC AN OCCASIONAL AND
STEM PROGRAMS SUPPORTED AT
MIDDLE AND SECONDARY SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HOWEVER
PEOPLE ARE EMERGING FROM THIS
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT.
DESERVE ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY
THIRTY SECONDS. TO APPLY THEIR
SKILLS TO PROBLEM SOLVING TO BE
PRODUCTIVE. FOUR DISTRICTS IN
SAN DIEGO AND HUMBLE AND
FACILITIES LIKE OUT TO SEA IN
LOS ANGELES ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
CAPACITY IN OTHER IMPORTANT
WAYS BY HOSTING FACILITIES FOR
INNOVATION PROVIDING START UP
ASSISTANCE THROUGH BUSINESS
INCUBATORS. AND HELPING O
SECURE PERMITS AND ENTITLEMENTS
WHERETHE LIFT IS TOO GREAT FOR
SMALLER START UPS. AS WE EMERGE
FROM THE CONFINES OF THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE FORTUNATE THAT
AQUACULTURE AMERICA WHICH IS
THE NATIONAL GATHERING OF
WORLDWIDE. EXPERTS IN
AQUACULTURE IS TAKING PLACE
FIRST WEEK OF MARCH IN SAN
DIEGO. PROVIDES A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM AND
PARTICIPATE IN TECHNICAL AND
POLICY DISCUSSIONS FOR
EXHIBITIONS. AND MEETINGS
COVERING THE BREADTH OF
AQUACULTURE TOPICS AND AN
OPTION TO TOUR THE DEPARTMENT'S
PARTNER. IN THE OCEAN RESOURCE
ENHANCEMENT AND HATCHERY
PROGRAM JUST HUBBS SEAWORLD
RESEARCH INSTITUTE. THEY HAVE
AND CONTINUE TO PIONEER THE
CULTIVATION OF WHITE SEA BASS
IN A VARIETY OF OTHER MARINES
SPECIES IMPORTANT TO SPORT AND
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES. PASSAGE
BY THE WAY A REPEAT HE B.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE AND A HALF
OF THAT PROGRAM LAST YEAR IS
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. AS IS
THE INFUSION OF SUPPORT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR ALL TO SEE AS
IT DEVELOPS BIRTH FIFTY EIGHT
INTO A CENTER FOR INNOVATION.
FOR OCEAN BASED BUSINESSES
SPECIALIZING IN SUSTAINABLE
AQUACULTURE. OFFSHORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY AN UNDERWATER ROBOTICS
AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATIONAL AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES. THESE
ARE ALL GREAT STARTS BUILDING
CAPACITY FOR AQUACULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF SOME.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF MANY
MORE. IT'S A START. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER LEVEL WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK SIR-
WORKING NET SO MUCH GENERALLY
SHE'S AQUACULTURE FOR HIS
CAREER VERY GRATEFUL SIR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. ALL RIGHT THE
GERMAN WE'RE NOT TO HEAR. FROM
A DEER IN ROW CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVISORY COMMITTEE
ON SALMON AND STEELHEAD TROUT
HERE AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY I'M
SORRY THAT WE CAN'T BE IN
PERSON. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK- PROVIDE AN-
UPDATE ON BEHALF. OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
IT'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECONDS.
HEADS UP. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE GOOD AFTERNOON AND- TO
YOU AND. I THINK THE COMMITTEE
MEETINGS IN PERSON YOU CONDUCT
SUCH A WONDERFUL MEETING- I
WISH I COULD BE THERE TODAY
BUT- IT IS AN HONOR FOR ME TO
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON SALMON
AND STEELHEAD AS OUR CHAIRMAN-
AS YOU SAID MY NAME IS DARREN
MURRAY ON THE NORTH COAST
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA TRIAL.%
IN THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
START A COUPLE POSITIVE NOTES I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
SENATOR IN THIS COMMITTEE. ON
BEHALF OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO HARD.
TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR
NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION IN
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET. IT'S
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGING TO US
THAT THE WORK WE DO TO PROTECT
SALMON STILL HAD IN THE STATE.
IS AMONG THE STATE'S NATURAL
RESOURCE PRIORITIES- THAT
FUNDING COMING FORWARD IS GOING
TO BE CRITICAL TO SAVING THESE
IMPERILED FISH POPULATIONS- I
ALSO WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
STATE'S EFFORTS OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS. AND IT'S CUTTING THE
GREEN TAPE EFFORT. FROM
SECRETARY CROWFOOT AND DEPUTY
SECRETARY DR JENNIFER NORRIS AT
THE RESOURCES AGENCY. DR BONHAM
AND HIS STAFF. IN THE STATE
WATER BOARD WHO HAVE DEVELOPED
A REALLY IMPORTANT TOOL WITH A
STATEWIDE RESTORATION GENERAL
ORDER- THIS COMING FORWARD THIS
COMING YEAR- THIS IS A GAME
CHANGER FOR MUCH OF THE RATE
RESTORATION WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING. AND I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THAT WORK. ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE THERE ARE TWO
MAIN ITEMS I WANT TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION TODAY. NAMELY
DROUGHT PLANNING. AND. THE
CALIFORNIA MONITORING PROGRAM.
OUR ADVISORY CAN ON DRY AT OUR
LAW. MEETING AND WE HAVE SIX
MAIN COMMENTS I WANT TO BRING
FORWARD TO YOUR ATTENTION.
FIRST OF ALL WE DON'T HAVE
INSTREAM FLOW REQUIREMENTS IN
MOST RIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY ARE UNREGULATED
COASTAL RIVERS. DESPITE THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ACTION PLAN
PRIORITIZING JUST FIVE RIVERS.
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF SLOW STUDIES
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. WE HAVE
STILL NOT RECEIVED FULL
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANY OF THOSE
FIVE RIVERS. SECOND OF ALL WE
NEED TO HAVE OUR STATE AGENCIES
PREPARED ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO
RESPOND TO DROUGHT. WE CANNOT
WAIT TILL WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
THE NEXT OUGHT TO DECIDE TO
TAKE ACTION. AND THEN HOW TO
IDENTIFY YET AGAIN WHAT ACTIONS
MIGHT BE TAKEN. WITH OUR
CURRENT FUTURE CLIMATE BECOMING
DRIER WE NEED TO HAVE ROBUST
DROUGHT MANAGEMENT PLANS IN
PLACE. AND READY AS A CRANIAL
ACTIVITY. THIS IN TURN WILL
LIKELY ENTAIL THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AVAILABLE TO
THOSE RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES. SO
THAT THOSE STEPHANOPOULOS SIX
TEMPORARILY. ASSIGNED TO DEAL
WITH THE ONGOING DROUGHT CRISIS
AND THEN DISAPPEAR BACK TO
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS ONCE THE
FIRST RAINS ARRIVE. WE NEED
PERMANENT. STAFF DEDICATED TO
DROUGHT PLANNING. WE NEED MORE
RESEARCH. FROM OUR PERMITTING
AGENCIES FOR SECURING WATER
RIGHT APPROVALS FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE PROJECTS. WATER
USERS HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE OPERATIONS MORE DROUGHT
RESILIENT BY CHANGING THE
SEASON OF DIVERSION. CREATING
OFF CHANNEL STORAGE ADOPTING
CONJUNCTIVE USE OF GROUNDWATER
AND MANY OTHER MECHANISMS FOR
PROTECTING STREAM FLOW AND
INCREASING WATER SECURITY. BUT
THESE PROJECTS TAKE TOO LONG TO
GET APPROVED AND THIS NEEDS TO
CHANGE. OUR OTHER EXISTING
RERESENTATIVES TODAY HAVE
ALREADY SUGGESTED CONTINUE
TRACKING OF HATCHERY FISH TO
MORE WESTERN RELEASE OINTS IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY INSTEAD
OF SAN PABLO. AND OUR ADVISORY
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS THAT ACTION
AS WELL. AND LAST WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE OUR STATE AGENCIES
REESTABLISHED BAY DELTA WATER
QUALITY AND FLOW REQUIREMENTS
THIS WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER IN
OUR BUDGET SHE SUPPORTS THAT AS
WELL AS SUPPORT STRONG
PROTECTIVE MEASURES. FOR SALMON
WHILE THE NEW DELTA BIOLOGICAL
OPINION IS BEING WRITTEN.
REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA
MONITORING PROGRAM- YOU'RE
LIKELY AWARE I'VE DISCUSSED
THIS PROGRAM WITH THE TOO MANY
IN THE PAST AND YOU STILL HAVE
NOT SEEN PROGRESS IN FUNDING.
TO ALLOW THIS PROGRAM TO SERVE
ITS PURPOSE WE RELY ON THIS
MONITORING PROGRAM STATEWIDE TO
INFORM OUR RESTORATION EFFORTS
SPOKE FOR HABITAT AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION. WHICH ARE NOW
SPENDING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TAX DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
THISEFFORT WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION WE DO NOT KNOW IF
THIS INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
FUNDS. IS BEING AFFECTED. IN
ADDITION OUR STATE STREET STATE
AND FEDERAL FISHERY AGENCY
PARTNERS RELY ON THIS
INFORMATION EXTENSIVELY FOR
POPULATION STATUS UPDATES. FOR
THEIR ENDANGERED SPECIES
RECOVERY TRACKING. AND THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE EXCELLENT JOBS
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
FISHERIES AND WATER SHOULD
SCIENTISTS. YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WORK FOR THE WATERSHED
STORAGE PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
IT'S A GREAT TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE FOLKS. THIS YEAR
THERE WAS A CONCERTED EFFORT BY
SEVERAL CONSERVATION GROUPS
INCLUDING SEVERAL OF OUR
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FROM THE STATE
BUDGET TO SEE IF W. YOUR MARKER
STAMINA STILL LIKE POPULATION
MONITORING. AS YOU'RE LIKELY
AWARE THIS FUNDING WAS ABSORBED
INTO GENERAL FUNDS FOR THOSE
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE. PROVIDED
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND NOW IT
LOOKS AS THOUGH THOSE FUNDS
WILL NOT BE GOING TOWARD THEIR
INTENDED TARGET OF MONITORING
PROGRAM. OUR MOST RECENT
ADVISOR INCISOR COMMITTEE
MEETING THE DEPARTMENT STAFF
INFORMED OUR COMMITTEE THAT.
OUT OF TWENTY SIX PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE FOR WHICH BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL FISHERIES AGENCIES
ARE PRIORITIZED ONLY TEN OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDED. AND THIS CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AN ADDITIONAL
SIX PROGRAMS WILL HAVE LOST OUR
FUNDING AND BE SHUT DOWN. THESE
ARE ALL PROGRAMS THAT HAVE LONG
TERM DATASETS ON POPULATION
ABUNDANCE AND THEY WILL BE
DISCONTINUED THIS YEAR. FINALLY
OF THE TOTAL PROGRAM NEED ABOUT
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WE ESTIMATE ONLY
ABOUT TWO MILLION IS BEING MADE
AVAILABLE FROM THE COASTAL
MONITORING PROGRAMS AND ALL OF
THAT IS FROM FEDERAL FUNDS.
FROM THE PCS ARE PROGRAM IN
CLOSING WE NEED OUR STATE
FISHERIES AGENCIES TO
PRIORITIZE THIS PROGRAMMING WE
NEED JUST NEEDS HELP TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO DO THIS
WORK. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. HEARING THE
PLEASURES. OURS THANK YOU SO
MUCH TERENCE CAN BE HANGING
WITH US HERE FOR A BIT AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET ANY
QUESTIONS DURING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY YOUR HARD WORK
SIR EACH AND EVERY YEAR AND
WE'RE THRILLED THAT YOU'RE WITH
US TODAY. WE'RE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
HEAR FROM THESE WHITE MEN- AT
LEAST DOES A FANTASTIC JOB
EVERY TIME SHE IS IN FRONT OF
KIM AT THE COMMITTEE. SHE OF
COURSE IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN SIGN
STRESSED THIS WOMAN IS SO
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU AGAIN
SORRY THAT WE COULD NOT BE IN
PERSON. THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH M. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS DR LIZ
WISEMAN AND I SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA OCEAN SCIENCE
STRESSED. I HAD TO APPRECIATE
THE REMOTE. PATIENT AS I JOIN
YOU TODAY LATE IN THE EVENING
AND LONDON- A QUICK REMINDER.
ABOUT AS CALIFORNIA OCEAN
SCIENCE TRUST IS A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
CONVENING SCIENCE EXPERTISE. TO
ACCELERATE PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
HEALTHY EQUITABLE AND
PRODUCTIVE CAUSED AN OCEAN. WE
WERE CREATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO BRIDGE THE GAP
BETWEEN CUTTING EDGE SCIENCE
AND CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSITIES
AND SCIENCE INSTITUTIONS. AND
FOUNDATION POLICY AND
MANAGEMENT. SO I HAVE TO UPDATE
FOR YOU TODAY. FIRST WE'RE
REQUIRED BY THAT STATE FUNDING
LEGISLATION TO REPORT ANNUALLY
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND TO THIS
JOINT COMMITTEE. TODAY I'M-
PLEASED TO FORMALLY PRESENT ON
TWENTY TWENTY AND YOUR RECORD.
AND SHARE A COUPLE. OF
HIGHLIGHTS FROM FROM THAT. SO
PULLING OUT TO COUPLE OF HIGH
THAT MAYBE OF PARTICULAR
INTEREST IN THIS VENUE- AND
ALSO BUILDING ON AN
APPRECIATING OUR COLLABORATIONS
WITH OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
THAT DOCTOR MARK GOLDRING
FRIENDS EARLIER. TODAY
DELIVERED A SCIENCE BASED
ROADMAPS TRACTION ON
MICROPLASTICS AND MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS. THE BUILDING
ON THAT THE THINGS THAT I
WANTED TO FOCUS ON HERE IS TO
START WITH A COMMENT THAT MUCH
FUNDING FOR BASIC SCIENCE
RESEARCH CREATES COMPETITION
BETWEEN CAMPUSES AND
RESEARCHERS. IT DOESN'T- ALWAYS
WORKING IN IN THE INTERESTS OF
PRIORITY STATES- QUESTIONS- SO
WE TAKE PRIDE IN OUR APPROACH
TO BUILD NEW COLLABORATIONS
ACROSS DISCIPLINES NATURAL AND
SOCIAL SCIENCES. FORGE NEW
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
RESEARCHERS AT DIFFERENT
UNIVERSITIES. AND ORIENT TO
ADDRESSING PARTY QUESTIONS TO
THE STATE. LAST YEAR WE WERE-
REALLY THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT GROUPS OF RESEARCHERS
TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW RESEARCH FUNDING
FROM CENTRAL AND STILL. IN
TRAFFIC- SUNDAY AS- FOR EXAMPLE
LAUNCHED NEW ROOF FROM AND-
WITH THE ECONOMISTS AT UC DAVIS
TO EXPLORE HOW FLEXIBLE FISHING
TOURNAMENTS AND OTHER ASPECTS
OF MANAGEMENT COULD OR- COULD
NOT BE DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT
HELPS FISHING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS. AND HERE WERE
REALLY TRYING TO PAY ATTENTION
TO NOT ONLY HOUSES POPULATIONS
ARE PREDICTED TO CHANGE AND
MOVE BUT ALSO GOOD TO THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC GOVERNANCE
AND MANAGEMENT APPROACHES.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY IN THE
CONTEXT OF DUNGEON S. CRAB
ABOUT- HOW UNCERTAINTY CREATES
A- N. AND RECURRING IMPACTS
CREATE A NEED FOR NIMBLENESS
AND FAST RESPONSE ANSWERED THIS
RESEARCH IS ATTEMPTING TO LAY
OUT SOME SCENARIOS- BY WAY THAT
WE COULD ACHIEVE THAT. THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING COMMUNITIES.
WE ALSO SUPPORTED A COALITION
OF RESEARCHERS FROM UC DAVIS
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY IN
ARKANSAS STATE UNIVERSITY TO
OBTAIN HOUSTON RESEARCH FUNDING
FROM THE NOW- OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION PROGRAM. THIS
RESEARCH WHICH IS ON THE WAY
NOW- AIMS TO UNDERSTAND THE
SOCIAL RESILIENCE-
SUCCESSFACTORS AMONG COASTAL
SHELLFISH GROWERS. IN THE FACE
OF CHANGING OCEAN CHEMISTRY ON
ON THE WEST COAST SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO COMING BACK TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW RESULTS- FROM THIS
I WOULD I THINK I WAS REALLY
POLICY SALIENCE- RESEARCH- WITH
YOU NEXT YEAR. SO MY UP TO IS
JUST PROGRESS FROM THE- YEAR OF
OUR NEW SCIENCE SERVICES
PROGRAM DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
LAWMAKERS. COMPLIMENTING OUR
DECADE OF EXPERIENCE IN WORKING
WITH PARTNERS IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO PROTECTION COUNSELED-
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE AND MANY OF
THOSE. THIS PROGRAM IS CREATED
TO FULLY LIVE UP TO THE
ASPIRATIONS OF COMPOUNDING
LEGISLATION AND BRINGS SCIENCE
KNOWLEDGE SOLUTIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. DIRECTLY TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT YOUR
DECISION MAKING. WE CATALYZE
THE LAUNCH OF THIS PROGRAM IN
JANUARY WITH DEEP SUPPORT FROM
THE WILLIAM AND FLORA HEWLETT
FOUNDATION AN ADDITIONAL
PRIVATE AND FOUNDATION DONORS.
TODAY WE HAVE HOSTED VIRTUAL
SCIENCE BRIEFINGS ON KELP
FOREST RESTORATION OFFSHORE
WIND ENERGY DEVELOPMENTS IN THE.
RECENT HUNTINGTON OIL SPILL. A
BRIEFING ARE THE MOST POP UP
AND I DESIGN TO OFFER AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STOCKS. FROM THE
LEGISLATION TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY
WITH SCIENCE EXPERTS- AND I'M
ASKING QUESTIONS WITH THRILLED
THAT THE BRIEFINGS HELD TO DATE
HAVE HAD OVER A HUNDRED
ATTENDEES WITH STRONG
LEGISLATIVE STOCKING
ENGAGEMENTS. AND I'VE SENT
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EMBARRASSED TO CHI. CHU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF TEACHING
ARTISTS FOR HOSTING THE EVENTS
THAT WE HAVE TODAY. I LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING THIS
COMMITTEE- FURTHER AND THE
STOCKS I AM IN IN FUTURE EVENTS
AND CONVERSATIONS. AND JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH OXIME BY OKAY I
THINK WE'RE FORTY AND COUNTING
COMMITTEE AND MEMBER STOCKS-
OVER THE PAST MONTHS IT'S BEEN
A REAL PRIVILEGE TO CONNECT
STOCKS TO SCIENCE EXPERIMENTS
ON THE GROUND IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDES TECHNICAL FEEDBACK
ON ON BILL IDEAS AMONG AMONG
OTHER CONVERSATIONS WE'RE
REALLY COMMITTED TO
STRENGTHENING THESE
RELATIONSHIPS AND DEEPENING OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS COSTA NOTION
INTERESTS AND PRIORITIES- IN
THE LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN
EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT IN THE
UPCOMING TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
SESSION. WITH USEFUL SCIENCE
SOLUTIONS AND ADVICE AND WITH
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
EXECUTOR WORKING THE NIGHT
SHIFT TONIGHT FROM LONDON OF
ALL PLACES MY GOODNESS WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE WITH US. I'M GONNA START
WITH A FEW QUESTIONS- IN MISS
WHITE MEN SO- YOU'VE BEEN DOING
SO MUCH WORK ON- I'M BEARING
LARGE LEGACY PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE. I'D LIKE TO BE TO
GET INTO SALMON- AND REALLY HOW
DO YOU SEE YOUR ROLE OR DO YOU
THINK YOU COULD GET POTENTIALLY
MORE INVOLVED. IN BRIDGING THAT
OCEAN FRESH WATER GAP IS LOOK
THIS SPECIES IS ON THE BRINK.
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE SACRAMENT
A WATERSHED RIGHT I MEAN THERE
IS A HIGH LIKELIHOOD THAT OVER
THE NEXT DECADE THAT WE MAY SEE
A TOTAL EXTINCTION- NOT THERE
YET BUT A HIGH LIKELIHOOD YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS. KNOWING HOW
BUSY YOU ARE AND SO. MANY
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS FOR THAT TO
BE TO GET YOUR TAKE. YEAH THE
QUEST- AND IT'S THAT I MAY TIME
WE- WE'VE GOT BEEN CONVERSATION.
WITH NOW I AND- AT THE TWO
CONSULTANTS- FOR THE COMMITTEE.
AND OTHERS SAID THAT UC SANTA
CRUZ ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF
ENGAGING MORE ON THIS AND WHILE
SUPPORTING. AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS- AT UC SANTA CRUZ WHO
HAS DEEP INTEREST IN THIS
ISSUE. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE INTERESTED IN
PURSUING I THINK THAT THE NEXUS
THAT I SEE WITH WITHOUT WORK IS
TWO FOLD ONE IS WITH THAT-
FLEXIBLE ALERT FLEXIBLE IS A
CHALLENGING WHERE IT THAT THIS
SORT OF. NIMBLE ADAPTIVE
CHANGING MANAGEMENT REGIMES
GETTING REALLY CREATIVE AND
THINKING ABOUT SALMON FISHERY
MANAGEMENT APPROACHES AND IN
THE STATES. AND NOT DOING SO IN
ISOLATION FROM FROM AND THEN TO
THE OCEANS OF SPECIES SO. LIKE
LIKE SALMON. AND ALSO
CONNECTING TO OUR NEW WEBSITE
SERVICES PROGRAM WHERE I HOPE
THAT WE CAN- BIEN A MECHANISM
TO FOSTER BRINGING SOME OF THE
NEW CUTTING EDGE- SCIENCE
RESEARCH ON RESTORATION
TECHNIQUES- TWO DIFFERENT
AUDIENCES AND VENUES AND IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S CERTAINLY A
TOPIC THAT I WOULD BE WILLING
TO AND OPEN AND EXCITED TO
DISCUSS ALONG WITH YOU. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONVERSATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS WELL AND
AGAIN WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE.
YOU BEING WITH US AND
ESPECIALLY AFTER HOURS THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WANNA GO BACK
OVER TO DARING. WITH THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON SALMON
STEELHEAD TROUT. IN THERE AND
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE IN A FIRE
DRILL EVERY YEAR WHEN- A
DROUGHT HITS YOU TALKED ABOUT.
ADVANCE PLANNING ARE YOU
FEELING THAT THERE IS ANY
CHANGE. IN WHAT THE STATE'S
DOING WITH FOR EXAMPLE THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THAT FIFTEEN BILLION. IT'S A
LARGER PACKAGE ON CLIMATE. AND
CLIMATE ACTION BUT ALSO ON
DROUGHT BUT ARE YOU FEELING
THAT. WE SOUGHT TO PICK UP THE
GAME ONE IT COMES TO TERM AND-
FOR WHAT A MORE AREA. BECAUSE
WILL LOOK IN THE STATE. THAT'S
REALLY A QUESTION YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT- SOME OF
THAT FUNDING IS GOING TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO OTHER
AGENCIES TO INCREASE OUR STAFF
AND THAT'S THAT'S A NUMBER. YOU
KNOW THE NUMBER ONE FIRST STEP
THAT NEEDS TO BE BAD- WE'RE
WE'RE I THINK YOU MAY BE AWARE
THAT SOME OF OUR GROUPS ARE
GOING TO BE COMING TO YOUR
STAFF AND YOURSELF TO DISCUSS
LEGISLATION THAT MIGHT PUT IN
PLACE SOME REQUIREMENTS TO HAVE
THESE ACTIONS TAKE PLACE. WE
CERTAINLY THINK THAT- THIRD
THIRTY THREE MORE DONE THAN
THERE IS NOW- THE FUNDING
THAT'S COMING FORWARD IS
CERTAINLY GOING TO HELP- OUT ON
THE GROUND AND IN THOSE
AGENCIES. YEAH BUT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO PUT THIS INTO PLACE
RIGHT WITH POLICY SO I THINK
THAT'S THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT ITEM. WHEN IT COMES
TO INDEBTEDNESS SO IT BECOMES
PART OF THE CULTURE RIGHT. WHEN
IT COMES WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WHAT OUR FUTURE LOOKS LIKE
IN THE STATE DURING THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I'D LIKE TO GO
QUICKLY. TO MR LEVEL SO LOOK IT
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF KIND OF A
CONVERSATION JUST A LEVEL ABOUT
AQUACULTURE- ANI AND HOW WE CAN
BE ABLE TO BECOME. A HOME HERE
ON THE WEST COAST FOR THIS. BUT
THE LEVEL THERE ALWAYS SEEMS TO
BE A BIT OF A STUMBLING BLOCK
SO IF YOU DON'T MIND TALK ABOUT
WHAT DO YOU SEE THOSE%
BOTTLENECKS TO BE ABLE TO. HAVE
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH HERE IN THE
YEARS TO COME- IT PROBABLY
WOULD TAKE TIME TO PROVIDE GOOD
ANSWERS BUT I THINK THAT- WHEN
I TOUCHED ON CAPACITY THAT'S A
THAT'S A CRITICAL THING- WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
REQUESTS FOR- RESPOND TO
REQUESTS TO EVALUATE NEW
PROJECTS- WE HAVE. SOME VERY
IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITIES. TO
MAINTAIN SAFEGUARDS ALSO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO SUPPORT
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT'S A FINE BALANCE THAT- WE
TAKE QUITE SERIOUSLY SO HAVING
THE CAPACITY TO- THOROUGHLY
ANALYZE THOSE THINGS THIS IS A
BIG DEAL- I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY'S. I'M LOOKING AT-
CUTTING CORNERS OR STREAMLINING
PROCESS SEES WE JUST NEED TO
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO FULLY.
YEAH WE HAVE A VERY COMPETITIVE-
LAND USE COAST THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON SOME.
THE FEDERAL FEDERAL EFFORT TO
IDENTIFY AQUACULTURE
OPPORTUNITY AREAS WAS- IT IS
COMING OUT WITH AN ATLAS LATER
THIS MONTH AND- HEARING WHAT
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH TO FIGURE
OUT SPATIAL PLANNING WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT CONSIDERATIONS
SHOWS JUST HOW CHALLENGING IT
IS SO THERE'S A LOT TO BE.
TACKLED AND I THINK THAT THE
OBCS ACTION PLAN WILL BE QUITE
HELPFUL IN IN PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK IN AND STRUCTURE FOR
HOW WE FILL IN THE GAPS AND I
EXPECT THAT WILL BE- HAVING
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME TO
THE FOREFRONT AS THAT ACTION
PLAN. GETS FINALIZED IN THE IN
THE FOLLOWING YEAR IT'S A LEVEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT AND
I KNOW I PUT YOU PUT ON THE
SPOT IN HAD A LIMITED TIME SO
VERY VERY GRATEFUL AGAIN FOR
YOUR WORK THAT'S RANDY LEVEL
AQUACULTURE COORDINATOR FOR THE
COPPER DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WHILE I FEEL I SAY THANK YOU TO
MR LEVEL OF COURSE. TO MISS
WHITE MEN WHOSE DEMON IN TODAY
FROM THE GREAT CITY OF LONDON
IS WHITE MEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
WERE REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
YOUR HARD WORK HE'S THE-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN
SCIENCE TRUST OF COURSE YOU
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA VISOR
COMMITTEE AND- SALMON STEELHEAD
TROUT DERREN SO GOOD TO SEE YOU
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WANT
TO SAY. THANK YOU TO OUR SHOWS
WELL SHE HELPS LEAD THE
CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB TASK
FORCE THOSE WHO WERE OUR
FISHERY COMEDIAN AQUACULTURE
PROGRAM REPORTS IN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW TO BE
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL PANEL OF
THE DAY. AFTER THIS PANEL WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU WE WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT
THERE IS A TOLL FREE NUMBER
THAT WE'RE GONNA INVITE YOU TO
CALL INTO HERE TODAY. THAT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AGAIN
AFTER THIS UPCOMING PANEL
FOCUSING ON STRATEGIES TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THRIVING
WE'RE GOING TO INVITE YOU TO
CALL OUR TOLL FREE NUMBER WE
WELCOME YOUR PARTICIPATION
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE EIGHT SIX FOUR AND
JUST DIAL US UP RIGHT THERE ON
THE NUMBER ON THE SCREEN WE
LOOK FOR TO TALKING WITH YOU
HERE IN JUST A BIT ALRIGHT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'VE
SAVED THE BEST FOR LAST WE ARE-
IT CAN BE WITH OUR FINAL PANEL
OF THE DAY. AND IT'S GOING TO
UPDATE US ON THE- COMMITTEE ON
STRATEGIES TO REALLY KEEP
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES DRIVING IF
I COULD BE CANDID. WE NEED A
THRIVING FISHERY WHETHER IT'S
SALMON ROCKFISH SQUID CRAB
SPINY LOBSTER OYSTER I HAD TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP SO MANY IN
PARTICULAR RURAL COMMUNITIES
THRIVING IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE OF THE
STATE IN THE FUTURE OF RURAL.
COASTAL CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE
COMPILED OF WONDER. ALL STAR
PAIN. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
CONVERSATION STRATEGIES TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THRIVING WE
KNOW IF SALMON CAN THRIVE IN
THIS STATE. COASTAL COMMUNITIES
WILL THRIVE. DOING THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
BENEFITS OUR ECONOMIC INTERESTS
AS WELL. SO LET'S GET THIS. ALL
STAR PANEL COULD DROP AND WHO
BETTER. TO START US OFF WITH-
THIS PANEL IS COREY RIGHT AND-
SHE IS DEFICIENT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR. OCEAN
CONSERVANCY. BUT SHE'S GOING TO
BE TALKING ABOUT. US AND I'M
TEACHING PRICE UPDATE ON STATE
AND FEDERAL INITIATIVES TO
ADDRESS. THE COMMUNITY IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN OUR
FISHERIES. HIS WRITINGS IT IS
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND-
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR. YOUR BRIEFING HERE
TODAY I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER CHAIR IN MR GRAY
CELL- MY NAME'S COREY WRITINGS
I WORK FOR OCEAN CONSERVANCY
I'M A CALIFORNIA NUMBER AT THE
PACIFIC FISHERY MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL. AND I'M A DOCTORAL
STUDENT IN THE LAB OF DR PHILIP
LEVIN AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON- TODAY MY
AFFILIATIONS ARE FOR
IDENTIFICATION PURPOSES ONLY
AND I AM SPEAKING INSURING IT
CAN. OPINIONS ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF ONLY. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU TODAY. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
HAVING MULTI FACETED IMPACTS ON
OUR OCEAN ECOSYSTEM OUR FISH
POPULATIONS. ARE FISHING IN
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. THERE IS
NO SINGLE SOLUTION TO PREPARE A
FISHERIES DATA COMPLEX NATURE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AND HOW WE
ARE SEEN IT IMPACTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN MULTIPLE
OVERLAPPING WAYS. BUT THERE ARE
SOME ACTIONS WE CAN AKE THAT
WILL SUPPORT A HEALTHY OCEAN
AND FISHING COMMUNITIES.
FIRSTLY AND FOREMOST WE MUST
RECOMMIT TO SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT. PORTENTS OF THE
RAIN LIKE MANAGEMENT ACT AND
NATIONAL LAW MANDATES THAT WE
USE THE BEST SCIENTIFIC
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AND THAT
WE DON'T OVER FISH. KEEPING FOR
STARTS HEALTHY IS CENTRAL TO
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE. NO
OTHER MANAGEMENT OR
CONSERVATION APPROACHES OR
TOOLS OR SHINY PRETTY TECH
SOLUTION WILL SUSTAIN A HEALTHY
OCEAN AND COASTAL COMMUNITIES
IF WE DON'T HAVE HEALTHY FISH
STOCKS. WE CAN'T HACK OUR WAY
OUT OF OVERFISHED STOCKS AND WE
CAN'T A. I. R. FISHING
COMMUNITIES KNOCK ONS ARE GONE.
TO THAT END WE NEED TIMELY
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE DATA THAT
IS INTEGRATED INTO AND USED
APPROPRIATELY IN MANAGEMENT. AS
A COUNCIL MEMBER I SEE THE
DIRECT IMPACT OF MANAGEMENT
THAT LACKS THE NEEDED DATA. AND
AS MR CLASS EARLIER WE LIVE AND
DIE BY THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE. TO BE CLEAR I'M NOT
SEEING THE MOUNTAINS MORE OF
DATA WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE ALTERING OR
OCEAN FISHERIES WE NEED TO BE
MORE STRATEGIC AND SCIENTIFIC.
ABOUT WHAT DATA WE'RE
COLLECTING AND HOW WE DO IT.
FOR EXAMPLE FISH YOUR BONES
WHICH ARE CRITICAL FOR
UNDERSTANDING FISH POPULATION
LEVELS. CURRENTLY WE RELY
HEAVILY ON VOLUNTARILY
COLLECTIONS CARCASS SAMPLING
FINE FISH AND OTHER
OPPORTUNISTIC COLLECTION. IT
CAN MARKET SHORT TERM FIXES A
COLLECTION PROGRAMS FOR
BIOLOGICAL INFORMATION LIKE
YOUR BONES NEED TO BE DESIGNED
BASED STRATIFIED AND
SCIENTIFICALLY RANDOM TO
PROVIDE THE DATA WE NEED FOR
ROBUST STOCK ASSESSMENT AND
MANAGEMENT. IT'S ALSO ESSENTIAL
THAT WE BREAK DOWN ANY
REMAINING BARRIERS THE DATA
FLOWING FROM BRUSSELS TO
MANAGERS. ESTABLISH HER CAR WAS
CONTROL RULES THAT APPLY THESE
DATA TO ENSURE THAT MANAGEMENT
TARGETS ARE MET ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. TO GET THERE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE NEEDS THE
RESOURCES AND THE CAPACITY TO
DO THEIR WORK AS PART OF THAT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN GREAT PEOPLE. AS WE
NOW KNOW FROM THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGET PROCESS AT THE
LEGISLATURE INITIATED THROUGH
MULTIPLE BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT
EMBRACED. THE DEPARTMENT
REMAINS UNDERFUNDED ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND IN PARTICULAR FOR
SPECIES AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION AND PUBLIC USE AND
ENJOYMENT. WITH SERVICE LEVELS
AND A THIRD OR LESS OF WHAT
WOULD BE NEEDED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MEET ITS MISSION.
THIS YEAR'S STATE BUDGET MADE
IMPORTANT NEW SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE NOT FEDERAL
MANDATES FOR SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT. SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
TARGETED INVESTMENT WILL BE
NEEDED. IT IS ALSO IMPERATIVE
THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUED TO
DEDICATE ITS LIMITED STAFF
RESOURCES TO ENGAGE IN FEDERAL
FISHERY MANAGEMENT FORMSSUCH
AS THE COUNCIL. IS THROUGH THE
COUNCIL AND OTHER REGIONAL
EFFORTS AND WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR FEDERAL AND
WEST COAST PARTNERS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR FISHERIES AND
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE ON THE
ECOSYSTEM LEVELS. FISH WHALES
AND SEABIRDS DON'T RECOGNIZE
STATE BOUNDARIES AND WE SHOULD
CONTINUALLY MOVING TOWARDS THE
SAME ECOSYSTEM BASED MANAGEMENT
APPROACH REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA
LAW UNDER FISHING GAME CODE
SECTION SEVEN OF THREE POINT
THREE. WE ALSO NEED TO ENGAGE
MORE INTENTIONALLY TO ENSURE
JUSTICE AND EQUITY AND
FISHERIES AND FISHERIES
DECISION MAKING. SUCH
ENGAGEMENT IS A NECESSARY STEP
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
REPRESENTING THE VALUES OF OUR
STATE AND SHIPPING LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR OCEAN AND
FISHERY. STATE MANAGEMENT MOST
OF ALL IF YOU ARE FISHERIES OF
THE COMPLEX AND DYNAMIC HUMAN
SYSTEMS THEY ARE. FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE MORE LATINO ASIAN
AMERICAN AND BLACK FISHERMAN
THAN EVER BEFORE HOWEVER MANY
OF THE STAPLES ARE NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO DECISION MAKING
POWER. WHERE HOW AND WHEN WILL
THEIR VOICES BE HEARD. HOW DO
WE HAVE ALSO THAT OPPORTUNITIES
IN FISHERIES AND FISHERIES
DECISION MAKING ARE OPEN TO
EVERYONE. A NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY HAS SIGNALED THEY WANT
TO START THIS DIALOGUE. WE ARE
ONLY THE BEGINNING OF THIS
IMPORTANT URGENT EFFORT AND
HE'S MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
MUST BE INVITED PARTICIPANTS.
RELATEDLY WE MUST THINK DEEPLY
ABOUT OUR COASTAL FISHING
CITIES AND TOWNS AND WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE. FISHERIES
INFRASTRUCTURES LING LING.
HOURS CONSULTING ACROSS THE
INDUSTRY IT'S TOO FEW HANDS.
BECAUSE OUR GENTRIFYING. AND
ALL THESE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
ISSUES ARE HAPPENING IN
ENVIRONMENT BUT THE CLIMATE IS
CHANGING POLLUTION CONTINUES.
IN OUR RIVERS AND STREAMS ARE
RUNNING DRY. AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY SALMON OFFICIAL CENTRAL
TO THE IDENTITIES OF MANY OF
OUR SMALL SCALE FISHING
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBES ALONG
OUR COAST RIVERS. MAY BECOME
EXTINCT FROM CALIFORNIA WATERS
ON OUR WATCH. THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT GO BEYOND FISHERY
MANAGEMENT AND HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SELL US AND WE
NEED A NEW WAY OF THINKING AND
NEW TOOLS THAT MANAGERS MUST
USED RIGHT ON A FINE USE. THE
COASTAL ACT PROVIDES A GOOD
STRUCTURE TO HELP PROTECT THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO COASTAL
SPACE AND WE NEED TO BUILD ON
THIS GOOD ETHOS REFLECT ON
PATTERNS OF RESOURCE USE. AND
NATURALLY HAVE INCLUSIVE
STREETS ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS.
IF YOU'RE- I MENTIONED EARLIER
THE NEED TO IMPROVE HOW WE
COLLECT BIOLOGICAL DATA. THE
SAME HOLDS TRUE FOR SOCIAL DATA.
THIS IS A STEP WE CAN TAKE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE SOCIAL
FABRIC OF OUR FISHERIES AND
HELP GUIDE US TOWARDS A MORE
JUST AND SUSTAINABLE AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I'M
DEEPLY HONORED TO HAVE SPOKEN
AT THE- GREATER FISHERIES
FORUM. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH HOW FAR ALONG ARE YOU IN
YOUR DOCTORAL PROGRAM. I JUST
STARTED IT SO  AM FRESH OUT
IT'S STILL VERY EXCITED HELLO
MY GOSH. THERE WE GO THAT IS SO
EXCITING THOUGH WE ARE THRILLED
FOR YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU AND THERE'S JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF WORK AHEAD YOU
KNOW I MEAN OH MY GOODNESS.
YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO BE ON HIS WRITINGS IS
GOING TO BE. HOLDING WITH US
HERE AND I SHOULD BE READY FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN JUST A
BIT. AT LEAST IN GENERAL NOW
GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
ROGER HE LEE. AND I GOTTA SAY
MR HEALY AND ALL THE COMMERCIAL
LOBSTER FISHERMEN. DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THEY HAVE
HAD A HELL OF A SEASON WITH
THIS DEVASTATING OIL SPILL. HI
MISTER GILLIES CAN UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE ON THE IMPACTS OF THE
OIL SPILL- IT TO HIS FISHING
COMMUNITY. AND TALK ABOUT HOW
THE REGULATORY PROCESS IS
IMPACTED COMMERCIAL FISHING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. MR HE
LEAVES THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TUNING THE COMMITTEE. WE'RE
CHECKING IN TO SEE IF WE HAVE
A- MR HEALY WHO IS ON THE LINE.
JUST GIVE US ONE SECOND. BUT
NOW ALL RIGHT THAT SOUNDS LIKE
WE GOT TO MISTER HEALY YEAH
SURE IS IT I'M NOT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL WIZARD ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I DON'T HAVE A
VIDEO HOOKED UP UNFORTUNATELY
GOING TO MISS MY MIKE I
ATTACHED MY PARTNER MIKE
IT'S RACE I. DOZENS OF YOU GET
INVOLVED BUT DO NOT- ALL. RIGHT
APPRECIATE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO YOU GUYS. AND I WASN'T SURE
WHAT MY THOUGHTS ARE AND I HOPE
I DON'T OFFEND ANYBODY AND BY
SPEAKING MY MIND BUT- IT'S HARD
TO GIVE A CULMINATION OF THIRTY
FOUR YEARS OF COMMERCIAL
FISHING AND JUST. FIVE MINUTES
BUT- I GET AROUND ABOUT MOVIE
GOING THERE WILL STILL BE VERY
ENDED TWENTY YEARS OF MY CAREER
OFFICE VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING OUT
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY OR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST AREA
LOBSTERS CRABS UP. RECENTLY
BEEN WORKING EXPERIMENT BOSCO
FISHERY URCHINS NEAR SHORE.
MARINE CORPS AND COLLECTED
BEFORE THE REGULATIONS CHECK
OUT THE VIABILITY OF THAT
INDUSTRY- I'VE BEEN TWENTY
YEARS I'VE BEEN POLITICALLY
ACTIVE ON THE PRESENT STATE BY
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA STATE
WHY SO SHE'S A LOBSTER
FISHERMEN ARE REPRESENTED IN A
COKE COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. AND THOSE TWENTY
YEARS LAWS CHANGED. YOU KNOW IT
TWENTY YEARS AGO THIS IS PRETTY
EASY TO MEET WITH THE
COMMISSION AND AN- UPDATE OR
AMEND ANY CODES OF DRESS THE
RESOURCE ISSUES OR ANYTHING
THAT NEED TO BE CHANGED. AS
TIME HAS GONE ON THE DAY OF THE
COMMISSION. WOULD EASILY. WORK
THINGS OUT BACK TODAY. IT
ALBERTA THE PAID LOBBYISTS AND
SPECIALIST CHRIS THE POWER TO
BE MADE A LOT MORE. FOR US. IS
TO LEAVE OUR OUR WATERS TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND EVERY SINGLE
BEAT AND IT WAS. NEEDED FOR US
TO BE THERE. YOU'LL GET LOST.
IN THE PLACE. THAT ACTUALLY
REPRESENT OUR INTERESTS WERE. I
THOUGHT IT WAS TIME WHEN I WAS
A POLITICAL LEADER THAT I WAS
NO LONGER ACTUALLY DOING THINGS
PRAGMATICALLY ANYMORE BUT I WAS
MORE OF A REACTIONARY FIGURE
TRYING TO JUST. STAVE OFF. THE
INEVITABLE MOSKOW MORE AREA
FISHING REGULATIONS AMASSING ON
TALKING BUST AND LACK OF
ABILITY TO ACCESS THE RESOURCES-
IT IT I'LL GIVE YOU A QUICK
EXAMPLE DOES THE LOBSTER
FISHERY MANAGEMENT PLAN WHICH
WAS PUT INTO PLACE A FEW YEARS
BACK I WAS ONE OF THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT REPRESENTED
THE- GROUP ONE OF THE- LEADERS
THAT REPRESENT A COMMERCIAL
FISHING PART OF IT. WE SPENT
TWO YEARS IN MEETINGS WE HAD A
CHARTER IS VERY SPECIFIC THAT
WE OUT OF. ALL COMPLETELY AGREE
OR AT LEAST COME TO A
CONSENSUS. IN THE VERY END OF
IT WE ALWAYS END UP WITH IS A
LOT MORE REGULATIONS FOR THE
COMMERCIAL BASICALLY. AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY DID NOTHING FOR THE
SPORT FISHING LAKE WHICH THE
ONLY REASON I WAS REALLY THERE
IS LESS CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
COMMERCIALIZATION OF THE SPORT
FISHING FLEET INTO. THEIR
ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE
HARVESTED. PRETTY MUCH
UNLIMITED CAPACITY SO LIMITED
DAYS SEVEN LOSSES TODAY THE
GUYS ALREADY INQUIRE INTO WORDS
THAT THE WORDS ARE HARVESTED.
SPORT FISHING. WISE UNDER LEGAL
OFFICERS THIS SEASON. WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN YEAR BUT I
BELIEVE THE M. L. APRIL. AND
TO. SO THIS FINANCE. COMMERCIAL
GROUPS AND NOW THEY HAVE MADE
CAREERS OUT OF. GAMBLING IN
CALIFORNIA'S BAY STREETS.
ADDING NEW BILLS TO FURTHER
SQUEEZE COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN
OUT OF BUSINESS. SUSPECTS AS
THE ROPELESS GEAR DECIDED
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW AMBITION
LIST. PARDON YOU KNOW
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES THEY'RE NOT
EVEN PRACTICAL REALISTIC AND IT
BUT SUCH ONEROUS. REGULATIONS
HONESTLY IT IT BASICALLY TAKES
UP THE PROFITABILITY OF THE
OFFICIAL. ON THE OTHER HAND ALL
DAY PROCESS AND THE RESULTING
RE PROTECTED AREAS BUT PLACED
COMPLETELY NEUTERED THE ORANGE
COUNTY FISHERIES ARE COMMERCIAL
FISHING FLEET. I BELIEVE OR
ABOUT LESS THAN HALF THE SIZE
WE WERE AT ONE TIME. THEN WE'VE
BEEN NEGATED DOWN TO JUST BE
ABLE TO FISH BASICALLY ONE
SPECIES WHICH IS LOBSTER I BEST
I DO HAVE AN URGENT PERMIT IF
THEY WANT TO HAVE A JOB BIBLE
FOR URGE YOU STICKERS LEFT OPEN
TO ASSIST. IS MARGINAL AT BEST
SUITS STILL WHERE WE USED TO BE
A HARVEST LOT OF A LOT OF IT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
COASTLINE FROM NEWPORT
STANDPOINT THE LEADING REALLY
ALLOWED TO TAKE HIS OFFICERS
THAT'S THE ONLY VIABLE
COMMODITY TO ASSUME. MANAGERS
IN OUR AREA WE HAVE A NEW
MARINE MANAGER YOU CAN START
MARINA MANAGER YET THE ALL THE
SIZE OF OUR FLEET IS DIMINISHED
SO MUCH THAT THAT LOOK THIS IS
ACTUALLY USED TO BE THIS SERIES
ANYMORE DID. YOU THINK OF A
SIMPLE ANSWER HOBBYIST. MATT
AND HAS. BAD BECAUSE- FOR US.
THEY DON'T. A DEGREE OF. AT
HELP OUT OR US ANY- THING AND
WORK YOU STILL YOU THAT THE
PROBLEM OUR COME FISHING. YOU
KNOW THAT RELIES ON ONE
RESOURCE MAKES US VERY
VULNERABLE TO MARKET TRENDS
RESOURCE ALTERNATIVE AND
NATURAL AND MAN MADE DISASTERS
SUCH AS THIS OIL SPILL. I DON'T
KNOW HOW WELL A COMPANY CAN
MEANS UNCONSCIONABLE FOR ME TO
HELP AN OLD COMPANY WORKING IN
ST LOUIS SLABS I GUESS WORK
BETTER LANCE. IT'S VIRTUALLY
INSOLVENT AND DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO EASILY WE DON'T
KNOW YET THEY'RE NOT TO PAY
OFF. THE DEBT TO GET THIS DONE
SO ARE YOUR LOCAL FISHERMEN.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS LONG
ENOUGH THAT I PROBABLY WILL
SURVIVE THIS BUT I'VE GOT
SEVERAL GUYS THAT REPRESENT.
NIGHT YOU'LL GET CHOKED UP. THE
PRODUCTS ARE THIS THEY ARE
CAUGHT. SOME I THIS AS RELIEF
FOR FIRE FLOODS AND OTHER. OR
BANDAGES. AND IT WHAT ALL THOSE
GOOD PRICE DO A SETTLEMENT
REALLY QUICKLY WITH THE WELL%
COMPANY BUT WHAT'S REALLY
QUICKLY TWO YEARS. WHAT ARE
FISHERMEN JOSH HERNANDEZ ON
ABLE BODIED. IS THIS IS THIRD
YEAR FISHING AND HE'S GOT A TWO
YEAR OLD A BABY COMING AND HE'S
GOTEVERYTHING INTO THIS YOU
GOT CREDIT CARD DEBT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE A DIFFERENCE. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF HE WILL BE AROUND
IN YEARS TO COME THINGS AREN'T.
RECTIFIED SOON ALLOWED HIM TO
GO FISH AND ALL THE REST OF US.
I DIDN'T WANT TO SELL TO GET
DISGRUNTLED FISHERMEN. IT ALL I
HAD A FEW MORE THINGS. WILL
SPILL RESPONSE IS PRETTY
MASSIVE THERE'S A LOT OF
PLAYERS IN IT DOCTOR SOON
ENOUGH SURE IS LISTENING ON THE
LINE HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN
TRYING TO GET TO MEDICATIONS UP
TO US BUT IT'S BEEN AN ONGOING
NOT LIVING AGAINST THE POWERS
TO BE A BIT. WITH ALL POWERS
THEY'RE WORKING IN THIS IN THIS
AREA RIGHT NOW IT'S AMAZING
I'VE LEARNED MORE FROM.
DIRECTOR BONNIE TODAY THAN I'VE
LEARNED IN THE LAST MONTH. I
THOUGHT YOU'RE GONNA BE OPEN
AROUND. YEAH NOVEMBER FIRST
ONLY LEARN I CAN A LOT OF LIKE
TO LOVE THIS. FOR THEM TO DO
TESTING ON I JUST LEARNING AS
OF LAST NIGHT IT'S GOING TO BE
DECEMBER FIRST NOW. WHEN YOU
HAVE THE BLOOD DROPS THE WATER
IN YOUR SITTING TIED TO THE
DOCK AND YOU'RE WAITING TO BURN
YOUR FIRST DOLLAR FOR THE YEAR
IT'S PRETTY. DIFFICULT I MEAN
FOR ME PERSONALLY I'M TRYING TO
GET INFORMATION ALL THE
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK AROUND THIS AND ARE
TRYING TO ALSO LIVE. OFF THE
OCEAN LOCALLY. AND THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF ANSWERS AND THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF DIRECTION AND-
SHUTTING DOWN THE HARBOR. DR I
JUST NEED TO ATTRACT FORTY FEET
OF WATER TO TEN FEET OF WATER.
WHAT. DID NOT ZERO NOTIFICATION.
IT SCARED ME TO DEATH BECAUSE
YOU LOSE ALL MY TRAPS MR STILL
WITHOUT GETTING TOO VERBOSE
THOSE ARE BASICALLY. SOME OF
THE THINGS I'M DEALING WITH. AS
THE MORE REGULATIONS COMING TO
PLACE THEM IN. YOUR CITY
COMMERCIAL BASEMENT THE TABLE
VERY OFTEN BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
SUCH LONG PROCESSES THAT MEET
WITH ARCADE INDIVIDUALS TO BE
THEIR- VOLUNTEER. AT AN
UNFORTUNATE WE CAN'T BE AT
EVERY MEETING IN YOUR- YOU. I
SO APPRECIATE IT TO YOU GUYS
AFTER LISTEN THIS ALL DAY
ACTUALLY LISTEN TO US AND BEING
THERE. AND BEEN FIGHTING ON OUR
BEHALF AND- ALL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR A QUESTION IF YOU HAVE
AFTER THIS. RELATED WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU MISS HEALY'S LOBSTER
FISHERMEN FROM GENCO- AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL
WE ARE. FOR YOU TO BE AT OR
PROVIDE THIS VERY PERSONAL
TESTIMONY ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF
LOBSTER FISHERMEN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE IMPACT OF THE
OIL SPILL IN WHY THE STAKES ARE
SO HIGH. IN THE EXAMPLE YOU
JUST GAVE UP THE GENTLEMAN WHO
HAS A TWO YEAR OLD AT HOME
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
RENT OR MORTGAGE AND CAR
PAYMENTS AND- NOT NOT ABLE TO
FISH TO BE ABLE TO BRING IN THE
DOLLARS. WE ARE SO APPRECIATIVE
YOU BRING THAT FORWARD IN. I
PROMISE IT WILL BE FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOU SIR- AND- KEEPING
TRACK OF. THE COMPENSATION IS
GOING TO BE NEEDED. ON SO MANY
LEVELS AND IN PARTICULAR FOR
THE FLEET TO MR HEALY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE A TURNING IT
BACK OVER TO MIKE CONROY. AS
YOU REMEMBER MR CONROY- IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST. FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION. MIKE
IS BACK WITH US TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN SUPPORT FISHING
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
COAST. IMAGE GALLERY A PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT-
YOU KNOW SO MUCH OF THIS IS IN
REGARDS TO INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE NEED FOR. INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. SO THAT WHEN- WE DO
HAVE A THRIVING PORT. THAT WE
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE THERE
HAD TO BE ABLE TO KEEP IT
MOVING FOR THE ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD. AND SO MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. THAT PCS OKAY
REPRESENTS AS FAR AS- DIFFERENT
PORT ASSOCIATIONS THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO. KEEP THIS INDUSTRY
MOVING BECAUSE THERE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE THAT KEEPS
THE FLEET GOING. LIKE I DON'T
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR
YOUR- FULL BRIEFING FIVE
MINUTES SIR. YEAH AGAIN SENATOR
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT INTEREST.
PLAYS A CRITICAL COMPONENT TO
THIS OUR FISHING COMMUNITIES
BUT I'LL TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT. BY WAY OF INTRODUCTION MY
NAME IS MIKE CONROY AND UNLESS
MY BOARD IS THAT A CHANGE OF
HEART SINCE THE DECRYPT HELL
I'MSTILL THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR PC FFA. WHEN THE IDEA
THE FISHERIES FORUM WAS
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED IN THE
LIST OF TOPICS TO BE DISCUSSED
COVERED I LEAPT AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PANEL LET THE COMMUNITY
SPELL AS I UNDERSTOOD IT WAS
TASKED WITH ADDRESSING ACCESS
PERMITTING SPACE. BUT FAR TOO
OFTEN WE GET WRAPPED AROUND THE
AXLE ON FISHERY SPECIFIC
ISSUES. AS EVIDENCED BY PRIOR
PANELS AND LOSE SIGHT OF THE
IMPORTANT BIGGER PICTURE ITEMS
SUCH AS ACCESS PERMITTING IN
SPACE. IN COVERING THESE TOPICS
IT WAS SUGGESTED WE HIGHLIGHT
THE GOOD AND THE BAD AND
PROVIDE SPECIFIC POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. WHAT YOU'LL
HEAR THAT BUT I WILL CONCLUDE
WITH THE UGLY. PERMITTING
PERMITTING SOME GOOD YEAR YOUR
SP EIGHTIES PROVISIONS. EASY
TRANSFERABILITY OF DUNGENESS
CRAB PERMITS ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
BASS PERMITS REMAIN
INACCESSIBLE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN AND WOMEN. DUE TO
AVAILABILITY AND WHEN AVAILABLE
AND WHEN AVAILABLE IN SOME
CASES COST. WAITING PERMITS
APARTMENTS BEING HELD BY
SPECULATORS RATHER SEE PERMIT
HOLDERS THERE'S ALSO A BAD
THING. A SPECIFIC POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS CONSIDER MAKING
COMMERCIAL FISHING PERMITS
REASONABLE. I CONSIDER
COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP APARTMENTS
WITH AN ABILITY FOR THOSE
PERMITS TO BE LEASED TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS I THINK
THEY'RE FROM SHERRY. FROM THE
MY BASS FISHERIES TRUST NEXT
AND THEY HAVE A THEY CAN BE
USED AS A MODEL FOR THAT.
CONSIDER ACTIVITY REQUIREMENT
WITH EXCEPTIONS TO AVOID PERMIT
SPECULATING IN LAYTON PERMITS
DEPRIVING CALIFORNIANS OF
SEAFOOD. CONSIDER
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND M.
C. GRETA SAN DIEGO'S DOING
SOMETHING WITH THAT WITH THE
LOCAL FISHERMEN DOWN THERE.
THAT CONSIDER LOTTERIES FOR
AVOID NON RENEWED OR REVOKED
PERMITS LIMITED TO THOSE. WITH
A HISTORY OF THAT SPECIFIC
TREASURY. MOVING ON JACK. AS
YOU KNOW SIX. MEANWHILE ALONG
THOSE. FISHERMEN NEED ACCESS.
THE GOOD IN UNDER ACCESS
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN
AND WOMEN ROSE TO THE OCCASION
AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO HEALTHY
AND SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF
PROTEIN DURING THE PAST TEN-
LIBERATION OF DIRECT MARKETING
IN BOTH THE DOOR DELIVERIES A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE TO
BE AVAILABLE IN BEEF POULTRY
AND PORK SUPPLY CHAINS. WERE
DISRUPTED BY COVERT. DURING
COPE WITH THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN GRACIOUS MAKING TIME TO
SPEAK PLEASE STAND IN DEEP
CRAB. FISHERMEN IMPACTED BY THE
RECENT OIL SPILL IN PARTICULAR.
BUT ALSO THE LARGER COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRY REGARDING BOTH ROUNDS
OF THE CHAIRS ACCESSORIES
SYSTEMS. PERMITS RENT TO THE
COUNCIL ALSO DESERVE KUDOS FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
WITH INDUSTRY. BUT FOR THEIR
EFFORTS MANY ACTIONS BENEFICIAL
TO OUR MEMBERS AND INDUSTRY AS
A WHOLE FOR EXAMPLE INCREASED
ACCESS TO MONTREAL OR C. IS
WHICH IS ONGOING FAVORABLE
SANTA SEASON FEDERALLY APPEARS
TO CAPTURE NURSE FOR DATA FOR
CPS STOCKS. WOULD LIKELY STILL
BE CONCEPTUAL. THE BAD IN TERMS
OF ACCESS WHAT MY MEMBERS
OFFERED A FEW COMMON
OBSERVATIONS HERE THE FISHING
INDUSTRY BELIEVES IT IS UNDER
REPRESENTED UNDER HER LARGELY
IGNORED AND UNDER APPRECIATED.
THE GOVERNOR'S. EXECUTIVE ORDER
REGARDING THIRTY BY THIRTY WAS
EXECUTED OVER A YEAR AGO AND
DESPITE BEING PROMISED A SEAT
AT THAT TABLE WE ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR THE TABLE. TO HEAR
MR GOLD SAY THE PATHWAY
DOCUMENT IS DUE OUT SOON
WITHOUT ANY INPUT FROM THE
FISHING INDUSTRY. EVIDENCE IS
DESTROYED. STATE AGENCIES AND
APPOINTEES WITH LITTLE TO NO
FISHING KNOWLEDGE ARE PROPOSING
AN ACTING ACTIONS RULES AND
REGULATIONS. WHICH COULD HAVE
PROFOUND IMPACTS ON OUR ABILITY
TO OPERATE. THERE ARE OHER
EFFORTS WHICH POTENTIALLY
ELIMINATE OUR ABILITY TO ACCESS
PRODUCTIVE FISHING AREAS.
OFFSHORE WIND IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THREATS TO OUR
LIVELIHOODS CALL AREAS RIGHT
DOWN TO FIGHT OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WITH LITTLE TO NO
THOUGHT GIVEN TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF USERS TO THE FISHING
INDUSTRY. THE LACK OF
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
FISHING COMMUNITY CONTINUES
THERE ARE NOTABLE EXCEPTIONS
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION WITH
THE VANDERBURGH PROJECTS. IN
RECENT CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD SEEM TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSITION.
EARRINGS ARE REPEATED
COMPLAINTS REGARDING ENGAGEMENT.
MANY QUESTIONS WE HAVE ASKED
FOUNDATIONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOLOGICAL
IMPACTS OF OFFSHORE WIND
REMAINED UNANSWERED NEWS
STORIES ABOUT FAILURES ISSUES
AND I'M NOT GONNA FIGHT
CONSEQUENCES OFFSHORE WIND UP
BECOMING MORE AND MORE
COMMONPLACE JUST LAST WEEK WE
LEARNED OF A FIRE INVOLVING
OFFSHORE WIND FARMS OFF THE
NETHERLANDS ONE OF THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE FIRES
REPORTED INVOLVING OFFSHORE
WIND OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS. OUR MARINE ECOSYSTEM IS
TOO IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE TO
ALLOW INDUSTRIALIZATION WITHOUT
FULLY UNDERSTANDING THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS BOTH POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE. KNOWLEDGE
PROVISIONS OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE IT HOPE IT ENDS UP
BEING MORE THAN WORDS ON THE
PAGE WITH REGARD TO AQUACULTURE
WEEKLY IT KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
ARE. DIFFERENT FORMS AND TYPE
OF AQUACULTURE. MAIN CONCERN
ABOUT- OPEN WATER AND FISH SELL
THESE INTRA OF LOSS OF FISHING.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
SURROUNDING THE OPERATIONS. AND
AS WE HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER FROM
BOTH GEORGE JOHN AND- THE
PLIGHT OF THE STATE'S SALMON
FISHERIES. I WILL NOTE THAT
RECENT STUDIES HAVE POSTULATED
THAT COVERING CALIFORNIA'S
AQUEDUCTS AND SOLAR PANELS. TO
GENERATE EIGHT GIGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY WELL SAVING
MILLIONS OF GALLONS OF WATER
FROM EVAPORATION WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE LOOKING AT THAT. IN
TERMS OF POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
WITH THIS REGARD YOU'RE SURE
THAT THE FISHING INDUSTRY BOTH
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL HAD
MEANINGFUL ROLES AN ACTIVE
VOICE IN CONVERSATIONS. RELATED
TO ACTIVITIES THAT INITIAL
RESISTANCE RESTRICT. OUR ACCESS
FOR EXAMPLE THIRTY. AFTER
WINNING. AN AWFUL. CONSIDER
REQUIRING FISHING EXPERIENCE
AND BACKGROUND FOR APPOINTEES
TO THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
AS MEMBERS. THE COMMITTEE NOW
OUR FISHERIES ARE NUANCED AND
MANAGEMENT OF THOSE REQUIRED OF
THOSE REQUIRE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE AND HOW THESE
FISHERIES OPERATE THERE IS A
GROWING CONCERN THAT THE
COMMISSION DOESN'T HAVE THAT
NECESSARY EXPERTISE. THERE IS
WANT TO WRAP UP BY TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE UGLIER WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT ME THAT THERE
IS A VERY REAL FEAR THAT ABSENT
SUPPORT THERE MAY BE NO
COMMERCIAL FISHING IN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS EVERY YEAR WE ARE ASKED
TO GET MORE CATCH LAST AND
CHANGE OUR OPERATING BUSINESS
MODELS. THE FISHERMEN JUST
TEXTED ME AND HIGHLIGHTED THE
INCREASED COST OF OPERATING
FROM INSURANCE TO FUEL TO
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT TREATMENT OF
CRUISE WE ASK THAT THE
EXEMPTION PROVIDED FOR THE
COMMERCIAL FISHING. INDUSTRY
UNDER EIGHTY FIVE BE EXTENDED.
COREY NOTED WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE SCIENCE TO GET
TOGETHER TO MAKE OUR FISHERIES
RESILIENT. TO CHANGING OCEAN
CONDITIONS. WE MUST ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE DEMOGRAPHICS THE
CURRENT STATE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH SUPPORTS FISHING
ACTIVITIES AND PORTS AND
HARBORS UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND ANALYZE WHETHER THESE
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO SERVE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SUPPORT.
I WAS GONNA I WAS GONNA LET
LEAVE ROGERS TESTIFYING AS HE
SAID I DON'T KNOW THAT I
COULDN'T STAND IT ANY BETTER.
WE MUST NOT FORGET THAT FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
THE ONLY ACCESS THEY HAVE TO
THE LIVING REEF RESOURCES ARE
STATE WATERS. IS THROUGH THE
SEAFOOD WE HARVEST FOR THEM.
ACTUALLY JUST RESTRICT OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTHY SOURCE OF PROTEIN.
OFTEN WITH A MUCH LOWER CARBON
FOOTPRINT VIS A VIS OTHER
SOURCES OF PROTEIN WILL OFTEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
VANISHED YEARS WE'RE GONNA NEED
A REFERENCE OF UNREALITY
RECOMMENDATION. CALIFORNIA'S
FISHERMEN AND WOMEN NEED A
CHAMPION WE ARE LOOKING TO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
RISE UP AND TAKE THAT ROLE FOR
US. TO THAT END WE SUGGEST
FINDING SUPPORT MANY THE IDEAS
AND SUGGESTIONS YOU HAVE HEARD
HERE TODAY. TALK TO US AND
LISTEN TO US WE ARE
APPROACHABLE MOST OF THE TIME.
WE ARE PEOPLE JUST LIKE YOU WE
HAVE FAMILIES JUST LIKE YOU WE
ARE DOING THE BEST WE CAN IN
VERY CHALLENGING TIMES IN
CONDITIONS THANK YOU WE MAKE
MISTAKES BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE
DEFINED BY THOSE MISTAKES.
THANKS NO THANK YOU SO MUCH HAS
GONE RIGHT WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
YOUR ADVOCACY AND OF COURSE
TCFA VERY VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
YOUR WORDS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AT LEAST IN GERMAN WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO GO TO SHERRY
FORMER FELLOW FORMER TELL
EXCUSE ME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MONTEREY BAY FISHERIES
TRUST. THIS FORMER FELT IS
JOINING US FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND WE ARE SO APPRECIATIVE OF
HER WORK AND THAT SHE IS HERE
TODAY WE HOPE THIS IS. NOT
NEARLY THE LAST AND THIS IS
GONNA BE A LONG STANDING
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE
MISSED WITH HIS FORMER FELT AS
WELL AS A MODERATE FISHERIES
TRUST. HE'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT
HER ORGANIZATION'S APPROACH TO
ENSURING. SUSTAINED ACCESS TO
SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES MADAM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND. PROMPT AS YOU GET CLOSE
TO THE END WELCOME. I YOU AND-
THANK FOR THE- TO SPEAK TODAY
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. YOU ARE
COMING IN AND CLEAR EXACTLY.
EXCELLENT MY NAME IS GEORGE
WONDERFUL TONIGHT THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MONTEREY BAY
FISHERIES TRUST. AND WE ARE NON
PROFIT THAT WORKS WITH
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN AND
SEAFOOD BUSINESSES. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND OTHERS TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN A HEALTHY OCEAN
ENVIRONMENT. AND A HEALTHY
LOCAL SEAFOOD ECONOMY. A
COMMERCIAL FISHING IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE CULTURE
AND ECONOMY OF MONTEREY BAY.
AND IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR FOOD
SECURITY AS THE PENTECOSTAL. WE
FEEL STRONGLY THAT OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO LOCAL SUSTAINABLY HARVESTED
SEAFOOD. AND SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
RELY ON SEAFOOD IMPORTED FROM
ACROSS THE WORLD OFTEN CAUGHT
UNSUSTAINABLY AND WITH
QUESTIONABLE LABOR PRACTICES.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY THAT
SHOULD BE THE CASE WE HAVE MANY
HEALTHY FISH STOCKS. ROBUST
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT A GROWING
LOCAL FOOD MOVEMENT AND
FISHERMEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
EAGER TO WORK. BUT AS ROGER AND
MIKE AND OTHERS HAVE DISCUSSED
BEFORE ME CALIFORNIA'S FISHING
INDUSTRY IS FACED WITH ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES AND OBSTACLES. AS A
FISHERMAN SAID TO ME THE OTHER
DAY IT FEELS LIKE A BUCKET FULL
OF HOLES THAT JUST KEEPS
BRINGING NEW LEAKS AND EVERY
TIME YOU PLUG ONE HOLE ANOTHER
HOLE OPENS UP. SO THIS PANEL IS
ABOUT HOW TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES AND COASTAL
COMMUNITIES THRIVING. SO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE IN PLACE IN ORDER
TO DO THAT. WE NEED HEALTHY
FISH STOCKS IN ECOSYSTEMS WHICH
DEPENDS ON EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT
AND STEWARDSHIP. AND THE
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION OF
FISHERY STAKEHOLDERS. FISHERMEN
NEED ACCESS TO FISHING RIGHTS
THAT ARE AFFORDABLE AND
AVAILABLE AND THEY ALSO NEED
ACCESS TO THEIR PRODUCTIVE
FISHING GROUNDS. THEY NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH ICE
MACHINES FUEL STORAGE IN A MIX
OF BUSINESS SENSE. AND THEY
NEED A DIVERSITY OF MARKETS IN
CHOICE. AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO HAVE A DIVERSITY OF
FISHERIES AND BOTH THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AND SUPPORT
LEVEL. A JUSTICE FISHERMEN DO
BETTER WHEN THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
APARTMENTS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE MOST RESILIENT FISHING
PORTS ARE THOSE THAT HAVE A MIX
OF FISHERIES INCLUDING HIGH
VOLUME LOW VOLUME DIFFERENT.
ISSUE STRUGGLING FISHERMEN CAN
LEAN ON OTHER FISHERIES AND
THIS MAINTAINS A CENTRAL
PROCESSING AND POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
MARKETS. AND FINALLY THE
FISHING INDUSTRY NEEDS A
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT WITH
GOVERNMENT MANAGERS CONSUMERS
COMMUNITY PARTNERS LENDERS AND
OTHER STOCKING. AT THE MONTEREY
BAY FISHERIES TRUST WE BELIEVE
WE NEED TO BE MOVING FORWARD ON
ALL OF THESE FRONTS TO
STRENGTHEN THE WHOLE SYSTEM AND
IN DOING SO WE CAN BUILD
RESILIENCE IN OUR FISHING
COMMUNITIES SO THAT THEY'RE
STRONGER AND BETTER ABLE TO
WEATHER FUTURE STORMS. AMONG
OUR PROGRAMS- WE STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AS A
COMMUNITY QUOTA FUNDS FOR THE
WEST COAST GROUNDFISH TRAWL
FISHERY. TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY'S FUTURE ACCESS TO
THIS HIGH VOLUME YEAR ROUND
FISHERY. THIS WAS INTENDED TO
PREVENT SOME OF THE EFFECTS OF
CONSOLIDATION IN THE CAPTURE
PROGRAM. SO WE HOLD QUOTA AND
PERMITS AND WE SOME TO
FISHERMEN AT AFFORDABLE RATES.
BUT THIS IS JUST FOR ONE
FISHERY. AND WE'RE STARTING TO
EXPLORE WHETHER. WHETHER
THERE'S A ROLE FOR GROUPS LIKE
OURS TO PLAY IN OTHER FISHERIES
TO HELP ADDRESS ISSUES OF
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY. THERE
ARE MANY SMALL SCALE FISHERMEN
AND FISHING BUSINESSES THAT ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED. AND DON'T
HAVE THE BACKING AND RESOURCES
THAT LARGER DISTANCES YOU. SO
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE SUPPORTED AND THEY THEY
HAVE THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED.
TO WORK WORKING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FISHERMEN TO STAY
INFORMED AND INVOLVED IN THE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
WHEN DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE
THAT IMPACT THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE BUSINESS
SUPPORT SUCH AS HELPING
FISHERMEN NAVIGATE COVERT
RELIEF OPPORTUNITIES SECURE
LOANS. OR HELP THEM FIGURE OUT
THE PERMITS REQUIRED TO SELL
OFF THE BOAT. OUR ORGANIZATION
IS ALSO WORKING TO SUPPORT THE
EXISTING STEWARDSHIP OF LOCAL
FISHERMEN THROW LOST YOUR
RECOVERY PROJECT THAT WE
OPERATE OUT OF MONTEREY MOSS
LANDING AT SANTA CRUZ. AND YOUR
CV DONATION PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
HELPING THE STUDENTS SECURE IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHILE FILLING
MARKET FLOYD'S FOR THE FISHING
INDUSTRY DURING THE PANDEMIC. A
BIG PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS TO CREATE A MORE
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
FISHING COMMUNITIES WHICH
INVOLVES RAISING CONSUMER
AWARENESS ABOUT LOCAL SEAFOOD.
AND BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN FISHERMEN AND
GOVERNMENT CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND OTHERS. MUCH OF OUR WORK IS
GUIDED BY THE PRINCIPLES OF
INCLUSIVITY AND COLLABORATION
WE ALL NEED TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER THE REGULATORS
MANAGERS NGOS MARKETS
PROCESSORS AND THE FISHERMEN.
WHO ALSO NEED TO BE WORKING
WITH EACH OTHER ACROSS YOUR
TYPES TO LIST THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY. AS THE SAYING GOES A
RISING TIDE LIFTS ALL BOATS.
RECENT STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT
COMMERCIAL FISHING COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY REBUILT
AFTER DECLINE ARE THOSE WITH
STRONG SOCIAL CAPITAL IN TERMS
OF COOPERATION TRUST LEADERSHIP
AND THE SUPPORT OF EXTERNAL
ORGANIZATIONS. TOGETHER WE ALL
NEED TO INCREASE THAT SUPPORT
AND STRENGTHEN THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND HOPEFULLY
CREATE RESILIENCY FOR OUR
FISHING COMMUNITIES MOVING
FORWARD. AND OUR STATE LEADERS
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN ALL OF
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
MADAM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I'M
GONNA COME STRAIGHT TO YOU ON
QUESTIONS TO LOOK YOU HAVE ONE
FISHERY FOCUSED IN ON- AND
LOOKING TO EXPAND SO TALK TO US
ABOUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN
REGARDS TO EXPANDING NUMBER
ONE. AND THEN NUMBER TWO ARE
YOU THINKING OF JUST ABOUT
EXPANDING WITHIN THE GREATER-
MONTEREY BAY AREA OR LOOKING
EXPANDING ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU MAY BE ON
TO SOMETHING IN REGARDS TO
POTENTIAL ROOT REPLICATING IT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO HIS FORMER FOE.
WELL I'D SAY LOOKING TO. IS
EVEN COMMIT YOUR WORK WORKS
LAWRENCE NO OCEANSIDE STRESSES
LOOKING UP BLACK'S ABILITY
PERMITTING SYSTEMS AND- YOU
KNOW A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN FOR AN
ORGANIZATION TO HOLD FISHING
RIGHTS FOR. FOR THE LOCAL
FISHING COMMUNITY AROUND YES
LOTS OF BILLION FROM CURRENCY
TRANSFER BILITY CURRENTLY
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO BE CERTAIN
CERTAIN PERMITS- WHICH YOU KNOW
IT IF YOU WERE ALLOWED TO IN A
COMMUNITY GROUP COULD HOLD
THOSE PERMITS. IT COULD OPEN
THE DOOR FOR NEW ENTRANTS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT CAN'T AFFORD YOU
KNOW FIFTY TO SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOUR SHORT TERM AND OR-
OR- YOU KNOW FORTY TO NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLAR DENTURES
PROPERLY OR WHATEVER THE COST
MAY BE. SO IT COULD OPEN THE
DOOR ALLOW THE BABIES ARE BEING
USED TO OWN SCENARIOS MAYBE IT
WOULD JUST BE- YOU KNOW THAT
YOU RESET ON A LOTTERY SYSTEM.
BUT WHAT YOU KNOW WE'RE THE
MONETIZATION STRUCTURE MISSION
IS WORRIED DAYPARTS BUT- I
COULD SEE OTHER THERE ARE OTHER
PRODUCT LINES UP NOW BECAUSE
THERE ARE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT. WE COULD DO THIS AND I
THINK THE CRITICAL CRITICAL
PIECE OF IT WOULD HAVE TO BE TO
DESIGN. IT WITH. IN MY THIS
COMP. TO SET UP ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES FROM SO I'M GLAD I ASKED
YOU. DAVIS OVER LESS. AT SHERRY
FORMER EXIT RECORD THE MONOMER
MODERATE FISHERIES TRUSTING YOU
SO MUCH FOR MAY TAKE A RETURN
ON A GO TO MR. YOU RIGHT LOOK.
I THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
FRUSTRATION IN THE SECOND ROUND
JUST BEFORE THE VERY BLUNT IN
FULL DISCLOSURE WE WORK A LOT
TOGETHER ON. THE ISSUES
IMPACTING FISHERIES- BECAUSE OF
MY ROLE HERE ON THE COMMITTEE.
AND I THINK MY FRUSTRATION. IS
YOUR FRUSTRATION IS. I WIND
HUNT 10% SUPPORTER OF OFFSHORE
WIND. BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
LAST THINGS FOLKS THINK ABOUT.
IS THE FLEET IN PUTTING THE
FLEET AT THE TABLE AND ENSURING
THAT- IF THERE ARE IF THERE'S
GONNA BE ANY LOSS OF FISHING
GROUNDS. THAT THERE IS FAIR AND
JUST COMPENSATION FOR THAT- BUT
LOOK I DON'T WANT THE WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH SIR I THINK WHAT DO
YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO
BE TO GET ADDITIONAL SEATS AT
THE TABLE. ON VARYING
INITIATIVES THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. YEAH THANKS FOR
THAT QUESTION AND THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION. WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING FOR. YOU NO SENSE OF
CALL AREAS CAME OUT IN.
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
INTERJECT OURSELVES IN THE
PROCESS- AS YOU WELL KNOW. YEAH
THESE INTER GOVERNMENTAL TASK
FORCES THAT OPERATE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. THERE ARE
LIMITED TO GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES GOVERNMENTAL
PARTICIPATION. SO OUTSIDE
STAKEHOLDERS THE FISHING
INDUSTRY FOR EXAMPLE HAS HAS A
DIFFICULT TIME IN IN GETTING A
SEAT AT THAT TABLE. I'M REALLY
BEEN SUCCESSFUL WE JUST- WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THE PACIFIC
FISHERY MANAGEMENT COUNCIL. TO
ESTABLISH A MARINE PLANNING
COMMITTEE THAT THAT IS GOING TO
BE ADDRESSING ITEMS WITH
REGARDS TO OFFSHORE WIND IN
TERMS OF. ENSURING THAT THAT
FISHERIES DATA IS USED IN
INFORMING THE SITE SELECTION
PROCESS. WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL
BE USEFUL MOVING FORWARD. BUT
YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID THAT THAT
THE MORRO BAY CALLER THE DIABLO
CANYON CALL AREA. AND THE
HUMBLE CALL EVERYWHERE ALL
DONE. REALLY WITHOUT ANY
CONSIDERATION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE NEEDS OF THE LOCAL
FISHING COMMUNITIES THOSE
AREAS. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE-
QUITE WELL AWARE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER AREAS. YOU KNOW PRETTY
MUCH FROM MENDOCINO UP TO THE
OREGON BORDER THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED FOR ADDITIONAL
OFFSHORE WIND. SITING
PROCESSES. AND WE'RE JUST
HOPEFUL THAT YOU KNOW DURING
THE SITE SELECTION PROCESS WERE
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE. THAT
FISHERIES DATA IS USED TO HELP
INFORM THE PROCESS. IN THAT
WORD YEAH YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE AT THE TABLE AS OPPOSED
ON THE MENU. I HAD A 10% THANK
YOU SO MUCH RISK ON OR THIS.
QUICK ON THE- OF THE A CRIME
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE- THAT
THE PACIFIC FISHERY MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL'S BEEN WORKING ON HIS
STANCE IN QUITE SOME TIME. WHAT
DO YOU THINK THE STATE NEEDS TO
DO. TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE AND
SOLUTIONS TO THE LESSONS
LEARNED OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH MISS WRITINGS.
I THANK YOU MR CHAIR ON. I
THINK I'M LEARNING FROM THAT
COUNCIL EXPERIENCE NOT FEDERAL
EXPERIENCE- THE STATE CAN TAKE
AWAY SORT OF STUFF SOME PROCESS
RECOMMENDATIONS IN SALCOMBE
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK
ANYTHING THAT THE STATE HAS TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
STAKEHOLDERS- ONE OF OUR
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THAT
PROCESS WAS THE IMPORTANCE. OF
BRINGING IN STAKEHOLDERS NOT
ONLY ON FISHERMEN AND OTHER
FOLKS ASSOCIATED WITH
FISHERIES- BUT THINKING WIDER
THAN THAT- AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE AND ADD THEIR POINT
OF VIEW- OUTCOME LIES. I THINK
THE COUNCIL AT THIS POINT IS
ENTERTAINING A LOT OF REALLY
GOOD IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
OUR FEDERAL FISHERIES READY FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE ON A LOT OF THEM
ARE ABOUT HOW CAN WE MAKE OUR
SCIENCE AND DATA COLLECTION
ROBUST. THINKING ABOUT THE-
SUDDEN CHANGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING FROM CLIMATE CHANGE-
WHETHER THAT BE SOMETHING LIKE
THE WARM BLOG OR SOCIAL CHANGE
LIKE COATED- AND THEN THINKING
ABOUT ONE OF THE THINGS WE CAN
ACTUALLY DO FOR MANAGEMENT
WHETHER THAT BE SOMETHING LIKE-
REDOING OUR HARVESTING FOR
RULES AND THINKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONSIDERING.
CLIMATE AND REST- OR WHETHER IT
BE SOMETHING EVEN LIKE
THINKING. OKAY HOW DO WE
INCLUDE THE RIGHT FOLKS IN THE
ROOM WHEN WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THAT DO WE HAVE
THE CAPACITY IN OUR DEPARTMENT
TO HAVE KLEIN EXPERTS AND
ECOSYSTEM EXPERTS- SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD IDEAS
COMING I THINK THERE'S MORE TO
COME- AND- IT'S. GREAT THAT THE
STATE IS LEANING INTO THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FISH
CONSERVATION MANAGER FROM THOSE
CONCERT. I WANNA I FINALLY GO
TO MR HEATLEY WHO. HE AND SO
MANY OTHER. MERSHON
RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OIL SPILL MR HEALY
I WANNA GET YOUR TAKE DO YOU
FEEL THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS PREPARED TO
RESPOND- IN YOUR INITIAL
COMMENTS YOU SAID THAT WAS-
JOHNNY ON THE SPOT IN REGARDS A
RESPONSE BUT WHERE YOU'RE DEEP
CONCERN IS. LONG TERM IN THE
IMPACTS LONG TERM ON THE
ECONOMY AND ESPECIALLY- THE
FISHERMEN MR HEALY I WANT WORDS
IN HER MOUTH BUT I THINK WE'RE
YOUR DEEP CONCERN IS ENSURING
THAT THE STATE AND ALSO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A LONG
TERM PLANS TO HELP COMPENSATE
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
ECONOMICALLY DAMAGED BY THIS
BILL CORRECT MISTER HALEY. YES
DEFINITELY I THINK THE BIG
ROUGH FOR US DOWN HERE IS IT
OBVIOUSLY ARE YOU ALREADY KNOW
THAT IT WAS SAID IT STATED
EARLIER EARLIER IN THE WEEK
ARRIVES A LOT OF THIS DRIVER SO
LIVELY HOOD FROM LOBSTER
FISHING AND WHAT THAT MEANS
THAT HALF WHAT WE CATCH COMES
OUT THE FIRST FEW WEEKS OF THE
SEASON IN OUR AREA MUST PACIFIC
PLATE. SO IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN IF WE START
LATER IN THE YEAR WE'RE GONNA
ACTUALLY CASTLES LOSS OR SICK
GOOD GONE SOMEPLACE ALSO MIGHT
NOT EVEN WANT TO OFFER YOU GO
IN THE TRASH BUT- AS FAR AS-
OUR BIGGEST ROB WAS THE
COMMUNICATION DEFICIT. HAVING
HAVING AN OIL SPILL WE GOT A
BIT. HAVING A CLOSURE AND I
KNOW THAT IT WAS DYNAMIC IT WAS
MOVING IN FLORIDA. AS IT WAS
GOING BUT THERE WAS NO
COMMUNICATION TO THE ACTUAL
USERS IN THAT AREA. THERE
SHOULD BE SOME TYPE OF PROTOCOL
SET IN THE PLACE THAT THEY WERE
NOTIFIED AS QUICKLY AS ANYTHING
COULD BE. TRANSPIRED OR
INFORMATION SHOULD BE GIVEN I
MEAN IF THEY'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
HARBOR WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN IT.
THEY BROUGHT THE BOOM DOWN THAT
MORNING THEY PROBABLY DO
THEY'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
HARBOR THAT INFORMATION SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DISSEMINATED TO US SO
THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. NOT MOVE ARE TRAPPED IN THE
AREAS THAT WE LOSE THEM IN THE
SERVICE SINCE WE COULD NOT. GET
OUT OF THE HARBOR WAS A HARD
CLOSURE- WE'RE STILL WAITING.
ANALYSIS OF THE ANIMALS TO BE
ABLE TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
WHEN. REFER MY WE'RE GONNA OPEN
A LOT OF US ARE IN LIMBO
KNOWING NOT KNOWING WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO. WE START TRAPS IN THE
WATER THAT WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO MAINTAIN AND NOT LOSE- AS
FAR AS- I DON'T. KNOW HOW TO
ANSWER QUESTION BUT- YOU KNOW.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT IF YOU
HAVE ANOTHER GUN ASKED AGAIN A
DIFFERENT PART OF IT NO I
APPRECIATE THAT MR HEALY AND
AGAIN DO YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
TO IT MYSELF MR OPPENHEIM WHO
IS OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU I WANT TO
MAKE SURE. THAT YOU ARE GETTING
WHAT YOU NEED FLEET IS GETTING
WHAT YOU NEED THE RECREATIONAL
FISHERMEN ARE GETTING WHAT YOU
NEED REGARDING EVERY LONG TERM
RECOVERY ESPECIALLY IN THE
ECONOMICS OF IT AND AGAIN I
THINK YOU WERE AT THE POINT
FIRE FLOOD EARTHQUAKE FEDERAL
STATE GOVERNMENT COMING
UNIFIED- IN COMMAND TO BE ABLE
TO HELP COMPENSATE FOLKS WHO'VE
BEEN. ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED OR
LOST THEIR HOME EXCEPT RUSSIA I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE TO DO
THAT AGAIN AS WELL WE DO THAT
DURING I DO WHEN WE HAD THAT
THAT- COMMERCIAL CRAB SEASON IT
WAS CLOSED THAT IN THE AREA IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO I
PROMISE YOU WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER HEALY. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MISS WRITINGS MR
HE THE MIST- FORMER FELT- AS
WELL AS YOUR CONROY AT FOR
THEIR EXCELLENT TESTIMONY. ON
STRATEGIES TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES AND COASTAL
COMMUNITIES THRIVING WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAVE FOLKS THAT HAVE
STUCK WITH US HERE FOR THE
FORTY EIGHTH ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER
FISHERIES FORMER JUST TWO YEARS
AWAY FROM THE FIFTY DANIEL
AGAIN THANK YOU TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR STICKING
WITH US HERE TODAY AND-
ESPECIALLY DESCENDED AWAY SO
THINK YOU SENT AWAY SO. ONE
REMIND FOLKS THAT WERE CAMPED
WAYS TO COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THEY NEVER
OVERFLOW ROOM B. FOURTEEN AND
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE TO DO A FOLK OR
STANDING BY HE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TALK WITH THE COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY SO LET'S GET GOING
LET'S. TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM
FORTY ZERO THREE WE'VE KNOWN
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF CHECK
IN AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO ONE
IS IN ROME IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
THAT MEANS WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GET A PROVIDE A
COMMENT HERE'S THE PHONE NUMBER
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR TOLL FREE.
844-291-6364. MADAM MODERATOR
GOOD AFTERNOON MY THE
MODERATORS BUT- HANGING WITH.
FOR QUITE SOME TIME IN WELL
OVER. HOUR THINKING ABOUT
MODERATOR. FOR WORK THAT TURN
IT OVER TO YOU MADAM. I DID
ABLE DO ALL CALL FOR FOLKS
WHO'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. PUBLIC COMMENT TWO
MINUTES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
EACH. AMANDA MODERATOR THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
WHO ARE ON THE LINE THAT YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT MATTER
MODERATOR TURNED OVER TO YOU. I
THANK YOU- JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR OUR FIRST COMMENT. ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD AND CLEAR
GOOD AFTERNOON. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR THIS IS RICHARD JAMES
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO- BE A PRESENT- FIRST
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR YOUNG
OF THE YEAR- I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE ENVIRONMENT
CRITICAL TO ALL FISHERIES.
GUARDING SHELLFISH ON THE
CAPACITY OF THE LACK OF STAFF
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
TAMALES BAY GROWERS PAY ROUGHLY
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR RENT FOR ALL LEASES INTO
ALL DAY. TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE
OF THOSE GROWERS HAD REVENUES
OF TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
I THINK THAT'S UNTAPPED
RESOURCE THAT COULD BE USED TO
FUND. STAFFING MOST GROWERS IN
THE BAY HAVE STEPPED UP THEIR
BEST PRACTICES IN THE LOSING
LEFT HERE AND THERE. MORE
QUICKLY MORE QUICKLY RECOVERING
LOST HERE AND I'M THANKFUL FOR
THEM FOR THAT. ON THE CRAB. THE
OCEAN IN THE FISHERY ARE IN BIG
TROUBLE. MR CLASS I'M JEALOUS
OF YOUR A 100% RECOVERY OF WASH
HERE IN YOUR COASTAL REGION
CHILDREN DON'T TREAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH LOST HERE WASHING UP
EACH YEAR TO KEEP MANY PEOPLE
MYSELF INCLUDED. PICKING UP
ABANDONED. CRAB GEAR ALL OVER
THE BEACHES HERE. I CALLED A
CRAB- LAST YEAR A COMMERCIAL
CREDIT LAST YEAR THE NUMBER ON
THE ORANGE TRUCK TANK ABOUT A
WASHED. UP ON ONE OF OUR LOCAL
BEACHES I RECEIVED NO. REPLY
THE NO ACTION WAS TAKEN. NOT
MOVING FORWARD TO ABANDON
VESSELS. THE AMERICAN
CHALLENGER A HUNDRED FOOT-
COMMERCIAL VESSEL IS THE LATEST
OF MANY UNINSURED FOLKS TO SHOW
UP ALONG OUR COAST. IN A MATCH
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN SPENT
MILLIONS WASTED THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN SPENT HELPING YOU FOLKS
AND MILLIONS MORE GOING TO BE
SPENT TO FIX THAT AND GET THAT
BOAT OFF THE SHORE. A SIMPLE
NUMBER LEVIN HAS ALTERED E. D.
FIFTEEN THIRTY NINE TO ADDRESS
THE LACK OF INSURANCE AND
HOPEFULLY TO ALSO ADDRESS THE-
THE MYRIAD REGISTRATION OR LACK
OF REGISTRATION OF BOATS TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO TRACK THESE.
BOTH BOTH DEADLY CRASH ON OUR
SHORES PLEASE SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIFTY THIRTY NINE ALSO OFFERS
SUPPORT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
ADDRESS THE- THANK YOU OIL
SPILL LIABILITY TRUST FUND.
THAT WE NEED TO GET ACCESS TO.
VERY MUCH SO AMOS JAMES I GOT
SAY I MISSED JAMES IS A- MAN.
HAS BEEN IN SO MUCH OF HIS TIME
HIS EFFORT IS ENERGY TO BE TO
KEEP. THE BEACHES CLEARED IN
WEST MARIN I HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN MISTER
JAMES AND I JUST WANT TO.
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR HARD
WORK SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN TODAY IT MEANS A LOT
THANK YOU FOR HANGING WITH US.
DURING THIS HEARING TODAY ALL
RIGHT NOT A MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. GREAT THANK YOU AND
HAVE A REMINDER ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS- JEFF CHESTER THE GOT A
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR
AND SENIOR SCIENCE. SCIENTIST
AT OCEANIA WE HAVE- OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHING- WORKING GROUP. WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB EIGHTY-
CONGRADULATIONS TO- TO YOU-
MISTER SENATOR FOR THAT-
HELPFUL AND BY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- WE WANTED TO-
COMMENDED THE INDUSTRY AND THE
DEPARTMENT FOR. OTHER GRANT
PROGRAM DOES SEEM TO BE-
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFULIN
REDUCING WELL ENTANGLEMENTS THE
SHOULD BE. THIS IS RECOGNIZED
BY THE CONSERVATION COMMUNITY
AND SHOULD BE FURTHER
RECOGNIZING KNOWLEDGE BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS-
PARTICULARLY- KNOWLEDGE IN THE
INDUSTRY SURVEYS. OF THE
FUNDING BY THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL. TO GET KEY DATA TO
INFORM THE RAMP PROGRAM- UNDER
THE RAMP PROGRAM- WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN ALTERNATIVE GEARS
INCLUDING POP UP FISHING GEAR.
WE'RE MAKING SOME MICHAEL
THOUGHT PROGRESS IN MONTEREY
BAY AND HOPEFUL TO SUBMIT. YOUR
AUTHORIZATION PROPOSAL FOR
APPROVAL THIS SPRING. WE WANT
TO THANK THE OPC A NATIONAL
MARINE SANCTUARY FOUNDATION FOR
THEIR WORK AS WELL. THE
TRIALS. HOWEVER WE DO NOT
SUPPORT- A FLEET WIDE POP UP
YOUR ROPE WITH YOUR MANDATE- WE
DO SUPPORT AUTHORIZATION
HOWEVER SO THAT- FISHERMEN. CAN
CONTINUE TO FISH UNDER
INCREASING TANGLE AT RISK WHEN
IT'S ELEVATED- FOR THOSE
FISHERMEN WHO VOLUNTARILY
CHOOSE TO USE THAT PARTICULARLY
IN EXTENDING THE SPRING SEASON-
SO WE WE'RE- WE SEE TIME
RELEASE POPS UP POP UP HERE AS
A LOW COST ENTRY LEVEL APPROACH
TO PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES TO.
FISH AND AT THE BEGINNING OF AN
INCREMENTAL STEP WISE APPROACH
TO OUR INCREASE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES- WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORT FOR.
EXPERIMENTATION AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR- ISSUES TO
ACCESS AND TRIAL THIS TYPE OF%
GEAR- BECAUSE FISHERMEN
PARTICIPATION IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO THESE-
AUTHORIZATIONS- SO I THINK YEAH
WE ARE- WE DO REMAIN CONCERNED
OVER THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
DUNGENESS CRAB TASK. FORCE FOR
INCREASED SERVICE INTERVAL I
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO- WITH THE-
FOR TO A- IN. ADDITIONAL
MEASURES IMPROVE YOUR
ACCOUNTING AND YOUR
ACCOUNTABILITY. ALSO LAST WEEK
THANK YOU- TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR SUPPORT FOR ONLY- FUNDING
THE DRIFT GILLNET TRANSITION
PROGRAM. TO GATHER THESE
EFFORTS ARE REALLY TRULY MADE
CALIFORNIA LEADER AND WELL
INTERNAL STATE FISHING AND WE
COMMEND THE FISHING COMMUNITY
AND I WANT TO KNOW THAT THE
CONSERVATION COMMUNITY IT IS IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH THE
RECREATIONAL AND COMMERCIAL.
FISHERIES IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH JEFF
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN MATAMATA.
WRITER THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND LADIES AND
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND SOMEONE
JUST QUEUED UP THERE CURRENTLY
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
WANT TO REMIND FOLKS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CALLING
TODAY WE WELCOME. THAT THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE A
TOLL FREE NUMBER AT THAT YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CALL WE'RE
GONNA PUT THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER
UP ON THE SCREEN NOW. IN WE
WELCOME ANY AND ALL COMMENTS
HERE TODAY I THANK YOU SO MUCH
I MET A MODERATOR GONNA COME.
RIGHT BACK TO YOU. THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU AT SENATOR MCGUIRE THAT THE
JAMESTOWN CAN YOU HEAR ME HEY
MISTER STONE HOW YOU DOING. I'M
DOING VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
LISTENING TO ALL THESE GREAT
ISSUES- MY NAME IS JAMES BROWN
I AM THAT NOR CAL GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR REPRESENTING
OVER SIX HUNDRED PLUS GUIDE. NO
MORE JORDY UP ALL FISHING AND
HUNTING GUIDES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS OVER FIVE
THOUSAND RECREATIONAL SPORT
MEMBERS FROM THE NORTH COAST
ALL THE WAY DOWN. TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BELOW THE DELTA
I AM ALSO A TSMC STAMINA BY
THREE SUBCHANNEL COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND AS WELL AS I SAID ON
THE CALIFORNIA ADVISORY- GAC
PERFORMANCE YEAH LET ME TRY
OUT- AND I AM A SUPPORT
REPRESENTATIVE THERE AND I ALSO
IN THE CENTER COUNTY FISH AND
GAME COMMISSIONER. ALTHOUGH I
WILL NOT BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE LATTER THREE I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION. NOR CAL GUIDES
AND SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION
TODAY. I WANTED JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT- SOME REMARKABLE
THINGS HAVE TRANSPIRED BECAUSE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT
AND THAT IS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
WE'RE GONNA BE ANNOUNCING LATER
THAT WEEK- POSSIBLY YEAH. OUR
BOSS MADE THE EARLY WEEK
THEY'LL BE A RISK YOU'LL BE
RECEIVING A LETTER FROM A
COALITION OF THE ENTIRE SALMON
INDUSTRY FOR THE FIRST TIME
REPRESENTING COMMERCIAL CHARTER
AND ONE GUY DOES WELL AT SPORTS
AND RECREATIONAL MEMBERS. ON
BEHALF OF OUR SHORT AND LONG
TERM GOALS THAT WE CAN ALL GET
BEHIND. I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT THE TWENTY ONE SEASON FOR
THE INLAND FISHERY WAS
ABSOLUTELY DEAD MALL- ABAI
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF BY YOUR
BOARD- PREVIOUSLY THIS YEAR-
THAT WE EXPECTED BECAUSE OF THE
LOW FLOWS AND TEMPERATURES THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE VERY
LITTLE FISHING OPPORTUNITY AND
MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T. THE
AMERICAN RIVER AND FEATHER
RIVER WERE UNACCEPTABLE THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR FIVE DAY
SALMON SEASON. ALTHOUGH WE STOP
THEMOKAY FISHING OUT IN THE
OCEAN WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE
BETTER FISHING AND THEY STILL
NEED TO HAVE HIGH REMINDED.
WHEN WE WORK ON THE P. F. M. C.
SEVEN ADVISORY SUB PANEL WE
TAKE. THE ABUNDANCE OF WHAT'S
OUT THERE FOR THE YEAR AND NEXT
YEAR WAS THE UPPER HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND THEN WE HAVE.
WHAT WE NEED WHEN TUESDAY WHEN
I MINIMUM OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
AND IT'S BEEN VALLEY. AND THEN
WE DECIDED HOW MANY OF THOSE
FISH CAN BE HARVESTED AND WHAT
FISHER HARVESTABLE IN BETWEEN
THOSE NUMBERS. THOSE NUMBERS
ARE WAY WAY AND WELL BELOW WHAT
THEY WERE TWENTY YEARS AGO. WE
USED TO HAVE ABUNDANCE OF OVER
A MILLION CONSISTENTLY EVERY
SINGLE YEAR MILLION MILLION
FIVE MILLION TO. IT WAS. A POOR
FISHERY TO WHAT I UNDER A
MILLION. AND NOW WE CAN
CERTAINLY SEE THE NORM OF
ABUNDANCE AND MAC TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHICH LEADS ME TO MY
LAST MY NEXT COMMENT. WHICH IS
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO LEGALLY MR.
GOING LATER THIS WEEK. AND THAT
IS THAT. THE INDUSTRY NEEDS
SUPPORT OUR HATCHERY INCREASES
WHETHER THAT'S THROUGH
LEGISLATION HOPEFULLY YOUR
OFFICE OR ANOTHER OFFICE. WE
HAVE TO DOUBLE IF NOT TRIPLE
HATCHERY PRODUCTION IMMEDIATELY
FOR SHORT TERM GOALS. AS YOU
HEARD FROM COMMERCIAL SPECIALLY
GEORGE BRADSHAW THE PRESIDENT
OF PCF BANK. WE ARE ENGAGED IN
RIGHT MORE PROGRAM HYBRID
PROGRAM WHICH WE WANT TO SEE
OUR HATCHERY GAME. IF THE BEST
SHORT TERM GOAL THAT WE CAN DO
AT THE LOWEST AVAILABLE **** WE
DOUBLE OUR PRODUCTION. WE THEN
ONCE THE FISH REACH AROUND FIVE
HUNDRED PER POUND WE RELEASE
APPLICATION IN ONE IN RIVER. TO
START RE POPULATING OUR NATURAL
SPONSORS THAT HAVE BEEN LOST.
DUE TO WATER MISMANAGEMENT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE THE ROUTE. AND
THEREFORE WE CAN KEEP THAT THE
REMAINING 50% OF THE CASH
RAISED IN THE SMALL. ACCORDING
TO CURRENT HATCHERY OPERATION.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS GONNA BE
THE BEST PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT PARENTAL
BASED TAGGING P. B. T. FOR THE
FUTURE WHAT YOU HEARD FROM MR
MCMAHON AT. WHICH OUR
ORGANIZATION IS ALSO INVOLVED
WITH QUITE A COLEMAN NATIONAL
FISH HATCHERY WITH THIS YEAR'S.
OPTION GIVEN THE SAGGING FOR
THE FIRST TIME ON THE WEST
COAST IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THESE
NEWER IDEAS. AND NATURAL
PRODUCTION INCREASE UP TO KEEP
DOING THAT. SO SORRY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A STONE
I'M REALLY REALLY GRATEFUL YOU
CALLED IN AND NOT AT ALL.
TRYING TO BE PUSHY WE JUST.
THAT WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
TIME LIMIT AND I DO APOLOGIZE
THANK YOU- AND WE NEED TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MR STONE FOR HIS.
INCREDIBLE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF SO MANY IN THE STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SIR STONE FOR
CALLING IN IT'S REALLY GOOD TO
HEAR YOUR VOICE TODAY HAPPY
HOLIDAYS TO YOU. LET'S. GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER MADAME
MODERATOR. OKAY WE HAVE A
NUMBER SIX CALLS- HI MY NAME IS
AMY COLOGNE AND I RATHER TELL
YOU OVER MY TEACHING EXPERIENCE
OR JUST LIKE TO REVIEW THE-
ISSUE PRESERVING FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT COUNCILS- SAM AND
HABITAT PROTECTION. WELL IF YOU
HELP MIGHT HELP GIVE YOU SOME
CARDS TO PLAY GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THERE SHOULD BE NO
NET LOSS IN THE PRODUCTIVE
CAPACITY OF ANY MARINE ESTUARY
IN OUR FRESH WATER HABITAT FOR
SALMON. THIS IS EXAMINED SHE'LL
BE ASSURED CO EQUAL TREATMENT
WITH OTHER PROPERTIES OF THE
WATER AND LAND RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. THERE
SHOULD BE NO VIGOROUS FFORTS
BY RESPONSIBLE PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO RESTORE AND STRENGTHEN
SALMON STOCKS WE SHALL BE.
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATORY
AGENCY SHOULD BE STRIPPED AND
REQUIRING THE BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AVAILABLE FOR TIMBER
HARVEST MINING WATER
DEVELOPMENT AGRICULTURE AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES UNDER THEIR
CONTROL THAT CAN HAVE ADVERSE
EFFECT ON SALMON AND LASTLY.
WATER DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
SHOULD BE REVIEWED AND
UNDERTAKEN A COMPREHENSIVE OR
PROGRAMMATIC BASIS IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY AND ELIMINATE HIM
MOTIVE OR SYNERGISTIC IMPACTS
IN DRAINAGES WERE SALMON
SPAWNING REAR. THANK YOU THE
CORNER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU HANGING WITH US
TODAY I KNOW THAT WE WENT LONG
SO IT MEANS A LOT THAT YOU
STUCK WITH US THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A CROWN FOR CALLING IN LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
AND A MODERATOR. BY NUMBER
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS DAVID GOLDENBERG
MANAGER OF THE CALIFORNIA SEA
URCHIN COMMISSION AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA SEVEN CAMPBELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK. TO- THESE
FIERCE INDUSTRY HAS THE- TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PASTRY- PROFESSOR THAT'S COMING
THROUGH THE PACIFIC STATE BUT
THERE'S- BUT RIGHT BEHIND THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT- HAVE A LETTER SENT
TO THE- THE FEDERAL GOVERMENT
FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
DISASTER AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE LETTER- IS SITTING IN
THE- GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WE ASK
THAT YOU- DO WHAT YOU CAN TO
SEE IF THE GOVERNOR AND- FIND
OUT THAT LETTER AND SEND IT OFF
TO THE DIRECTOR OF THE COMMERCE
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE- AND
SECONDLY THE- RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY COUNCIL- WE ARE
GOING TO BE STEPPING UP TO.
HELP WITH THE DELIVERY OF THE
USDA BLOCK GRANT FOR SEAFOOD
PROCESSORS THIS IS FOR- I'M-
THE BURSTING OF PEOPLE PROCESS
FOR A CALL THAT EXPENSES. IT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY- THE
DEPARTMENT- LOSES IS STRETCHED
TO THE LIMIT AND THAT THE STATE
AGENCY WE'RE NOT STEP UP TO
SUPPORT OF. THE DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO THE COMPANY DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN AGRICULTURE WHICH WERE
ORGANIZED UNDER. TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE GRANT TO RELEASE THOSE
FUNDS AND THEN PAY FOR COVERED
EXPENSES SO WE WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE COALITION. YOU COULD-
SENATE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TRYING. AND THE LIVE THOSE FIVE
OUT INJURY THERE IS A MUCH
NEEDED. MR GOLDBERG I WAS JUST
CHECKING NOTICE TALKING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR CALL FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY OF SO MANY- WE
WILL. GET BACK TO YOU I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONVERSATION
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
ISSUE- AND WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU ON THIS AS WELL I KNOW
OPPENHEIM. RT CONSULTANT IS
ALSO WATCHING YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT I TOUCH BASE WITH HIM
AND- WE'LL CIRCLE BACK WITH
YOU. NEXT WEEK ON A POTENTIAL
LETTER ON THAT ADDITIONAL
DISASTER REQUEST SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A CONVERT FOR
CALLING IN TODAY. AT THE TO GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER MADE A
MODERATE. ONCE AGAIN WE ARE ONE
OF THEM ZERO FOR COMMENTS WE
HAVE NO OTHER THANK YOU AT THE
TIME. ALL RIGHT THIS IS GONNA
BE OUR LAST CALL FOR A CALLERS
FOR A FORTIETH ANNUAL IZZY
GREATER FISHERIES FORM IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY WE WELCOME YOU OF COURSE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR TOLL FREE
844-291-6364 THIS IS GONNA BE
OUR LAST CALL. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON OUR FORTY EIGHTH
ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER FISHERIES
FORM THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE THANK
YOU AGAIN ALL OF YOU OF IT
CONTINUED TO STAY TUNED INTO
THIS AT HEARING. THAT A
MODERATOR LET'S DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN THE
QUEUE- WE ARE ONE THEN ZERO FOR
COMMENT AND WE DO HAVE THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CENTER MCGUIRE MY NAME IS BOB
ANGLES FROM THE BOARD MEMBER
THAT CALLED A PASSIONATE SO
SESSION AN OLDER HALF MOON BAY
SPORTFISHING. I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
EVERYBODY HERE WHICH I'M SURE
WE ALL PRETTY WILL KNOW. THAT
THERE'S A THERE'S A BIG A
FREIGHT TRAIN COMING OUR
DIRECTION HERE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THAT SALMON. WHEN THERE'S A
LOWER BOUNDARY SAMBAR
INDEPENDENT CHARTER BOATS AS
WELL DOES EVERYBODY ELSE BUT WE
HAVE. A RAW. FISH THAT ARE
BEING- OVER. IN THE- BOX TO MY
IT DOES EVERYBODY ELSE. ALL THE
SAME BOAT HERE SO TO SPEAK. BUT
THE TRAIN COMING DOWN THE HILL
WITH NO BRAKES ON IT. RIGHT NOW
IT IS THE- CARBS SITUATION.
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
I'M SURE WE PROBABLY HEARD
ABOUT THIS BUT THEY GOT THE
ENGINES NOW THERE THERE ARE
REQUIRED HAS. HAS WRITTEN THEM
THIS NOT FINAL YET BUT- AS AS
IT'S WRITTEN RIGHT NOW. IF WE
HAVE TO PUT THE CHAIR FOR
ENGINES OF THE BOATS WELL THEY
DON'T MAKE THEM. THEY'LL MAKE
UP FOR THE SIZE OF OUR BOATS.
AND THERE ARE THEY HAVE A FIRE
HAZARD. AND EVEN THE AIRPORT
ITSELF SAID WELL YOU'VE GOT A
WOODEN BOAT OR FIBERGLASS BOAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE IT
OUT OF SERVICE AND BUILD A
BRAND NEW BOTH OUT OF STEEL TO
MAKE IT SO COMPLEX COMPLIES. SO
THAT. THIS REALLY EVERYBODY IN
THEIR STORES AND I ONLY GOT TWO
MINUTES YOU'RE SO FAR FROM THE
CHARTER BOAT SIDE. YOU KNOW IT
IT IT REALLY AFFECTS WHAT WE DO
GET BACK TO THE COMMUNITY WE
WANT. WE ARE PLATFORM TO TAKE
OUT PEOPLE FICTION THAT CAN'T
GO ON THEIR OWN DON'T HAVE
THEIR OWN BOAT. WE TAKE ALL THE
AWFUL LOT OF KIDS WE TAKEN FROM
FREE. THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS
OF KIDS ARE TAKEN OUT EVERY
YEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S A LOT OF
PROGRAMS THAT THAT HELP PAY FOR
THAT. BUT THEY'RE THE ONES ARE
GONNA LOSE HERE I MEAN OWNERS
AND OPERATORS YES AND THEIR
FAMILIES THEY'RE GONNA HURT
THEY GOT TO GET RID OF THEIR
BOAT. AND I'M GOING TO GO OUT
OF BUSINESS BUT THE REALLY ONES
ARE HURT THE MOST. ARE THE KIDS
IN THE FUTURE. BUT THE FIRST
CHANCE THEY GET. MAYBE C. THAT
C. O. TO MAYBE SEE THAT WAY.
AND GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
ON A BOAT MAYBE OPEN THE RIGHTS
FOR THE FUTURE. HELLO THANK YOU
BOB MY PRIVATE PROPERTY THAT'S
WHAT I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
I'M WE LOVE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND YET YOU KNOW WE DID
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND WE THAT LED THIS LETTER WE
HAD OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH WERE
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR WHO
SIGNED ON TO THIS LETTER. OUR
DEEP CONCERN RELATED TO THESE
POTENTIAL- NEW RULES AND RAGS
BUT WE FORMALLY REQUESTED- THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
WORKING GROUP OF PIES ON THIS
IMPLEMENTATION ESPECIALLY IN
RECREATIONAL. WATERCRAFT AT FOR
THOSE RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN AT
THIS WOULD BE A DEATH KNELL OF
THE INDUSTRY AND I'M JUST GOING
TO BE CANDID HERE TODAY THERE
IS NO ALTERNATIVE- ENGINE THAT
THE INDUSTRY CAN GO TO. AT THIS
POINT IN TIME RIGHT SO I DID
HAVE A MEETING SCHEDULED WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
LAST WEEK THEY HAD TO POSTPONE
WHICH I TOTALLY GET IT- IN MY
LAP WE HAVE ANOTHER TIME SET UP
IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO. BOB
WE'D BE HAPPY TO KEEP YOU IN
CONTACT AND- ON THAT ONE AND
AFTER I MEET WITH CAR BECAUSE I
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN ALL RIGHT LAST CALLMADAM
MODERATOR- FOR R. FORTY DANIELS
A GREATER. FISHERIES FORM WITH
THE LAST CALL. SORRY IT'S IN
THE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY IN Q. AS
OF RIGHT NOW YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER MODERATOR GREAT JOB
TODAY ALWAYS A PLEASURE WORKING
WITH YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE WE
WANT TO SAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TUNING IN TODAY ARE FORTY
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT AND YOU'LL
SEE GREATER FISHERIES FORM.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO THEN GATHER
NEXT YEAR FOR OUR ANNUAL
SEAFOOD RECEPTION. EVERYBODY
KNOCK ON WOOD FOR THAT- WE HAVE
THE BIG HOPE FOR AT THIS YEAR'S
DUNGENESS CRAB SEASON. THIS
DUNGEONS CORRECTLY- IT NEEDS A
BREAK- AND WE CAN'T WAIT TO GET
THEM OUT OF THE WATER. AGAIN
GET THEM OUT ON THE WATER THE
LAST PIECE OF SAY IS THIS- THE
DEEP CONCERN THAT WE HAVE. IN
REGARDS IN PARTICULAR IN
REGARDS TO THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
WATERSHED. 80% OF THOSE ACHES
THAT LEGALLY COOKED BECAUSE OF
HIGH TEMPERATURES. ONLY 2% OF
OUTLINING OUT MIGRATING
JUVENILES AND MADE IT THIS YEAR
IT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. AND
WE PROMISE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
ON THIS- AND CAN KEEP FIGHTING
WITH SO MANY CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS- ON ALL ISSUES
OF. SALMON IN KEEP THEM
THRIVING HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU THINK YOU
SAID IT WAS A THANK YOU TO KNOW
OPPENHEIM. WHO IS OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT I WAS A THANK YOU TO
MICHAEL KENNEDY FOR ALL AT HIS
WORK AND OF COURSE. I DO JERIT
INTO PADDY- WHO ARE BEHIND THE
SCENES IS WELL INTO OUR
SERGEANTS AND INTO OUR
TECHNICAL TEAM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR MAKING THE FORTY
EIGHTH ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER
FISHERIES FORM A FANTASTIC
SUCCESS. THIS MEETING OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE. WILL BE
ADJOURNING IN AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO SENATOR WAY SO AS
WELL. THANK. YOU SO MUCH HAPPY
HOLIDAYS EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU.